welcome to this new full course on Cloud
devops by simply learn devops or
development and operations is a
collaborative approach to software
development that aims to improve
efficiency and quality by bringing
together developers and operations team
as the demand for it professionals
continues to grow the demand for
individuals with developed skills is
also on the rise with the right skills
and experience a career in devops can
offer significant salary and growth
potential whether you are just starting
out in the field or looking to advance
your career devops provides a wide range
of opportunities to make an impact on
complex technology projects while
learning new skills and earning a
competitive salary as a devops
professional you will have the chance to
work on Cutting Edge projects
collaborate with talented teams and gain
valuable experience that can open up
even more opportunities for growth and
advancement in the future and now just a
quick info for you if you want to
upskill yourself master devop skills and
land your dream job or or grow in your
career then you must explore simply
learn's cohort of various devops program
simply learn offers various
certification and postgraduate program
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like ctech
and Google Cloud through our courses you
will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like devs
methodology deployment automation cicd
Pipeline and over a dozen others and
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
inp top TI product companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a DS
role as a fresher or moved onto a higher
paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a devops program
that fits your experience and areas of
interest when I go through a number of
key elements today the first two will be
reviewing models that you're already
already probably using for delivering
Solutions into your company and the most
popular one is waterfall followed by
agile then we'll look at devops and how
devops differs from the two models and
how it also borrows and leverages the
best of those models we'll go through
each of the phases that are used in
typical devops delivery and then the
tools used within those phases to really
improve the efficiencies within devops
finally we'll summarize the advantages
that devops brings to you and your teams
so let's go through waterfall so
waterfall is a traditional delivery
model that's been used for many decades
for delivering Solutions not just IT
solutions and digital Solutions but even
way before that it has its history it
goes back to World War II so waterfall
is a model that is used to capture
requirements and then Cascade each key
deliverable through a series of
different stage Gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage Gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planing so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution they build out
their applications they build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the code you'll do
manual testing you do UI testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks now the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage Gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requir ments from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for 6 months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expensive and it's very time
consuming also if you spend weeks and
months away from your client and you
deliver a solution that they are only
just getting to see after you spend a
lot of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or are not implemented correctly or
lead to just general unhappiness the
challenge you then have is if you want
to add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes and then you go back
and you have to start your programming
and you have to then start your testing
process again and just you're really
adding in lots of additional time into
the project so using waterful model
companies have soon come to realize that
you know the clients just aren't able to
get their feedback in quickly
effectively it's very expensive to make
changes once the teams have started
working and the requirement in today's
digital world is that Solutions simply
must be delivered faster and this has
led for a specific change in agile and
we start implementing the agile model so
the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the the client with the
requirements faster and the client is
able to then send the requirements back
to the programmer with feedback this
allows us to create what we call a
feedback loop where we're able to get
information to the client and the client
can get back to the development team
much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about 2 weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the client the changes
that have happened but we do all of this
in a much tighter cycle that we call a
Sprint and that typically a Sprint will
last for about 2 weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to to you as a team
to decide how long you want to actually
run a Sprint but typically it's 2 weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that Loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of Sprint 2 and the client says
hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for Sprint 3
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to Agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and they may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple Sprints but when you go through
the Sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually implement M successfully into
their Sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your Sprint again
it's a twoe activity you meet every
single day to with the actual Sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a Sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each Sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a WF project
to be completed however there are also
some distinct disadvantages the product
itself really doesn't get tested in a
production environment it's only being
tested on the developer computers and
it's really hard when you're actually
running agile for the Sprint team to
actually build out a solution easily and
effectively on their computers to mimic
the production environment and the
developers and the operations team are
running in separate silos so you have
your development team running their
Sprint and actually working to build out
the features but then when they're done
at the end of their Sprint and they want
to do a release they kind of fling it
over the wall at the operations team and
then it's the operations team job to
actually install the software and make
sure that the environment is running in
a stable fashion that is really
difficult to do when you have the two
teams really not working together so
here we have is a breakdown of that
process with the developers submitting
their work to the operations team for
deployment and then the operations team
may submit their work to the production
servers but what if there is an error
what if there was a setup configuration
error with the developer test
environment that doesn't match the
production environment there may be a
dependency that isn't there there may be
a link to an API that doesn't exist in
production and so you have these
challenges that the operations team are
constantly faced with and their
challenge is that they don't know how
the code works so this is where devops
really comes in and let's dig into how
devops which is developers and operators
working together is the key for
successful continuous delivery so devops
is is an evolution of the agile model
the agile model really is great for
Gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
Solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the Ops Team and the
dev team and so with Dev Ops what we're
doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that is based on data so let's step
through the different phases of a devops
team so typically you'll see that the
devops team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
Agile and what I'd like to point out at
time is that again agile and devops are
very closely related that agile and
devops are closely related delivery
models that you can use with devops it's
really just extending that model with
the key phases that we have here so
let's step through each of these key
phases so the first phase is planning
and this is where we actually sit down
with a business team and we go through
and understand what their goals are the
second stage is as you can imagine and
this is where it's all very similar to
Agile is that the coders actually start
coding and but they typically they'll
start using tools such as git which is a
distributed Version Control software it
makes it easier for developers to all be
working on the same code base rather
than big of the code that is rather than
them working on bits of the code that
they are responsible for so the goal
with using tools such as git is that
each developer always has the current
and latest version of the code you then
use tools such as mavin and gradal as a
way to consistently build out your
environment and then we also use tools
to actually automate our testing now
what's interesting is when we use tools
like selenium and junit is that we're
moving into into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another Point here
is that the tools that we're listing
here these are all open-source tools
these are tools that any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment of code into
the production environments and then
finally tools such as anible and Chef
will actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment
so you can zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things I want to point out is
that these tools are open-source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
it's quite likely that you're already
using some of these tools today you may
already be using Jenkins you may already
be using git but some of the other tools
really help you create a fully
scriptable environment so that you can
actually start scripting out your entire
devops tool set this really helps when
it comes to speeding up your delivery
because the more you can actually script
out of the work that you're doing the
more effective you can be at running
automation against those scripts and the
more effective you can be at having a
consistent experience so let's step
through this devops process so we go
through and we have our continuous
delivery which is our plan code build
and test environment so what happens if
you want to make a release well the
first thing you want to do is send out
your files to the build environment and
you want to be able to test the code
that you've been created because we're
scripting everything in our code from
the actual unit testing being done to
the all the way through to the
production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the the scripting test it
can then be deployed and once it's out
to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases to Agile
which is 2 weeks or 4 weeks depending on
your Sprint Cadence to where you are
today with devops where you can actually
be doing multiple releases every single
day so there are some significant
advantages and there are companies out
there that are really zeroing in on
those advantages if we take any one of
these companies such as Google Google
any given day will actually process 50
to 100 new releases on their website
through their Dev Ops teams in fact they
have some great videos on YouTube that
you can find out on how their devop
teams work Netflix is also a similar
environment now what's interesting with
Netflix is that Netflix have really
fully embraced Dev Ops within their
development team and so they have a
devops team and Netflix is a completely
digital company so they have software on
phones on Smart TVs on computers and on
websites interestingly though the devops
team for Netflix is only 70 people and
when you consider that a third of all
internet traffic on any given day is
from Netflix it's really a reflection on
how effective devops can be when you can
actually manage that entire business
with just 70 people so there are some
key advantages that devops has it's the
actual time to create and deliverer
software is dramatically reduced
particularly compared to Waterfall
complexity of maintenance is also
reduced because you're automating and
scripting out your entire environment uh
you're improving the communication
between all your teams so teams don't
feel like they're in separate silos but
that are actually working cohesively
together and that there is continuous
integration and continuous delivery so
that your consumer your customer is
constantly being delighted if you're
into the tech industry or just curious
about the role of devops in software
development you have come to the right
place so what exactly is devops in
simple terms it's a set of practices and
tools that help developers and
operational team work better together
releasing software fast with higher
quality at its core devops is about
breaking down barriers between
development and operations and creating
a culture of collaboration that focuses
on delivering value to customers as
quickly and efficiently as possible of
course this is a vast oversimplification
and there are many different aspects to
devops that we could spend hards diving
into but for now let's focus on some of
the key responsibilities of a devops
engineer who is the person responsible
for implementing and overseeing devops
practices and processes but before we
begin if you're new to the channel and
haven't subscribed already consider
getting subscribed to Simply learn to
stay updated with all the latest
Technologies and with that Bell icon to
never miss an update from us having said
that the demand for devops professionals
has overgrown in recent years as more
and more companies adapt Dews practices
to improve their software development
and delivery processes so are you ready
to advance your professional career to
the next level taking our stepbystep
simply learns postgraduate program in
devops in collaboration with IBM will
help you start your devops journey that
will prepare you for the devops engineer
role in order to match your skills with
market demand this devops training
program is designed in collaboration
with Caltech ctme our Cutting Edge
Blended learning combines live online
devop certification classes with
interactive labs to give you practical
experience this postgraduate program
covers topics including git GitHub
Docker cicd practices using genkins
kubernets and much more so what else can
you expect from this program well this
deop training program will cover skills
like devops methodology continuous
integration devops on cloud deployment
Automation and you'll also get hands-on
experience with the latest tools and
techniques including terraform Maven
asemble junkins Docker junit and many
more this program will cover industry
projects like dockerizing Junkin
pipeline deploy angular application and
Docker container branching development
model and many more exciting projects so
if you're looking to pursue a career as
a devops engineer and acquire skills
that will prepare you for your job
consider enrolling in this intensive
training program we will leave the link
in the description box below make sure
you check that out so without any
further Ado let's get started with
today's
topic firstly let us understand what is
devops now devops is a software
development approach that emphasizes
collaboration Automation and
communication between development and
operations team it aims to streamline
the entire software development life
cycle by integrating and optimizing
processes tools and methodologies it
encourages a culture of shared
responsibility where developers and
operations team work together closely
throughout the entire software
development life cycle from planning and
coding to testing deployment and
monitoring now the question is who is a
devops engineer well you got it right a
devops engineer is a professional who
combines software development expertise
with operations knowledge to facilitate
collaboration steamline processes and
improve software delivery and
infrastructure management within an
organization a deop engineer role is to
bridge the gap between development and
operations team enabling efficient and
reliable software development and
deployment
practices but the question is how to
become a devops engineer what are the
skills that you need to possess to
become a good devops engineer well a
devops engineer possess a wide range of
skills including Proficiency in
scripting and programming languages
knowledge of various tools and
Technologies expertise in system
administration Cloud platforms and
conization Technologies as well as
strong problem solving in and
communication skills are necessary
firstly having a good coding knowledge
well tools like Confluence jira git
these tools can support and enhance
collaboration and project management
within a devops environment next having
a good knowledge on deployment tools are
also necessary now tools like dcos
provides alization capabilities for
distributed applications Docker enables
containerization for consistent and
scalable deployments and AWS offers a
broad range of cloud services for
infrastructure provisioning scalability
and manage services next you need to
have a good knowledge on operations
tools as well now chef and anemal focus
on infrastructure Automation and
configuration management while cuber net
specializes in container oration and
management these tools are utilized in
devops to automate various aspects of
software development life cycles
including infrastructure provisioning
configuration management application
deployment and scaling moving ahead you
need to have a strong grip on monitoring
tools nagios Splunk and data dog are
three commonly used tools in the field
of monitoring and observability now each
tool serves a specific purpose in
monitoring and managing system and
applications nagio specializes in
infrastructure and application
monitoring spun focuses on log analysis
and data visualization data do provides
comprehensive monitoring and analytic
capabilities in Cloud environments these
tools play a crucial role in maintaining
the health and performance of systems
and applications moving ahead you need
to have a good knowledge on Jenkins and
cod ship now genkin and C chips are both
essential Tools in DEA practices genkins
is a flexible and extensible automation
server that supports continuous
integration testing and deployment on
the other hand cor ship is a cloud-based
cicd platform that offers Simplicity and
ease of use particularly for cloud
native applications both these tools
contribute to improving development
productivity and code quality and
finally having a good knowledge on
testing tools like selenium junit are
necessary for a doops engineer junit is
primarily focused on unit testing and
automated testing of java code while
selenium is geared towards functional
testing and automation of web
applications both these tools play
critical roles in devops workflow
contributing to faster feedback Cycles
improved code quality and Reliable
Software releases so these are some of
the main and important skills that you
need to possess as a doops engineer
before moving ahead let's take a minute
and listen to the experiences of our
Learners who have enrolled in the devops
pgp program which has proven to be
highly beneficial for many aspiring
engineers and professionals leading them
to achieve New Heights in the field of
devops I started my It Journey with
Accenture 3 years ago I joined there as
a cloud architect there I worked with
AWS and Azure Technologies and looking
for higher paying jobs and devops seemed
the right career choice so I decided to
go with the post graduate programing
devops in collaboration with Caltech
ctme the course was divided into modules
and we had
assignments I was really impressed by
how many job interviews I landed after I
added the certification to my portfolio
and now I am earning 40% more than my
previous job it didn't only boost my
career but also my
confidence well now comes the main part
what exactly are the day-to-day roles
and responsibilities of a devops
engineer now a devops engineer play a
crucial role in Bridging the Gap between
development and operations team as we
discussed earlier so here are some of
the top five roles and responsibilities
of a doops engineer in detail first on
the list we have collaboration and
communication now deop engineer fa State
effective communication and
collaboration with development and
operations team they actively
participate in meetings and discussions
to align goals and expectations now as a
devops engineer you need to engage in
regular meetings and discussions regular
engagement ensures that they are up to
date with ongoing projects challenges
and goals enabling them to better align
their efforts and contribute effectively
regular engagement ensures that they are
up to date with ongoing projects
challenges and goals enabling them to
better align their efforts and
contribute effectively actively listen
and understand the requirement concerns
and feedback now when engaging with
development and operations team day offs
Engineers practice active listening they
pay close attention to the requirements
concerns and feedback expressed by team
members from both the sides by
understanding their perspectives pain
points and suggestions doops Engineers
can better assess the needs of their
teams and collaborate to find suitable
Solutions facilitate effective
communication channels now devops
Engineers take the initiative to
establish and maintain effective
communication within the organization
this often involves settling up
dedicated chat platforms like slack
Microsoft teams or collaboration tools
like jira to Foster better collaboration
and ensure that information flows
smoothly between the teams and finally
encourage cause functional collaboration
now deop Engineers recognize the the
value of cross functional collaboration
and knowledge sharing among the team
members they actively encourage them
from development and operation team to
collaborate exchange ideas and share
their expertise second on the list we
have infrastructure Automation and
configuration management now deop
Engineers focus on automating
infrastructure provisioning and managing
configurations using certain tools they
Define infrastructure as code enabling
efficient deployment and scaling of
resources now as a devops engineer you
have to identify the infrastructure
requirements effectively now de off
Engineers work closely with development
teams to understand the infrastructure
requirements of the application this
involves analyzing the needs of
applications in terms of Computer
Resources Storage security networking
and scalability by gathering all these
requirements devops engineer can ensure
that infrastructure is provisioned and
configured to meet the application
specific need and future growth write
infrastructure automation scripts and
templates now once the infrastructure
requirements are ID identified devops
Engineers use automation tools and
techniques to define the desired state
of infrastructure components the right
scripts and templates that specify how
the infrastructure should be provisioned
configured and managed automate the
provisioning configuration and
management of servers well deop
Engineers leverage infrastructure as
code or in short IAC principles to
automate the provisioning configuration
and management of servers networks and
other infrastructure resources they use
tools like anmol chef puppet to automate
the deployment and configuration of
infrastructure components and finally
regularly update infrastructure code now
devops engineer uses Version Control
Systems like git to track changes
collaborate with team members and manage
different versions of infrastructure
code by regularly updating and
versioning infrastructure code devops
Engineers can easily track and rever
changes whenever necessary now third on
the list we have continuous integration
and continuous deployment or cicd in
short now de Engineers are responsible
for establishing and maintaining cicd
pipelines which enable developers to
integrate code changes seamlessly and
deploy applications
rapidly so for that they have to set up
a version control system now Version
Control System like G play a crucial
role in devops by providing a
centralized repository for managing code
and tracking changes setting up a
Version Control System involves creating
a repository initializing it with a code
and defining branching and merging
strategies
configure a built server now a built
server automates the process of
compiling testing and packaging
application code tools like genkin and
gitlab cicd allows you to Define build
pipelines that specify the steps to be
executed these pipelines typically
involve tasks such as pulling code from
repository compiling source code
generating artifacts and packaging the
application next automate the deployment
process now automation of the deployment
process is CR crucial for achieving
rapid and consistent software releases
containerization tools like Docker
provide a lightweight and portable way
to package application and the
dependencies docker containers can be
created and deployed consistently across
different environments ensuring
consistency between development testing
and production Define and enforce
quality Gates and monitor cicd kpis
quality Gates ensure that the code meets
predefined quality standards before it
is promoted to the next stage of the
cicd pipeline automated testing
including unit test integrated test and
end to end test integration test and end
to end test help catch bugs and validate
the functionality of the managing
applications and finally measuring kpis
of the cicd pipeline provide insights
into it performance and help identify
areas for improvement well next we have
monitoring and performance optimization
now deop Engineers monitor system
performance identify and optimize the
infrastructure and application Stacks
whenever necessary they Implement
monitoring tools to collect and analyze
metrics logs and traces so for that
select and configure monitoring tools
now monitoring tools like Prometheus or
graph can be used to collect and
visualize these metrics allowing teams
to identify bottlenecks or optimize
processes and enhance the overall
efficiency of the cicd
pipeline also they have to collaborate
with development and operations team to
fine tune application
performance so continuously optimizing
the infrastructure which will ensure
High availability scalability and
reliability of that application and
finally we have security and compliance
now do engineers play a critical role in
implementing security measures and
ensuring compliance with industry
standards and regulations they work
closely with security teams to Define
and Implement security controls
throughout the software delivery
pipeline so they have to continuously
collaborate with the security teams to
identify and Define security
requirements and controls and Implement
security measures such as vulnerability
scan planning access management and
secure configuration they have to
continuously integrate security testing
and code analysis into the cicd pipeline
and monitor for any sort of potential
security risk or breaches and respond
promptly to mitigate any identified
vulnerabilities so these were some of
the main or top five roles and
responsibilities of a devops engineer I
hope you understood that talking about
the salary figures of a senior devops
engor according to glasto a senior
devops engineer working in the United
States earns a whooping salary of
17836 the same senior devops engineer in
India earns 18 lakh rupees
annually to sum it up as you progress
from entry level to mid-level and
eventually to experience devop engineer
your roles and responsibilities evolve
significantly each level presents unique
challenges and opportunities for growth
all contributing to your journey as a
successful full devops professional so
excited about the opportunities devops
offers great now let's talk about the
skills you will need to become a
successful devops Inu coding and
scripting strong knowledge of
programming languages like python Ruby
or JavaScript and scripting skills are
essential for Automation and Tool
development system administration
familiarity with Linux Unix and Windows
systems including configuration and
troubleshooting cloud computing
proficient see in Cloud platforms like
AWS Azure or Google Cloud to deploy and
manage applications in the cloud
containerization and
orchestration understanding container
Technologies like Docker and container
orchestration tools like kubernetes is a
must continuous integration or
deployment experienced with cicd tools
such as Jenkins gitlab Ci or Circle CI
to automate the development workflow
infrastructure as code knowledge of IAC
tools like terraform or censible to
manage infrastructure programmatically
monitoring and logging familiarity with
monitoring tools like prom the grafana
and logging Solutions like elk stack
acquiring these skills will not only
make you a valuable devops engineer but
will also open doors to exciting job
opportunities so to enroll in the
postgraduate program in devups today
click the link mentioned in the
description box below don't miss this
fantastic opportunity to invest in your
future so let's take a minute to hear it
out from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
career through a postgraduate program in
devops what is cloud computing as we
learn what is cloud computing we will
also be learning about how things were
before cloud computing and benefits of
cloud computing different types of cloud
computing available and some of the
famous companies that are using cloud
computing and they're getting benefited
out of it we're going to learn all that
before cloud computing existed if we
need any it servers or application let's
say a basic web server it does not come
easy now here is an owner of a business
and I know you would have guessed it
already that he's running a successful
business by looking at the hot and fresh
brewed coffee in his desk and lots and
lots of paperwork to review and approve
now he had a smart not only smartlook
but a really smart worker in his office
called Mark and on one fine day he
called Mark and said that he would like
to do business online in other words he
would like to take his business online
and for that he needed his own website
as the first thing and Mark puts all his
knowledge together and comes up with
this requirement that his boss would
need lots of servers uh database and
softwares to get his business online
which means a lot of investment and Mark
also adds that his boss will need to
invest on acquiring technical expertise
to manage the hardware and software that
they will be purchasing and also to
monitor the infrastructure and after
hearing all this his boss was close to
dropping his plan to go online but
before he made a decision he chose to
check if there are any alternatives
where he don't have to spend a lot of
money and don't have to spend acquiring
technical expertise now that's when Mark
opened this discussion with his boss and
he explained his boss about cloud
computing and he explained his boss the
same thing that I'm going to explain to
you in some time now about what is cloud
computing what is cloud Compu Computing
cloud computing is the use of a network
of remote servers hosted on the internet
to store manage and process data rather
than having all that locally and using
local server for that cloud computing is
also storing our data in the internet
from anywhere and accessing our data
from anywhere throughout the internet
and the companies that offer those
services are called Cloud providers
cloud computing is also being able to
deploy and manage our application ations
services and network throughout the
globe and manage them through the web
management or configuration portal in
other words cloud computing service
providers give us the ability to manage
our applications and services through a
Global Network or Internet example of
such providers are Amazon web servers
and Microsoft Azure now that we have
known what cloud computing is let's talk
about the benefits of cloud computing
now I need to tell you the cloud
benefits is what is driving Cloud
adoption like anything in the recent
days if you want an IT resource or a
service now with Cloud it's available
for me almost instantaneously and it's
ready for production almost the same
time now this reduces the go live date
and the product and the service hit the
market almost instantaneously compared
to the Legacy environment and because of
this the companies have started to
generate Revenue almost the next day if
not the same day planning and buying the
the rights Hardware has always been a
challenge in Legacy environment and if
you're not careful when doing this we
might need to live with a hardware
that's undersized for the rest of our
lives with Cloud we do not buy any
hardware but we use the hardware and pay
for the time we use it if that Hardware
does not fit our requirement release it
and start using a better configuration
and pay only for the time you use that
new and better configuration in Legacy
environments forecasting demand is an
full-time job but with Cloud you can let
the monitoring and automation tool to
work for you and to rapidly scale up and
down the resources based on the need of
that R not only that the resources
Services data can be accessed from
anywhere as long as we are connected to
the internet and even there are tools
and techniques now available which will
let you to work offline and will syn
whenever the internet is available
making sure the data is stored in
durable storage and in a secure fashion
is the talk of the business and Cloud
answers that million-dollar question
with Cloud the data can be stored in an
highly durable storage and replicated to
multiple regions if you want and uh the
data that we store is encrypted and
secured in a fashion that's beyond what
we can imagine in local data centers now
let's bleed into the discussion about
the types of cloud computing very lately
there are multiple ways to categorize
cloud computing because it's growing now
we have more categories out of all these
six sort of stand out you know
categorizing cloud based on deployments
and categorizing cloud based on services
and again under deployments categorizing
them based on how they have been
implemental you know is it private is it
public or is it hybrid and again
categorizing them based on the service
it provides is it infrastructure as a
service or is it platform as a service
or is it software as a service let's
look at them one by one let's talk about
the different types of cloud based on
the deployment models first in public
Cloud everything is stored and accessed
in and through the internet and um any
internet users with proper permissions
can be given access to some of the
applications and resources and in public
Cloud we literally own nothing be it the
hardware or software everything is
managed by the provider AWS Azure and
Google are some examples of public Cloud
private Cloud on the other hand with
private Cloud the infrastructure is
exclusively for an single organization
the organizations can choose to run
their own cloud locally or choose to
Outsource it to a public cloud provider
as manage services and when this is done
the service the infrastructure will be
maintained on a private Network some
examples are wmware cloud and some of
the AWS products are very good example
for private Cloud hybrid cloud has taken
things to the whole new level with
hybrid Cloud we get the benefit of both
public and private Cloud organizations
will choose to keep some of their
applications locally and some of the
application will be present in the cloud
one good example is NASA it uses hybrid
Cloud it uses private Cloud to store
sensitive data and uses public Cloud to
store and share data which are not
sensitive or confidential let's now
discuss about cloud based on servers
model the first and the broader category
is infrastructure as a service uh here
we would rent the servers network
storage and we'll pay for them in an
early basis but we will have access to
the resources we provision and for some
we will have root level access as well
ec2 in AWS is a very good example it's a
WM for which we have root level access
to the OS and admin access to the
hardware the next type of service model
would be platform as a service now in
this model the providers will give me a
pre-built platform where we can deploy
our codes and our applications and they
will be up and running we only need to
manage the codes and not the
infrastructure here in software as a
service the cloud providers sell the end
product which is a software or an
application and we directly buy the
software on an subscription basis it's
not the infra or the platform but the
end product or the software or a
functioning app apption and we pay for
the hours we use the software and in
here the client maintains full control
of the software and does not maintain
any equipment Amazon and Azure also sell
products that are software as service
this chart sort of explains the
difference between the four models
starting from on premises to
infrastructure as a service to platform
as a service to software as a service
this is self-explanatory that uh the
resource managed by by us are huge in on
premises that towards your left as you
watch and it's little less in
infrastructure as a service as we move
further towards the ride and further
reduced in platform as a service and
there's really nothing to manage when it
comes to software as a service because
we buy the software not any
infrastructure component attached to it
there are lots of famous well-known
organization around the world they have
moved or have migrated to the cloud
environment Pinter is one company which
is one of the world's largest visual
book marketing tool with more than 70
million monthly active users now
Pinterest was able to scale its business
because it was all built on Amazon web
services with a company with a less
number of employees Pinterest decided
that they do not want a dedicated staff
time to manage a data center instead
Pinterest users AWS or they used AWS to
manage their high performance so social
application and store more than 8
billion objects and 400 terab of data in
AWS Cloud using a service called Amazon
simple storage service or in short
Amazon S3 and not only that they are
running 2 lakh 25,000 instance hours a
month and they run that on Amazon
compute service called Amazon ec2 or
Amazon elastic compute Cloud Spotify is
an another company that got benefited
using AWS it's an online music service
offering and it offers instant access to
over 16 million licensed songs Spotify
needed a peculiar requirement it needed
a storage solution that could scale very
quickly without incurring long lead
times for upgrades long story short
Spotify used Amazon S3 which is a Amazon
simple storage service and Amazon S3
gave them the confidence in their
ability and to expand their storage
quickly while ALS also providing High
data durability the third biggest
company I want to mention is Netflix
it's the world's largest internet
television network with more than 100
million members in more than 190
countries Netflix uses Amazon web
services for nearly all its Computing
and storage needs now that includes
database analytic recommendation Engines
video transcoding and a lot more not
only that this company is planning to
use AWS Lambda to build an automated or
an rule-based self-managing
infrastructure and replace some of their
inefficient process to reduce the rate
of errors and replace inefficient
processes to reduce the rate of errors
and save their valuable time xedia is
another famous company that got
benefited by using Cloud xedia provides
travel booking service through its
Flagship site called expedia.com and not
only that they also run 200 plus travel
booking sites around the world xedia is
all on AWS and by using AWS xedia has
become more resilient with an high
scalable infrastructure and better cloud
services because it had offloaded the it
management to the cloud provider itself
in this case AWS and because of this
expedia's developers have been able to
innovate faster while saving the company
millions and millions of dollars we can
categorize the different types of cloud
computing based on two wide categories
one being the deployment model and the
other one being service model let's talk
about the deployment model first
deployment model is categorized into
three types first one is public and then
private and then hybrid cloud in other
words public Cloud private cloud and
hybrid Cloud it'll be easy for me to
explain and also it'll be easy for you
to understand if I walk you through this
example consider the different types of
vehicles we use to commute from one
place to another for example if I want
to travel I can pick a bus which is
accessible to anyone I get in and I pay
for the seat that I occupy and I pay for
the time that I will be traveling in it
and I'm done cost is very less here a
similar kind of thing happens in the
public Cloud I pay only for the resource
that I use and I pay for how long I use
it if I use less I pay less if I use
more I pay more for that month simple on
the other hand private cloud is like
buying your own car and using it for
commuting purpose here I pay a huge
amount UPF front and it is all owned
only by me I do not pay for it in an Ali
fashion but completely and all upfront
the cost here is very huge and thirdly
if I want the best of both types like
the comfort of the own car and still
don't want to pay all up front otherwise
want only to pay for the time that I use
the service I can rent a car similarly I
can have it in a hybrid environment
meaning if I already have a DC I can
integrate it with the cloud and use both
the DCs and that would become an hybrid
environment all right so that was good
of an uh learning let's summarize the
types of cloud based on deployment
models and as we know now about the
public Cloud public cloud is an Cloud
infrastructure that's made available to
the general public over the internet and
it is owned by the cloud provider some
of the major players as Cloud providers
are AWS Microsoft Azure IBM's blue cloud
and suncloud and private Cloud now this
cloud infrastructure is exclusively
operated by a single organization it can
be managed by organizations or third
party and may exist on premises or off
premises doesn't matter but the point
here is this is exclusively operated for
a single organization and some companies
that provide private Cloud are AWS and
VMware and hybrid Cloud gives the best
of both public and the private Cloud for
example the federal agencies they opt
for private clouds for storing and devel
veloping personal data and they use
public Cloud to share the non-sensitive
data with the general public or with
other government departments now let's
talk about different clouds based on the
service model if we need to categorize
them broadly we can categorize them as
infrastructure as a service IAS or
platform as a service Pas or software as
a service s they sometimes are referred
to as I Pas and SAS now at this moment
you could build like this guy thinking
Sam I thought you're done categorizing
the cloud now you're going to talk about
three more categories which one should I
pick well let me explain if all that you
want is just a Wim and you have all the
expertise to install the software on top
of it and make it work then go for is if
you only want a platform or an interface
to program or an interface to upload a
program and make it run then pick pass
or if all that you want is a finished
product hosted in the cloud and be able
to access it through the internet then
go for SAS here you get a username and
password for an application and you can
begin to customize the application based
on your needs all right let's talk about
um IAS in a bit more detail IAS it gives
basic Computing infra it's based on uh
pay for what you use model and some of
the cloud providers who are big players
are AWS Azure and Google and here the
users generally will be it admins in
pass the provider gives giv you a
platform or a runtime environment for
developing testing and managing
application it's platform ready you buy
the platform you upload your code and
you start working on it and it allows
the software developers to deploy
applications without running the
underlying infrastructure and as you
might have guessed by now the
interesting candidates who would use
pass is software developers and in SAS
everything is managed by the vendor be
it the hardware or the software it's
managed by the vendor and we pay for the
the service and we pay for it through a
pay as youo subscription model and as
you might have guessed the end users
here would be End customer itself all
right let's put together everything in
the same page and compare and contrast
the different types of service models in
this chart it explains the difference
between the four models starting from on
premises to IAS and then Pas and SAS it
is self-explanatory that the resources
managed by us are huge in on premises
and little less in is and further less
or reduced in p and nothing to manage
when it comes to SAS let me also explain
the different types of cloud services
through an example like this let's say
that you have a crush on cake and you're
planning to bake one yourself now let's
look at the options you can have you can
make all the ingredients yourself be the
floor uh butter and uh you know put
together and bake the whole thing
yourself using your own oven pan you
know the needed water and and the rest
you get an idea right everything is
yours and that's on premises all that
you use is owned by you and nothing is
managed by the vendor the other options
you can have is buy the ingredients and
mix and bake the cake yourself now this
would be like is here the infra is
managed by the provider and we get to
use it and customize it the way we
wanted here the cloud service is then
shared responsibility the other options
you still have on hand is simply pick a
phone and order a cake now this is a lot
simpler than the rest we discussed so
far you know it's simply picking the
phone and ordering the cake and pay for
it when it arrives simple and when it
reaches home you will have to arrange
the table garnish the cake if that's
needed and then enjoy the cake it's the
same way with pass just get the platform
in which you would run your code and
upload your code and start running your
application here you and the vendors
still share the responsibility you still
have one more option left that is simply
go out and dine this is a lot lot
simpler that it requires no effort from
us at all you buy the fully finished and
garnished cake and pay for it and walk
out no responsibility on making the cake
it's the same way with SAS we buy the
finished product and pay for the
finished application if you have
stumbled upon this video there is a very
high probability that you are wondering
about how to get a job in the cloud
computing domain and why won't you the
cloud industry is booming with
opportunities and it allows everyone to
be a part of its growing industry even
for the people with no coding skills Yes
you heard it right even if you don't
have extensive coding skills you can
join as a cloud computing professional
in some of the top Tire product
companies in this video we will discuss
all the nitty-gritty details of how you
can get a head start and an entry-level
job in the cloud computing domain so
without further Ado let's quickly jump
on to the topic
but wait to help you with next step we
have our celtech postgraduate program in
cloud computing this course will help
you become an expert in aure AWS and gcp
and let you master key architectural
principles and develop the skills needed
to become a cloud expert this
post-graduate program in cloud computing
help you become an expert in designing
planning and scaling Cloud
implementations a cloud computing course
helps you master the core skill sets
required to design and deploy Dynamic
scaling and reliable application on
completion of this course you will gain
ktech ctme postgraduate certification
with 40 plus Hands-On projects along
with opportunity to secure a job in
large companies like Netflix MasterCard
and more you can check out its Link in
the description box below Cloud
technology is in high demand and
organization are seeking skilled
professionals to manage their Cloud
infrastructure this video will guide you
through the steps to secure an
entry-level Cloud job the first one is
gain fundamental knowledge in that you
to understand Cloud implementation in
detail after that we'll see learn Cloud
platforms and then start networking and
security the first one is understand
cloud computing familiarize yourself
with the Core Concepts of cloud
computing including different deployment
models like public private hybrid more
Concepts like service models like L AAS
p and SAS visualization you also have to
learn and Cloud security next we have
learn Cloud platforms focus on popular
Cloud platforms such as Amazon web
services Microsoft aure and Google Cloud
platform gcp start by understanding
their basic offerings features and
services your next step should be study
networking and security a require
knowledge of networking fundamentals TCP
I protocols firewalls load balancing and
network security this knowledge is
crucial for cloud related roles the next
step is build practical skills the first
one in that is on experience the next
one is work on projects I will tell you
them in detail the third one is obtain
certification now let's see hands-on
experience create a personal cloud lab
using free trial account on platforms
like AWS aure or gcp practice deploying
virtual machines configuring networking
and security settings experiment with
different services and get comfortable
with their interfaces the next one is
work on projects undertake personal or
open-source projects that involves Cloud
Technologies this will provide practical
experience and help you showcase your
skill to potential employers example
could include deploying a web
application or on cloud platform or
automating infrastructure the next one
we have obtain certification Cloud
certification demonstrate your expertise
and enhance your credibilities start
with entry-level certifications like AWS
certified Cloud practitioner Microsoft
aure fundamentals or Google Cloud
certified associate Cloud engineer these
certification validate your knowledge
and make your resum a stand out Simply
learn also offers Cloud certifications
that can help you land a good job In
This Cloud domain next we will discuss
networking and professional development
in that the first one is join online
communities the next one is attend
meetups and conferences and the third
one is build a professional online
presence let's talk about join online
communities engage with online Cloud
communities and forums such as stack
Overflow participate in discussion ask
questions and learn from experienced
professionals networking with life
like-minded individuals can also lead to
a good opportunities next we will see is
attend meetups and conferences attend
local Tech meetups Cloud conferences and
workshops these events provides
opportunity to networking with industry
professionals learn about latest trends
and gain insights from experts be
proactive in sharing your knowledge and
connecting with potential employers next
we will see build a professional online
presence create a LinkedIn profile
highlighting your Cloud related skills
projects and certifications share
articles contribute to relevant
communities and connect with
Professionals in this field a strong
online presence can attract attention
for recruiters and increase your chance
of getting noticed next we have job
search and preparation the first step
would be refine your resumee the next is
practice interviewing and apply for
entry-level position so so how to refine
your resume tailor your resume and
emphasize your Cloud related skills
projects and certification highlight any
relevant work experience internship or
project that demonstrate your
understanding of cloud Technologies next
we have to practice interviewing so
let's see about how to practice
interviewing prepare for technical
interviews by reviewing common Cloud
related interview questions and PR
responses be ready to discuss your
hands-on experience problem solving
abilities and how you have applied Cloud
Technologies to solve real world
challenges next we have apply for
entry-level positions search for
entry-level Cloud jobs opening on online
job portals company websites and
Professional Network apply for position
that match your skill set and career
goals customize your cover letter for
each application showcasing your
enthusiasm for cloud computing and the
specific company you are applying to
continue learning and growth Cloud
technology is constantly involving stay
updated with the latest trends new
services and best practices explore
Advanced certification and consider
pursuing higher level cloud roles as you
gain experience now securing an
entry-level Cloud job requires a
combination of fundamental knowledge and
practical skills networking and a
proactive approach by following these
steps continuous learning and
demonstrating your passion for cl CL
Computing you will increase your chances
of Landing an entry-level Cloud job and
Kickstart your career in this exciting
field now in a world driven by rapid
technological advancements businesses
are constantly seeking ways to deliver
software faster and more efficiently
enter devops the dynamic philosophy that
has revolutionized the software
development and operations landscape
devops is not just a bus word it's a
game-changing approach that Bridges the
gap between developers and operations
team forer collaboration and enhancing
the entire software development like
cycle
now at its core devops embodies a
cultural shift towards seamless
integration and continuous delivery it
promotes a collaborative environment
where developers system administrators
quality assurance professionals and
other stakeholders work together
harmoniously and promoting cross
functional communication the devops
empow teams to streamline processes
automated workflows and ultimately
deliver high quality software at an
accelerated Pace having said that the
demand for devops professionals has
overgrown in recent years as more and
more companies adop devops practices to
improve their software development and
delivery processes so are you ready to
advance your professional career to the
next level taking our stepbystep simply
learns postgraduate program in devops in
collaboration with IBM will help you
start your devops journey that will
prepare you for the devops engineer role
so in order to match your skills with
market demand this day offs training
program is designed in collaboration
with CTIC cdme and Cutting Edge Blended
learning combines live online day of
certification classes with interactive
labs to give you practical experience
this day deop training program will
cover skills like devops methodology
continuous integration devops on cloud
infrastructure deployment Automation and
many more and along with that you'll
also get hands-on experience with latest
tools and techniques including terraform
Maven anible Docker Jenkins and much
more so if you're looking to pursue your
career as deop engineer and acquire
these skills that will prepare you for
your job consider enrolling in this
intensive training program today we will
leave the link in the description box
below so make sure you check that out so
let us move go ahead and proceed with
our topic today so the main question is
what fuels is deop Revolution now it's a
powerful collection of tools
specifically designed to support and
amplifi principles so these tools access
as a catalyst empowering teams to
automate task manage infrastructure
efficiently and monitor application
performs effectively so without any
further delay let us directly jump into
the top nine noteworthy tools
highlighting their features benefits and
significance that have become synonymous
with the devops ecosystem in no
particular order so first on the list we
have genkin now genkin is an open source
automation server known for its
extensive plug-in ecosystem making it
highly verstile and customizable it
facilitates continuous integration and
continuous delivery or in short cacd
pipelines automating the built test and
deployment processes Junkin enables team
to integrate code frequently ensuring
early detection of issues and faster
software releases so let us now look at
some of the key features of the genkin
firstly easy installation and
configuration genkins has a userfriendly
web interface that simplifies
installation configuration and
management of build jobs and pipelines
distributed builds for scalability now
it's supposed for a vast ecosystem of
plugins for seamless integration and it
can distribute build tasks across
multiple nodes which helps in paralyzing
builds and reducing overall build time
especially in large projects and finally
extensible throughing languages like
groy now Jenkins provides extensibility
through scripting languages like groy
which is a powerful and verstile
language AG that runs on the Java
virtual machines or in short jvm so by
leveraging groovy scripting capabilities
Jenkins becomes highly adaptable and
customizable to meet the specific
requirements of different development
teams and projects so those are some of
the key features of genkins let us now
move ahead and discuss some of the
benefits or advantages of using genkins
so firstly we have enabled faster
feedback and quicker time to market now
jenkin's continuous integration
capabilities enable developers to merge
their code changes into a shared repres
regularly by doing so genkins
automatically triggers build and testing
processes to validate any kind of
changes this automates feedback loop
allows developers to receive quick
feedback on the quality of their code so
as a result issues and bugs can be
identified early in the development
cycle preventing the accumulation of
defects and reducing the time required
to fix them as discussed earlier it also
facilitates early issue detection and
reduce bug turnaround time now with
genkins running automated builds and
test every time new code is committed
potential issues and bugs are got early
in the development process so by
detecting issues at an early stage
developers can address them promptly
before they propagate further into the
code base and finally automates
repeative task same time and effort now
jungus automates various tasks involved
in the software development life cycle
this includes tasks such as building the
code running tests and deploying
applications by automating these
repetitive and timec consuming tasks
genen saves developers and operations
team significant amount of time and and
efforts so that is what genkins is all
about it's a widely adopted in the
devops landscape due to its flexibility
and extensive plug-in support and
learning it will add a great value to
your array of skills so its ability to
automate CSD processes and integrate
with various tools makes it a crucial
component of mod software development
and delivery pipelines second on the
list we have Docker Docker has
revolutionized application deployment
with its containerization approach it
allows developers to package
applications and their dependencies into
lightweight isolated containers Docker
contains provide consistency across
different environments ensuring that
applications run consistently regardless
of the underlying infrastructure this
portability along with the rapid startup
times and efficient resource utilization
has made Docker a foundational tool in
deos practices so let us now some
discuss some of the key features of
Docker first one is packaging
applications and dependencies into
containers now Dockers allows developer
to package their applications and all
their dependencies into a self-contained
units called containers and the process
is known as containerization now these
containers encapsulate the application
code its runtime various libraries and
system tools required to run the
application by doing so Docker ensures
consistency across different
environments secondly efficient resource
utilization through containerization now
this lightweight nature of containers
allows for more efficient resource
utilization multiple containers can run
on a single physical machine without the
need for individual OS instances it
means that you can host more
applications and services on the same
Hardware reducing the number of servers
needed and finally easy scaling and
management of containers Now
containerization simplifies application
scaling and management so when you need
to handle increased application load you
can quickly scale by running more
instances on the containerized
application on additional servers or
within a container orchestration
platform like
kubernets so let us now talk about some
of the benefits of the docker tool now
firstly rapid deployment and scalability
dock ER enables rapid deployment of
applications due to its lightweight and
containerized approach when using
Dockers developers package their
applications and dependencies into
containers which encapsulate everything
needed to run the application so these
containers are portable and can be
easily moved from one environment to the
other and next we have the isolation of
applications and dependencies for
improved security Docker utilizes
conization to isolate applications and
the dependencies from the ecosystem and
other containers each containers operate
in its own user space space separate
from other containers providing a strong
level of isolation this isolation
prevents applications from affecting
each other and helps contain potential
security breaches within the confines of
the container and finally simplify
development to production workflow now
Docker streamlines the development
production workflow by providing
consistency between different
environments with Docker developers can
create containers that run the same way
in development testing and production
environments thereby reducing the
chances of unexpected issues arising
during the deployment
so Docker has become a Cornerstone of
modern day of practices it's updated to
streamline application deployment and
improved resource utilization has
transformed software development and
operations enabling faster and more
reliable application delivery so that
was all about Docker so let us now move
ahead and discuss the next tool which is
kubernets so next on the list we have
kubernets kubernets is an open source
container orchestration platform that
automates the deployment scaling and
management of container applications it
provides a robust infrastructure for
running and coordinating containers
across clusters of machine making it
easier to manage large scale deployments
deop steams can easily deploy update and
scale applications facilitating faster
and more Reliable Software delivery
while promoting collaboration and
consistency across development and
operations life cycle through kubernets
so let us look at some of the key
features of it automatic container
deployment and scaling now container
orchestration platforms like kubernets
provide automatic container deploy
deployment and scaling capabilities when
deploying applications on kubernets you
can Define the desired state of your
application using yl files on
declarative configuration cubet then
take carees of this ensuring that
specified number of container replicas
is running at all times service
Discovery and load balancing now kuber
net enables faster feedback and quicker
time to Market in a cized environment
multiple instances of an application may
be running across different containers
making it challenging for clients or
other services to know the IP addresses
of all the running instances and
detecting and keeping tracking of the
locations of various services within the
container cluster and kubernets for
example provides a built-in service
Discovery mechanism next we have
selfhealing and aut set of containers
now container orchestration platform
provides self feeling capabilities to
ensure that applications are always
available and responsive if a container
fails due to an application crash or any
other issues the orchestration platform
detects the failure and automatically
restarts the fail container so let us
move ahead and discuss some of the
benefits of using kubernets tool firstly
it is scalable and highly available
application and it provides a seeming
repeat and provides a seamless scaling
of resources based on demand next it has
a simplified management of conization
applications across various clusters and
finally automated deployment and updates
reducing manual Intervention which
further improves resource utilization
and optimization overall kubernets has
emerged as the industry standard for
container orchestration its ability to
automate application deployment scaling
and management simplifies the
complexities of running content rized
applications at scale making it a
crucial tool for devops
practitioners moving ahead let us
discuss our next tool which is anible
anable is a powerful automation tool
that simplifies configuration management
application deployment and orchestration
it employs a declarative language to
Define desire shed configuration making
it easy to manage and automate
infrastructure task anible follows an
agentless architecture allowing it to
work efficiently across a wide range of
systems and environments so let us now
look look at it some of its features
firstly it's a declarative language for
defining infrastructure configuration
and it is also an agentless architecture
for easy deployment and management as it
discussed earlier now this is done
through a Playbook driven automation for
orchestration where extensive library of
modules for a wide range of task are
employed so let us now discuss some of
its benefits so firstly it's simplified
infrastructure management through
automation which increases the
operational efficiency with reduced
manual task and its ENT nature ensures
that it has consistently and
predictability overall and finally it
supports a wide range of infrastructure
automation use cases and with its
agentless architecture it allows easy
integration with various systems and
environments so in a natural anible
Simplicity flexibility and ease of use
have made it a popular choice for
automating infrastructure and
application deployment task approach and
agentless architecture contribute to
efficient and streamline development
Workforce so moving ah the next tool on
our list is git is a distributed version
control system that has become a
fundamental tool for modern software
development practices it allows
developers to track changes collaborate
effectively and manage codebase
efficiently GS decentralized
architecture ensures that developers can
work offline and merge changes
seamlessly across branches let us now
discuss it some of its key features now
its distributed coion control system has
efficient collaboration with various uh
tools within the management of the
ecosystem of devops and it also has an
integration with various code hosing
platforms which is the branching and
merging capabilities for concurrent
development and finally it support for
code reviews and collaboration workflows
which also gives a commit based tracking
of changes so these are some of the key
features of git so let us now discuss
some of the advantages or like benefits
of using git so firstly it's easy
tracking and management of code changes
which ensur sufficient collaboration and
concurrent development within the
resource files and its ability to work
offline and merge changes seamlessly
will benefit a lot of devops Engineers
and finally its easy integration with
other devops tools makes it a wonderful
to use to manage code versions track
changes and enable efficient
collaboration which is revolutionize the
software development so it has become a
essential tool for Version Control
facilitating effective collaboration and
a enabling streamlined devops
workflows so moving ahead the next tool
on our list is terraform now terraform
is an infrastructured code or in short
IAC tool that allows teams to Define and
provision infrastructure resources in a
declarative manner it supports multiple
Cloud providers and enables consistent
and reproducible infrastructure
deployment terraforms declarative syntax
and State Management capabilities
simplify infrastructure provisioning and
configuration let us now look at some of
its key features firstly it provides
multicloud support for provisioning
resources across different providers its
infrastructure as Cod approach for
consistent and reproducible deployments
makes it a declarative Syntax for
defining infrastructure configurations
and finally automated resource
provisioning and dependency
management so some of its benefits or
the advantages of using terraform as its
simplified resource provisioning and
dependency management now terraforms
infrastructure as code approach supports
for multiple Cloud providers makes it an
essential tool for managing
infrastructure codes and collaboration
and Version Control for infrastructure
configurations as well and finally it
State Management for tracking
infrastructure changes which makes it a
beneficial tool for devops
engineers now nigos is used to Monitor
and manage the health and performance of
the infrastructure application and
network resources it's a comprehensive
monitoring solution to identify and
resolve issues proactively ensuring High
availability and reliability of systems
so let us look some of its key features
firstly its monitoring capabilities
secondly it's centralized fun figure
management and finally its even handling
and escalation tool so learning nagios
is also crucial and beneficial if you're
just starting on de's
Journey so moving ahead let us now
discuss our next tool on our list which
is Elk stack now elk stack offers offers
a comprehensive solution for
centralizing logs from various
applications and systems making it
easier for deop teams to monitor
troubleshoot and gain valuable insights
from their log data the elk stack
comprising elastic search log statch and
kibana provid a comprehensive log
management and Analysis platform it ACC
as a distribution search and analytics
engine while log stack collects
processes and transform locks and
finally kibana offers a userfriendly
interface for visualizing and explor
data so some of its key features
including realtime monitoring alerting
scalable and efficient log storage and
retrieval and distributed search and
analytics to data visualization and
Exploration with
cabana let us look at some of its
benefits so firstly it's realtime
monitoring for proactive detect is
repeat it's realtime log monitoring for
proactive issue detection with the help
of centralized log management and
Analysis Advanced log analytics for
troubleshooting and performance
optimization making it a scalable
architecture for handling large scale
volumes of data and finally efficient
log storage and retrieval for compliance
and auditing purposes in a Nell elk
stack has gained immense popularity for
its ability to handle log management and
Analysis its scale it empow deop teams
with realtime insights into application
and infrastructure logs facilitating
effective trouble shooting and
performance
optimization well finally on the list we
have jira software jira is a widely used
project management tool that supports
asile development methodologies it
offers robust features for planning
tracking and managing task issues and
workflows J's customizable boards
backlogs and workflows Empire teams to
collaborate effectively visualize and
progress to gain transparency into
project statuses with integration to
various deop tools J facilitate seamless
tracking of development activities
enabling continuous Improvement and
efficient project management some of its
key features are customizable boards
workflows for project management
agile planning and estimation features
issue tracking and management
capabilities and some of its benefits
include efficient task management and
tracking enhanced collaboration and
visibility across various teams and
integration with various devops tools
for streamline workflows it also helps
in reporting and analytics for project
insights and performance measurement
finally jira has become a go-to tool for
agile project management in the doops
ecosystem It's ability to support agile
methodologies track task and integrate
with other Deo ruls makes it a valuable
assets for teams seeking efficient
project management and continuous
Improvement so learning it will add a
great value to your Aro skills again so
these are some of the top nine deop
rules that you must know which will help
you enhance and accelerate your career
in devops now let's get
started meet Tim Tim builds a robot in
his lab a climate controlled and
pollution free
environment once he he's done he drops
the robot off at his project partner
Mia's house Mia takes it out to her
backyard to ensure that the robot meets
the requirements but here is where the
problem arises the change in the
environment causes the robot to
malfunction Mia is now really annoyed
and she has a lot to correct and it
seems to her as though Tim didn't really
do much this wall between them leaves a
poor robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall Tim and
M now work together in a common space
Tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by Mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as in when a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product they
develop a common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective Tim would be the developer
while Mia the operations their Union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these Tim first puts down a
plan in terms of his software this could
mean deciding on the modules and the
algorithms to use once he has the plan
he now codes the plan with tools such as
git Tim has a repository for storing all
the codes and their different versions
this is called Version Control next this
code is fetched and made executable this
is the build stage tools such as Gradle
and Maven will sort this out now before
deployment the product is tested to
catch any bugs the most popular tool AO
automating testing is selenium once the
products are tested Mia must deploy it
the deployed product is then
continuously configured to the desired
State anable puppet and Docker are some
of the most common tools used that
automate these stages now every product
is continuously monitored in its working
environment nagios is one such tool that
automates this phas and the feedback is
fed back to the planning stage and
finally we have the core of the devops
life cycle the integration stage tools
such as Jenkins is responsible for
sending the code for build and test if
the code passes the tests it's further
sent for deployment this is called
continuous integration let's now have a
look at an organization that has adopted
the devops approach which of the below
sequence of steps would they follow to
develop a software leave your answers in
the comment SE section keep an eye out
for the right answer on the comment
section or our YouTube Community Giants
such as Amazon Netflix Target XE and
Walmart have all adopted devops and seen
a considerable increase in delivery and
quality in 2014 an hour of downtime for
Netflix would cost it
$200,000 it became absolutely crucial
that Netflix prepared themselves for any
sort of failure
and so they took to the devops approach
and implemented it in the most unique
way they developed a tool called Simeon
Army this tool created failures and
automatically deployed them in an
environment that did not affect the
users the team would troublesho these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its Divergence from the
traditional methods what devops be the
future let us know what you think in the
comment section below hello this is
Matthew with simply learn and today
we're going to introduce you to Dev Ops
so let's go through waterfall so
waterfall is a traditional delivery
model that's been used for many decades
for delivering Solutions not just IT
solutions and digital Solutions but even
way before that it has its history goes
back to World War II so waterfall is a
model that is used to capture
requirements and then Cascade each key
deliverable through a series of
different stage Gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage Gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project plan
so you have an understanding of what the
level of work is needed to be able to be
successful in delivering the solution
after that you got your plan then you
start doing the development and that
means that the programmers start coding
out their solution they build out their
applications they build out the websites
and this can take weeks or even months
to actually do all the work when you've
done your coding and development then
you send it to another group that does
testing and they'll do full regression
testing of your application against the
systems and databases that integrate
with your application you'll test it
against the actual code you'll do manual
testing you do UI testing and then after
you've delivered the solution you go
into maintenance mode which is just kind
of making sure that the application
keeps working there's any security risks
that you address those security risks
now the problem you have though is that
there are some challenges however that
you have with the waterfall model the
cascading deliveries and those complete
and separated stage Gates means that
it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expensive and it's very time
consuming also if you spend weeks and
months away from your client and you
deliver a solution that they are only
just getting to see after you spend a
lot of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or are not implemented correctly or
lead to just general unhappiness the
challenge you then have is if you want
to add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes and then you go back
and you have to start your programming
and you have to then start your testing
process again and just you're really
adding in lots of additional time into
the project so using the waterall model
companies have soon come to realize that
you know the clients just aren't able to
get their feedback in quickly
effectively it's very expensive to make
changes once the teams have started
working and the requirement in today's
digital world is that Solutions simply
must be delivered faster and this has
led for a specific change in agile and
we start implementing the agile model so
the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the client with the
requirements faster and the client is
able to then send the requirements back
to the programmer with feedback this
allows us to create what we call a
feedback loop where we're able to get
information to the client and the client
can get back to the development team
much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about 2 weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the client the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
Sprint and that typically a Sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a Sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that Loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of Sprint 2 and the client says
hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for Sprint 3
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to Agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call product backlog and this will be
just a whole bunch of different features
and they may be small features or bug
fixes all the way up to large features
that may actually span over multiple
Sprints but when you go through the
Sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually Implement successfully into
their Sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your Sprint again
it's a two-e activity you meet every
single day to with the actual Sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a Sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering featur at the end of
each Sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
being tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the Sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their Sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their Sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production servers but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developer test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an API that
doesn't exis in production and so you
have these challenges that the
operations team are constantly faced
with and their challenge is that they
don't know how the code works so this is
where devops really comes in and let's
dig into how devops which is developers
and operators working together is the
key for successful continuous delivery
so devops is is an evolution of the
agile model the agile model really is
great for Gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
Solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the Ops Team and the
dev team and so with Dev Ops what we're
doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that is based on data so let's step
through the different phases of a devops
team so typically you'll see that the
devops team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
Agile and what I'd like to point out at
time is that again agile and devops are
very closely related that agile and
devops are closely related delivery
models that you can use with devops it's
really just extending that model with
the key phases that we have here so
let's step through each of these key
phases so the first phase is planning
and this is where we actually sit down
with a business team and we go through
and understand what their goals are the
second stage is as you can imagine and
this is where it's all very similar to
Agile is that the code coders actually
start coding and but they typically
they'll start using tools such as git
which is a distributed Version Control
software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as mavin
and Gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another Point here
is that the tools that we're listing
here these are all open-source tools
these are tools that any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment of code into
the production environments and then
finally tools such as anible and Chef
will actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can zero
in on spikes and issues that are
relevant to either the code or changing
consumer habits on the site let's go
ahead and start with this session on top
10 reasons to learn devops so what is
devops devops is a collaboration between
the development and operation teams
which enables continuous delivery of
applications and services to our end
users before devops there was a lot of
communication gap between the
development and operation teams the code
that used to work fine on the
development side would create a lot of
errors on the operation side this in
fact led to a lot of issues the biggest
issue was the delay in Project delivery
the solution to this was devops in
devops the op option and development
Engineers participate together in the
entire life cycle from the design
through the development process to the
delivery of the software to the end
users it enhances the process to deliver
the software faster and a software of
high quality if there is any bug or
error it is fixed at the right time
rather than dragging it to the last
phase let's now look into the 10 reasons
why you should learn devops so at number
10 we have technical cultural and
business benefits of devops let me expl
explain each benefit one by one so first
we have the technical benefits
continuous software delivery is the most
important process of delivering the
software in smaller increments to ensure
that the software can be released at any
time with this approach of devops the
team will always be ready on delivering
anytime it has the benefit of having
less complex problems to fix the code is
tested at every stage and both the
development and operation teams make
sure that the complexity is reduced to a
great extent develop also has the
benefit of faster and easier resolution
to every problem if any bug or error is
found at an earlier stage it is fixed
and then moved on to the next stage
hence this way at the final stage there
will be zero or minimum number of bugs
moving forward let's look into the
cultural benefits of devops the workload
is divided equally between all the
employees so no individual is under the
pressure to Code test debug an entire
software this results in a team that is
happy and more productive productive
since devops is a collaboration between
the development and operation teams if
any issue arises on one side the team is
always ready to help and the employees
are engaged to make sure that the
software is as the end user requires and
hence is delivered at the set date
devops helps in increasing the
professional development opportunities
finally let's look into the business
benefits of devops the basic principles
of devops that is automation continuous
delivery and quick feed back cycle aimed
to make the software development process
faster and more efficient being an
extended version of agile methodology
devops ensures that the complete
software development life cycle goes
smoothly by promoting collaboration
between the teams devops offers
continuous feedback so that the errors
are fixed in time and the releases are
done faster these days the development
teams need to break down the interde
departmental constraints and collaborate
as well as communicate in a dynamic
round the-clock environment the wops
gives away way to improve the business
agility by providing an environment of
mutual collaboration communication and
integration across the various teams in
an IT organization all the team members
are responsible for meeting the quality
and timeline of the software
deliverables with devops organizations
can improve the deployment frequency
recovery rates and hence result in a
lower failure rate with every new
release it is possible to ensure the
reliability and stability of an
application when applications perform
flaw ly in the market organizations reap
the benefits of Greater customer
satisfaction at the ninth position we
have work with good developers PO Code
is all too common sadly users arrive at
the realization when it's too late the
fact is some developers are good at what
they do While others have poor coding
skills a team of software developers
consists of excellent good average and
poor developers it is important that the
bad codes generated by many developers
need to be stopped else it may increase
the production time devops helps in
reducing the bad code limits as the bad
code cannot go to the next phase until
it is fixed also a team member who is
terrible at coding could be good at any
other different roles and vice versa
retasking team members earlier in the
process prevent wastage of time and
resources so in this way devops
eliminates bad developers and ensures
that the team comprises of good
developers next at eighth position we
have increased efficiency
due to increment in efficiency level it
results in speeding up the process of
development and also makes it error-free
devops can also increase efficiency
through automation there are many ways
to automate tasks in devops devops
allows Engineers to focus on those tasks
which are not automated there are
certain tools of acceleration that
increase the efficiency they are the
cloud-based platforms or other scalable
infrastructure which help in increasing
the access of the team to the hardware
resources and and hence speeds up the
process of testing and deployment
operations with the use of build
acceleration tools the code compiles
faster there may be a process that helps
in embedding parallel workflows into the
continuous delivery chain so that the
delays are avoided moving on at seventh
position we have a better organizational
culture with the help of devops there
has been an improvement in software
development the development and
operation teams are more focused on
performing together rather than having
separate goals the team is more focused
on production if both the teams are
combined it will result in innovative
ideas in a very efficient and effective
manner there is improved collaboration
and communication between the team
members devops facilitates better
understanding among the team members and
this understanding increases worker
morale next at the sixth position there
is faster release of software it is true
that devops makes the process of
software development agile hence it
leads to the timely release of the
software companies can quickly study the
behavior of users and incorporate the
changes to come up with a better product
this in turn helps the organization to
stay competitive there is a reduction in
roll backs and failure rates regarding
deployment and the time that is taken to
recover with better products devops
reduces the time for cycles of
development and also ensures a faster
rate of innovation at position five we
have better knowledge of software
delivery life cycle once you get to know
about devops you will get a lot of
information about the software delivery
life cycle it is divided into main
phases like planning analysis design
implementation testing and integration
and maintenance in the plan phase
initially there should be a plan for the
type of application that needs to be
developed getting a rough picture of a
development process is always a good
idea in analysis a detailed study of
requirements is done to check whether
all the requirements are available or
not the list of all the requirements
like human resources Hardware software
Ware required to accomplish this project
successfully will be clearly analyzed
and listed out here in the design phase
the whole project is divid into modules
each module into sub modules by drawing
some diagrams using unified modeling
language a pseudo code will be prepared
at this phase in the implementation
phase the application is coded as per
the end user requirements coder now has
the task to do the coding developers
will develop the actual Source Code by
using the pseudo code and following the
coding standards the testing and
integration phase is the most important
step of the application development here
the application is tested and rebuilt if
necessary the multiple modules of codes
from different programmers are finally
integrated into one then finally the
application is developed and delivered
to the end users the Final Phase is
maintenance once the client starts using
the developed software then the real
issues start coming up in this stage the
team is required to fix the issues roll
out new features and Define the
functionalities as required
at the fourth position we have Boost
product quality the concept of devops
does not allow mistakes in the stage of
methodology when both the operation and
development stages are done correctly
with no errors then it will result in a
release of better and improved product
qualities this leads to a cleaner more
efficient code and hence increases the
software quality with each release the
devor process brings better quality to
the development process and reduces the
chances of unplanned work at the third
position we have exposure to trending
Technologies and advanced tools devops
works with a variety of tools few of
them are naos Chef Docker git selenium
puppet kubernetes anible and many more
you will get a chance to understand and
use all these tools and learn how to
design develop deploy and maintain an
app or software with the help of these
tools apart from that by knowing all
things about such software and tools you
can increase your chances of getting
hired by the best best companies at the
second position we have increase your
professional credibility by obtaining a
devop certification you can increase
your professional credibility this
certification will help you to let the
others know that you have sufficient
skills in monitoring a software's
performance easily write and code with
scripts enhancing the software security
to a greater extent providing the best
it Hardware you will be able to
troubleshoot various issues in the
software and finally you will be able to
to connect softwares databases and much
more to ensure effective functionality
42% of companies are now preferring open
source jobs and want candidates with
devop skills so if you want to become a
part of developing the devops job market
then this is the perfect time to start
getting devops training and finally the
top reason to learn devops is to get a
perfect job and increase your salary
devops is a very popular career choice
now researchers have also shown that in
the coming years devop will be the main
hiring CR criteria for 46% of the it
companies however they are not
sufficient experts who can match the
requirements that's why there are
massive opportunities for candidate
seeking devops jobs besides when it
comes to salary you can earn a lot of
money on an average a divorc
professional gets a pay of
$9,600 per anom in the United States and
a divorc professional in India gets an
average salary of 6 lakh 2,000 Rupees
per anom now let me recap and call out
all the 10 reasons for learning devops
once again at number 10 we had the
technical cultural and business benefits
of devops at number nine we had work
with good developers at number eight we
had increased efficiency at number seven
we had a better organizational culture
at number six we had faster release of
software then at fifth position we had
better knowledge of the software
delivery life cycle at the fourth
position we had boost product quality
and and at third position we had
exposure to trending Technologies and
advanced tools at the second position we
had increased your professional
credibility and finally at the top
position we had get a perfect job and
increase your salary we have come a long
way from storing stuff on our computers
to using the cloud which is like a giant
virtual storage the amount of data we
have is expected to explode to
175 zabt by 2025 that's a lot of
information to handle and that's why
cloud computing comes to the rescue a
game-changing technology in today's
digital world has transformed how we do
things is the driving force behind
sharing emails videos and running
businesses with ease so getting
certified in Cloud technology is like
getting the key to this digital Treasure
Chest companies are moving their stuff
to the cloud because it's safe flexible
and cost effective as organizations
increasingly migrate to the cloud the
demand for skilled professionals who can
design manage and secure Cloud
environments is skyrocketing so whether
you are a seasoned ID professional or
just starting your Tech Journey a cloud
certification not only signifies your
commitment to staying ahead but also
opens the door to exciting opportunities
in this Dynamic field so here we are
with the top five Cloud certifications
you should watch out for in 2024 hey
everyone and you are already watching
simply Lo before we begin with the top
five Cloud certifications make sure that
you have subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any updates from simp so
without any further delay let's get
started let me share some fascinating
statistics with you that illustrate the
impact and potential of this
gamechanging technology before we delve
into the fascinating world of cloud
computing certifications so according to
glass door the average salary of a cloud
engineer is
$142,000 in the United States and in
India is 7.5 lakh rupees perm with
additional cash benefit so let's move on
to the top five cloud Computing
certifications for
2024 at number one we have the cloud
architect Masters program this program
will help you build your AWS Microsoft
Azure and Google Cloud platform
expertise from the ground up you will
learn to master the architectural
principles and services of the top Cloud
platforms design and deploy highly
scalable fall tolerant applications and
develop skills to transform yourself
into an AWS and asure Cloud expert this
program will give you an in-depth
understanding of cloud services such as
AWS cloud formation Azure resource
manager ec2 S3 Route 53 VPC Azure app
services gcp and more you'll acquire the
Knowledge and Skills for passing Cloud
architect certifications such as AWS
architect and Azure architect Cloud
architecture certification program
consists of a structured learning path
designed by leading industry experts
you'll have access to 60 plus live
instructor-led online classrooms 100
plus hours of cell-based we video
content simulation exams a community
moderated by experts and other resources
that ensure you follow the optimal path
to your desired role of cloud architect
the course includes 16 plus real world
industry projects that let you work your
way through the technical challenges
associated with cloud computing
candidates with one plus year of
experience are preferred to enroll in
this program so do check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
for more details at number two we have
the AWS cloud archit Masters
program this AWS Cloud architect
certification course will make you an
expert in Amazon web services in this
program you'll become familiar with the
architectural principles and services of
AWS learn how to design and deploy
highly scalable and fall tolerant
applications on Amazon web services
Implement AWS security and testing and
become an expert in AWS components such
as S3 and cloud formation this AWS Cloud
architect certification training will
enable you to master the course skills
required for Designing and deploying
dynamically scalable highly available
fall tolerant and reliable applications
on one of the top Cloud providers the
Amazon web services so candidates with
one plus years of experience are
preferred to enroll in this program for
more details check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
moving on to number three at number
three we have the Azure Cloud architect
Masters program Azure Cloud architect
Masters program will help you master the
Azure infrastructure by understanding
Azure Cloud architect Technology
Solutions implementing workloads and
Security in Azure creating and deploying
apps in Azo and securing data in
Microsoft Azo a Microsoft Azo
certification validates your Cloud
skills and demonstrate your expertise
for a given role it can help you improve
your earning potential and stay ahead of
your peers it is predicted that around
80% of all Enterprise workloads will
move to the cloud by 2025 this this
means that there will be high demand for
professionals who can develop Cloud
applications and manage cloud
infrastructures and a Microsoft Azure
training certification will help you
gain these skills also candidate with
OnePlus years of experience are
preferred to enroll in this program so
for more details check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
moving on to number four at number four
we have professional certificate program
in cloud computing and devops with a
professional certificate program in
cloud computing and devops with E and
ICT Academy IIT guti become an Azure AWS
devops and Cloud infrastructure design
expert gain hands-on experience through
our real well projects for an exciting
career in it our programs offer
comprehensive training on designing and
implementing Solutions using AWS and
Azure you'll also gain Proficiency in
Cloud architecture infrastructure design
Administration and automation so prepare
for certifications acquire Real World
skills and boost your cloud and devops
career this program covers multiple
skills like application migration Cloud
workloads Auto scaling web services and
apis database management multicloud
deployment Cloud migration and
deployment disaster recovery and many
more candidates with OnePlus year of
work experience are preferred to enroll
in this program and for more details
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below at number five we
have cloud computing boot camp by
celtech cdme becoming an expert in AWS
and Azure is made easy with the Caltech
cloud computing boot camp this in-depth
online course equips you with the
essential skills and Architectural
principles needed to excel in cloud
computing Master the art of cloud
technology and become a sought-after
cloud expert this program includes 40
plus Hands-On projects and integrated
Labs Capstone projects in four different
domains simply learn career service
helps you get noticed by the top hiring
companies and keltech ctme boot camp
certificate validate CR your expertise
so join the simply learn cloud computing
boot camp and unlock a world of
opportunities in this rapidly expanding
field candidates with OnePlus years of
work experience are preferred to enroll
in this program so visit our website
today to enroll and take the first step
toward becoming a certified cloud
computing professional link to this
program is mentioned in the description
box below so with that we have come to
the end of this video on top five cloud
computing certifications in
2024 now let's take a minute to hear it
out from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers with simply loan hey I am Salah
Quadra and I am currently living I
wanted to experience what is like to
leave I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with C
with this course I had the choice to
study while I Contin and that is how I
got this new job offer with 60% salary
high in Finland I will be leading the
cloud computing unit we cannot wait to
start our new life in Finland we are all
so
excited let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a cloud
administrator first off you need
experience with programming languages
like CP and.net you'll also need to be
experienced with devops tools like
Jenkins Docker anible and Chef you'll
need to have understanding of database
configuration so that you can take
advantage of all the relevant
information about the hardware and
software components used by the
organization you'll also need to have
experience with Cloud infrastructure
systems like servers storage Network and
visualization software finally you'll
also need to configure virtual machines
VPN and Cloud servers now let's have a
look at the salary offered to Cloud
administrators now in the United States
the average salary of a cloud
administrator is approximately $65,000
perom similarly in India it's
approximately 7 lakh rupees perom now
let's have a look at some of the
companies hiring for cloud
administrators we have companies like
Vio infosis Accenture IBM and so on so
here I see a comment which says I'm a
fresher and want to learn about AWS how
can I start so actually any fresher can
make a career in AWS as long as you have
interest towards the subject now if you
are from non- technical background you
need to put in a lot more hard work and
have a lot of patience so I would
recommend that before you take up the
AWS course you have a look at the course
curriculum types of AWS courses
opportunities in the market for AWS
certified candidates and so on so now
let's go to number six Cloud application
developer now a cloud application
developer mainly focuses on implementing
and maintaining an organization's Cloud
infrastructure now they're involved with
designing building creating analyzing
and maintaining Cloud systems now these
individuals are also involved with
ensuring that there's an effective
design of business processes in the
cloud they're also involved with a
number of different tasks like
optimizing efficiency and performance
scaling application components and
security issues now let's have a look at
some of the skills required to become a
cloud application developer first off
you need to have experience with
database languages like MySQL SQL and
mongodb then you need have experience
with programming languages like python
Ruby and pearl so that you can code and
create cloud computing applications
you'll also need to have experience with
Linux now this is because most Cloud
infrastructures are created with Linux
servers you'll also need to have
experience with cloud service providers
like Amazon web services Google Cloud
platform and Microsoft aure you'll need
to have experience with information
security with the help of certifications
you'll also need to know how to create
microservices and to create cloud Cloud
applications now let's have a look at
the salary offered to a cloud
application developer in the United
States it's approximately $70,000 perom
in India the average salary of a cloud
application developer is approximately 8
lakh rupees perom now let's have a look
at some of the companies hiring Cloud
application developers you have
companies like Bosch mecafe sap and so
on so now let's go to number five Cloud
network engineer a cloud network
engineer is responsible for implementing
supporting maintaining and optimizing
the network Hardware software and
communication Links of the
organization's Cloud infrastructure he
or she basically focuses on Automation
and security while building the cloud
infrastructure enhancing Network tooling
visibility and improving productivity
now let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a cloud
network engineer first off obviously you
need to have experience with networking
which means a familiarity with the
internet and Van communication
Technologies protocols and best practice
practices you need to have an
understanding of cloud security and how
you can design a public cloud with
multiple options you'll need to have an
experience with data center
Administration which basically means an
understanding on infrastructure design
operations and life cycle management and
finally you need to have experience with
cloud computing platforms like Amazon
web services Microsoft as your and
Google Cloud platform next let's have a
look at the salaries offered to a cloud
network engineer firstly the average
salary of a cloud Network engineer in
the United States is approximately
$72,000 perom in India the average
salary of a cloud network engineer is
approximately 4 lakh rupees perom now
that we're done with this let's have a
look at the companies hiring Cloud
Network Engineers we have companies like
Amazon web services Rakuten Cisco and so
much more now for number four we have
Cloud automation engineer a cloud
automation engineer focuses on cloud
Automation orchestration and integration
he or she implements optimizes and
supports the cloud infrastructure and
ensures it has high availability they
also have to increase the cost
Effectiveness and availability of the
cloud now let's have a look at some of
the skills required to become a cloud
automation engineer first off since the
role is cloud-based experience with a
cloud service platform like Microsoft as
your AWS or Google Cloud platform is an
absolute must you'll also need to have
experience with programming languages
like Python and go that will help you
make the process
of automation easier next experience
with devops tools like chef anible and
puppet are seen as a huge plus you'll
also need to have an understanding of
Docker and containers experience with
databases like post SQL and MySQL that
can handle multiple workloads would be
very useful and finally you need to have
experience with virtualization which
means you need to know how you can work
with virtual servers applications
storage and networks with this you can
reduce the amount of of resources
required by the organization now let's
have a look at the salary offered to
Cloud automation engineers in the United
States the average salary of a cloud
automation engineer is approximately
$79,000 per anom the average salary of a
cloud automation engineer in India is
approximately 5 lakh rupees perom now
that we're done let's have a look at
some of the companies hiring Cloud
automation Engineers we have companies
like Oracle Google Kappa Gemini Disney
and so on and now to number three Cloud
security manager a cloud security
manager is someone who's responsible for
providing security for cloud-based
digital platforms and protecting the
organization's data he or she may be
involved with creating new security
methods or to analyze existing ones they
may also have to create cloud-based
applications performing threat
simulations and providing security
recommendations now let's have a look at
some of the skills required to become a
cloud security manager first off you'll
need to have experience with a at least
one of the popular cloud service
providers like Amazon web services
Microsoft resure and gcp you'll also
need to have experience in programming
languages like python experience with
commonly used devops tools like jenin so
that you can Implement continuous
integration or continuous deployment
models would be very helpful you'll also
need to be well wored with TCP IP
protocols and other networking Concepts
you need to be well wored with pki SSL
SSH https and so on
experience with web-based analytics and
services would also be very helpful now
let's have a look at the salary offered
to a cloud security manager in the
United States the average salary of a
cloud security manager is approximately
$99,000 per anom in India the average
salary for cloud security manager is
approximately 11 lakh rupees perom now
let's have a look at some of the
companies hiring Cloud security managers
we have companies like deoe VMware Cisco
Dell and so on now let's move on to
number two Cloud engineer a cloud
engineer is an individual who is
responsible for any technological duties
that are associated with cloud computing
including design planning management
maintenance and support they're also
involved with orchestrating and
automating cloud-based platforms
throughout the organization let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
cloud engineer first off you'll need to
have experience with at least one of the
popular cloud service providers like AWS
Microsoft as or the Google Cloud
platform you'll need to have an
understanding of networking Concepts
like building and accessing servers
virtual networks and so on this enables
Cloud engineers make sure that the
network is responsive to the users next
you need to have experience with
virtualization with virtualization you
can reduce how many Hardware units you
need with the help of virtual machines
it also makes resources scalable and
fall tolerant in an organization
experience with the Linux operating
system would also be very help helpful
considering how 30% of the servers that
powers your are Linux based you'll need
to know about apis to design restful
Services experience with devops is also
a major skill to have since it'll be
able to help handle work dependencies
between the development and operation
teams and finally you need to have
programming experience with languages
like Java python C++ and Ruby next let's
have a look at the salary offered to a
cloud engineer in the United States the
average salary of a cloud engineer is
approximately
$105,000 perom the average salary in
India is approximately 5 lakh rupees
perom now let's have a look at some of
the companies hiring Cloud Engineers we
have companies like mecafe IBM JP Morgan
visa and so on now I see a pretty good
question in the chat how do you become a
cloud engineer so to become a cloud
engineer you need to have experience
with the programming language experience
with at least one cloud service platform
which is Amazon web services or
Microsoft is your or Google Cloud
platform the choice is yours and you
need to specialize in a particular
service be it storage networking
disaster recovery and so on and now for
number one Cloud architect a cloud
architect is responsible for managing
cloud computing architecture in an
organization he or she handles
everything to do with front-end
platforms servers storage delivery and
networks now let's have a look at some
of the skills required to become a cloud
Arch
first off you need to have knowledge in
programming knowledge about Pearl python
Ruby PHP Java and net can provide users
with the ability to build deploy and
manage applications quickly you'll need
to know about the basics of networking
since most of the work what you'll be
doing would be web related knowledge
about networking can be really helpful
knowledge about data storage
fundamentals are also really important
this provides you with the knowledge to
determine which data storage option to
use and when being experienced with
cloud service platforms is also really
important platforms like AWS Google
Cloud platform and Microsoft asure are
what you're are going to be basing most
of your work on experience with them is
pretty important and finally Cloud
security this will help you make sure
that your data is secure and only
authorized code is run and the right
people are allowed to run it now let's
talk about the salary of a cloud
architect the average salary of a cloud
architect is approximately 107 ,000
perom in India the average salary of a
cloud architect is approximately 16 lakh
rupees perom and there you go those are
the top job roles in the field of cloud
computing now let's have a look at some
of the companies hiring Cloud Architects
we have companies like ey vpro Huawei
hulet Packard Enterprise and so on so
what are we going to cover today so
we're going to introduce to the concept
of Version Control that you will use
within your Dev Ops environment then
we'll talk about the different tools are
available able in a distributed Version
Control System we'll highlight a product
called git which is typically used for
Version Control today and you'll also go
through what are the differences between
git and GitHub you may have used GitHub
in the past or other products like
gitlab and we'll explain what are the
differences between git and git and
services such as GitHub and gitlab we'll
break out the architecture of what a get
process looks like um how do you go
through and create forks and clones how
do you have collaborators being added
into your projects how do you go through
the process of branching merging and
rebasing your project and what are the
list of commands that are available to
you in git finally I'll take you through
a demo on how you can actually run git
yourself and in this instance use the
software of git against a public service
such as GitHub all right let's talk a
little bit about Version Control Systems
so you may have already been using a
version control system with any in your
environment today you may have used
tools such as Microsoft's team
Foundation services but essentially the
use of a Version Control System allows
people to be able to have files that are
all stored in a single repository so if
you're working on developing a new
program such as a website or an
application uh you would store all of
your Version Control software in a
single repository now what happens is
that if somebody wants to make changes
to the code they would check out all of
the code in the repository to make the
changes and then there would be an
addendum added to that so um there will
be the the version one changes that you
had then the person would then later on
check out that code and then be a
version two um added to that um code and
so you keep adding on versions of that
code the bottom line is that eventually
you'll have people being able to use
your code and that your code will be um
stored in a centralized location however
the challenge you running is is that
it's very difficult for large groups to
work simultaneously within a project the
benefits of a VCS system a Version
Control System should demonstrates that
you're able to store multiple versions
of a solution in a single repository now
let's take a step at some of the
challenges that you have with
traditional Version Control Systems and
see how they can be addressed with
distributed Version Control so in a
distributed Version Control environment
what we'll look looking at is being able
to have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively uh
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest um piece of code so a key part of
a distributed Version Control System
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed VCS server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those are clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software in a peer-to-peer like approach
so that as changes are being made into
the server of changes to the code then
those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed VCS environment is
git now you may remember that we
actually covered git in a previous video
and we'll reference that video for you
so we start off with our remote git
repository and people are making updates
to the copy of their code into a local
environment that local environment can
be updated manually and then
periodically pushed out to the git
repository so you're always pushing out
the latest code that you've code changes
you made into the repository and then
from the repository you're able to pull
back the latest updates and so your get
repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is git git
is a distributed Version Control tool
used for source code management so G Hub
is the remote server for that source
code management and your development
team can connect their get client to
that remote Hub server uh git is used to
track the changes of the source code and
allows large teams to work
simultaneously with each other it
supports a nonlinear development because
of thousands of parallel branches and
has the ability to handle large projects
efficiently so let's talk a little bit
about git versus GitHub so git is a
software tool whereas GitHub is a
service and I'll show you how those two
look in a moment you install the
software to for get locally on your
system whereas geub because it is a
service it's actually hosted on a
website git is actually the software
that used to manage different versions
of source code whereas GitHub is used to
have a copy of the local repository
stored on the service on the website
itself get provides command line tools
that allow you to interact with your
files whereas gith help has a graphical
interface that allows you to check in
and check out files so let me just show
you the two tools here so here I am at
the git website and this is the website
you would go to to download the latest
version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do Version Control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as
GitHub as a way to be able to store your
files so git can communicate effectively
with GitHub there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to GitHub gitlab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as Microsoft
Visual Studio are also incorporating
giit commands into their tools so the
latest version of Visual Studio team
Services also provides this same ability
but GitHub it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
sharable is a place where we can store
our files and create public sharable
projects you can come to GitHub and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment I'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects here in
fact I think there's something like over
100,000 projects being managed on GitHub
at the moment that number is probably
actually much larger than that and so if
you are working on a project I would
certainly encourage you to start at
GitHub to see if somebody's already
maybe done a prototype that they're
sharing or they have an open- source
project that they want to share that's
already available um in GitHub certainly
if you're doing anything with um Azure
you'll find that there are thousands
45,000 Azure projects currently being
worked on interestingly enough GitHub
was recently acquired by Microsoft and
Microsoft is fully embraced in
open-source Technologies so that's
essentially the difference between git
and GitHub one is a piece of software
and that's git and one is a service that
supports the ability of using the
software and that's GitHub so let's dig
deeper into the actual git architecture
itself so the working directory is the
folder where you are currently working
on your git project and we'll do a demo
later on where you can actually see how
we can actually simulate each of these
steps so you start with your working
directory where you store your files and
then you add your files to a staging
area where you are getting ready to
commit your files back to the main
branch on your git project you will want
to push out all of your changes to a
local repository after you've made your
changes and these will commit those
files and get them ready for
synchronization with the service and
will then push your services out to the
remote repository an example of a remote
rep repository would be GitHub later
when you want to update your code before
you write any more code you would pull
the latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the mainline code you can
do lots of really creative things that
ensure the that a the code remains at
very high quality and B that you're able
to seamlessly add in new features
without breaking the core code so let's
step through some of the concepts that
we have available in git so let's talk
about forking and cloning in git so both
of these terms are quite old terms when
it comes to development but forking is
certainly a term that goes way way way
way back um long before uh we had
distributed CVS systems such as ones
that we're using with G to Fork a piece
of software is a particular an open
source project you would take the
project and create a copy of that
project and but then you would then
associate a new team and new people
around that project so it becomes a
separate project in entirety a clone and
this is important when it comes to
working with GID a clone is identical
with the same teams and same structuring
as the main project itself so when you
download the code you're downloading an
exact copy of that code with all the
same security and access rights as the
main code and then you can then check
that code back in and potentially your
code because it is identical could
potentially become the mainline code uh
in the future now that typically doesn't
happen your changes are the ones that
merged into the main branch but also but
you do have that potential where your
code could become the the main code with
G you can also add collaborators that
can work on the project which is
essential for projects where
particularly where you have large teams
this works really well when you have
product teams where the teams themselves
are self-empowered you can do a concept
what's called branching in git and so
say for instance you are working on a
new feature that new feature and the
main version of the project have to
still work simultaneously so what you
can do is you can create a branch of
your code so you can actually work on
the new feature whereas the rest of the
team continue to work on the main branch
of the the project itself and then later
you can merge the two together pull from
remote is the concept of being able to
pull in Services software the team is
working on from a remote server and get
rebase is the concept of being able to
take a project and reestablish a new
start from the project so you may be
working in a project where there have
been many branches and the team has been
working for quite some time on different
areas and maybe you kind of losing
control of what the true main branch is
you may choose to rebase your project
and what that means though is that
anybody that's working on a separate
Branch will not be able to Branch their
code back into the mainline Branch so
going through the process of a get
rebase essentially allows you to create
a new start for where you're working on
your project so let's go through forks
and clones so you want to go through the
process so you want to go ahead and Fork
the code that you're working on so this
use a scenario that one of your team
wants to go ahead and add a new change
to the project the team member may say
yeah go ahead and you know create a
separate Fork of the actual project so
what do that look like so when you
actually go ahead and create a fork of
the repository you actually to go and
you can take the version of the mainline
Branch but then you take it completely
offline into a local repository for you
to be able to work from and you can take
the mainline code and you can then work
on a local version of the code separate
from the mainland Branch it's now a
separate Fork collaborators is the
ability to have team members working on
a project together so if you know
someone is working on a piece of code
and they see some errors in the code
that you've created none of us are
perfect at writing code I know I've
suddenly made errors in my code it's
it's great to have other team members
that have your bag and can come in and
check and see what they can do to
improve the code so to do that you have
to then add them as a collaborator now
you would do that uh in GitHub you can
give them permission within GitHub
itself it's really easy to do super
visual um interface that allows you to
do the work quickly and easily and
depending on the type of permissions you
want to give them sometimes it could be
very limited permissions it may be uh
just to be able to read the files some
sometimes it's being able to go in and
make all the changes you can go through
all the different permission settings on
GitHub to actually see what you can do
but you'll be able to make changes so
that people can actually have access to
your repository and then you as a team
can then start working together on the
same code let's step through branching
in git so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature and this is very typical within
a Dev Ops environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build new
feature on that Branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then develop your feature and then merge
it back into the master Branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master Branch so we
always have the latest code the circles
that we have here on the screen show
various different commits that have been
made so we can keep track of the master
branch and then the branches that have
come off which have the new features and
there can be many branches in git so git
keeps you the new features you're
working on in separate branches until
you're ready to merge them back in with
the main branch so let's talk a little
bit about that merge process so you're
starting with the master branch which is
the blue line here and then here we have
a separate parallel branch uh which has
the new features so if we're to look at
this process the base commit of feature
B is the branch f is what's going to
merge back into the master branch and it
has to be said there can be so many
Divergent branches but eventually you
want have everything merg back into the
master Branch let's step through git
rebase so again we have a similar
situation where we have a branch that's
being worked in parallel to the master
branch and we want to do a get rebase so
we're at stage C and what we've decided
is that we want to reset the project so
that everything from here on out with
along the master branch is the standard
product however this means that any work
that's been done in parallel as a
separate Branch will be adding in new
features along this new rebased
environment now the benefit you have by
going through the rebase process is that
you're reducing the amount of storage
space that's required for when you have
so many branches it's a great way to
just reduce your total footprint for
your entire project so get rebase is the
process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the primary reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase you unplug a branch and
replug it in on the tip of another
branch and usually you do that on the
master branch and that will then then
become the new Master Branch the goal of
rebasing is to take all the commits from
a feature branch and put it together in
a single Master branch and makes it the
project itself much easier to manage
let's talk a little bit about pull from
remote Suppose there are two developers
working together on an application the
concept of having a remote repository
allows the code to the two developers
will be actually then checking in their
code into a remote Repository that
becomes a centralized location for them
to be able to store their code it
enables them to stay updated on the
recent changes to the repository because
they'll be able to pull the latest
changes from that remote repository so
that they are ensuring that as
developers are always working on the
latest code so you can pull any changes
that you have made to your for remote
repository to your local repository the
command to be able to do that is written
here and we'll go through a demo of how
to actually do that command in a little
bit good news is if there are no changes
you'll get a notification saying that
you're already up to date and if there
is a change it will merge those changes
to your local repository and you get a
list of the changes that have been made
remotely so let's step through some of
the commands that we have in git so get
in it initializes a local git repository
on your hard drive git add adds one or
more files to your staging area get
commit dasm commit message is a commit
changes the git command commits changes
to head up so the get command commits
changes to your local staging area get
status checks the status of your current
repository and lists the files you have
changed getlog provides a list of all
the commits made on your current Branch
get diff views the changes that you've
made to the file so you can actually
have files next to each other you can
actually see the differences between the
two files uh get push origin branch name
so the name of your branch command will
push the branch to the remote repository
so that others can use it and this is
what you do at the end of your project
get config D Global username will tell g
Who You Are by configuring the author
name and we'll go through that in a
moment get config Global user email will
tell get the author of by the email ID
get clone creates a g repository copy
from a remote Source get remote ad
origin server connects the local
repository to the remote server and adds
the server to be able to push to it get
branch and then the branch name will
create a new Branch for you to create a
new feature that you may be working on
uh get checkout and then the branch name
will allow you to switch from one branch
to another Branch get merge Branch name
Will merge a branch into the active
Branch so if you're working on a new
feature you can then merge that into the
main branch a get rebase will reapply
commits on top of another base tip and
get rebase will reapply commits on top
of another base tip and these are just
some of the popular git commands there
are some more but you can certainly dig
into those as you're working through
using git so let's go ahead and run a
demo using get so now we are going to do
a demo using get on our logo machine and
GitHub as the remote repository for this
to work I'm going to be using a couple
of tools first I'll have the deck open
as we've been using up to this point uh
the second is I'm going to have my
terminal window also available and let
me bring that over so you can actually
see this and the terminal window is
actually running git bash as the
software in the background which you'll
need to download and install you can
also run git bash locally on your
Windows computer as well and in addition
I'll also have the GitHub repository
that we're using for simply learn uh
already set up and ready to go all right
so let's get started so the first thing
we want to do is create a local
Repository so let's go ahead and do
exactly that so the local repository is
going to reside in my development folder
that I have on my local computer and for
me to be able to do that I need to
create a drive in that folder so I'm
going to go ahead and change the
directory so I'm actually going to be in
that folder before I actually create
make the new folder so I'm going to go
ahead and change
directory and now I'm in the development
directory I'm going to go ahead and
create a new
folder
and that's gone ahead and created a new
folder called hello
world I'm going to move my cursor so
that I'm actually in the hello world
folder and now that I'm in the hello
world folder I can now initialize this
folder as a git repository so I'm going
to use the git command in it to
initialize and let's go ahead and
initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here I have my hello
allall folder that I've created and
you'll now see that we have a hidden
folder in there which is called doget
and we expand that we can actually see
all of the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so that we
can see the rest of the work and now if
we check on our folder here we actually
see this is users Matthew uh development
hello world doget and that matches up
with hidden folder here
so we're going to go ahead and create a
file called readme.txt in our folder so
here is our hello world folder and I'm
going to go ahead and using my text
editor which happens to be
Sublime I'm going to create a file and
it's going to have in there text hello
world and I'm going to call this one
read
me.txt
if I go to my Hello World folder you'll
see that we have the readme.txt file
actually in the folder what's
interesting is if I select the get
status command what it'll actually show
me is that this file has not yet been
added to the commits yet for this
project so even though the file is
actually in the folder it doesn't mean
that it's actually part of the project
for us to do that we actually have to go
and
select
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the git status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the git status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders have been committed
and what we can now do is we can go and
actually add the read me file so let's
go ahead and we just going to sel add
git add so the git command is ADD
readme.txt so that then adds that file
into our main um project and we want to
then commit those files into the main
repositories history and so to that do
that we'll hit the the get command
commit and we'll do a message in that
commit and this one will
be first
commit and it has committed that project
what's interesting is we can now go back
into readme file and I can change this
so we can go hello git git is a very
popular version control
solution and
we'll
we'll save that now what we can do is we
can actually go and see if we have made
differences to the read me text so to do
that we'll use the diff command forget
so we do get
diff and it gives us two um releases the
first is what the original text was
which is hello world and then what we
have afterwards is what is now the new
text in green which has replaced the
original
text so what we're going to do now is
you want to go ahead and create an
account on GitHub we already have one so
what we're going to do is we're going to
match the account from GitHub with our
local account so to do that we're going
to go ahead and set get
config and we're going to do Dash and
it's going to be a global user.name and
we're going to put in our username that
we use for GitHub in this instance we're
using the simply
[Music]
learn Das GitHub account
name and under the GitHub account you
can go ahead and create a new repository
name in this instance we call the
repository uh
hello-world and what we want to do is
connect the local GitHub account with
the remote hell World doget account and
we do that by using this command uh from
git which is our remote connection and
so let's go ahead and type that in open
this up so we can see the whole thing so
we're going to type in get remote add
origin
https back SL back
slash
github.com
simply
learn Das GitHub and you have to get
this typed in correctly when you're
typing in the location
hello-world
doget that creates the connection to
your hello world account and now what we
want to do is we want to push the files
to the remote location using the git
push command commit get push
origin master
so we're going to go ahead and connect
to our local remote GitHub so I'm just
going to bring up my terminal window
again and so let's select get remote add
origin and we'll connect to the remote
location
github.com
slash simply
learn Das GitHub
slash
hello-world
doget oh we actually have already
connected so we're connected to that
successfully and now we're going to push
the master Gish so get push
origin master and everything is
connected and successful
and if we go out to GitHub
now we can actually see that our file
was updated just a few minutes
ago so what we can actually do now is we
can go and Fork a project from GitHub
and clone it locally so we're going to
use the um fork tool that's actually
available on GitHub let me show you
where that is located and here is our
branch tool it's actually changed more
recently with a new UI
interface and once complete we'll be
able to then pull a copy of that to our
account using the Fork's new HTTP URL
address so let's go ahead and do
that so we're going to go ahead and
create a fork of our project now to do
that you would normally go in when you
go into your project you'll see that
there are Fork options in the top right
hand corner of the screen now right now
I'm actually logged in with the default
primary account for this project so I
can't actually Fork the project as I'm
working on the main branch however if I
come in with a separate ID and here I am
I have a different ID and so I'm
actually pretending I'm somebody else I
can actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the
fork and there we are we have gone ahead
and uh created the
fork so you want to set clone or
download with this and so this is the I
select they'll actually give me the web
address I can actually show you what
that looks like I'll open up my text
editor
that's not
correct I guess that is correct so I'm
going to copy
that and I can Fork the project locally
and clone it locally I can change the
directory so I can create a new
directory that I'm going to put my files
in and then post in that content into
that fileer so I can now actually have
multiple versions of the same code
running on my
computer I can then go into the for
content and use the patchwork command to
actually so I can create a copy of that
code that we've just created we call it
that's a a clone and we can create a new
folder that we're actually putting the
work in and we could for whatever reason
we want to we could call this folder
Patchwork and that would be maybe a new
feature and then we can then paste in
the URL of the new uh directory that
would has the fork work in it and now at
this point we've now pulled in and
created a clone of the original
content and so this allows us to go
ahead and Fork out all of the work for
our project onto our computer so we can
then diver our work
separately so now what we can actually
do is we can actually create a branch of
the fork that we've actually pulled in
onto our computer so we can actually
then create our own code that runs in
that separate branch and so we want to
check out um the uh the branch and then
push the origin Branch uh down to our
computer this will give us the
opportunity to then add our
collaborators so we can actually then go
over to GitHub and we can actually come
in and add in our
collaborators and we'll do that under
settings and select collaborators and
here we can actually see we have
different collaborators that have been
added into the project and you can
actually then request people to be added
via their GitHub name or by email
address or by their full
name one of the things that you want to
be able to do is ensure that you're
always keeping the code that you're
working on fully up to dat by pulling in
all the changes from your
collaborators you can create a new
branch and then make changes and merge
it into the master Branch now to do that
you would create a folder and then that
folder in this instance would be called
test we would then move our cursor into
the folder called test and then
initialize that folder so let's go ahead
and do that so let's call um create a
new folder and we're going to first of
all change our root folder and we're
going to go
to
development and we're going to create a
new
folder call it test and we're going to
move into the test folder and we will
initialize that
folder and we're going to move some
files into that test
folder
close one test one and we're going to do
file save as and this one's going to be
test
two and now we're going to commit those
files get
add kit add and then we'll use the dot
to pull in all
files and then get
commit
DM files
committed make sure I'm in the right
folder here I don't think I
was and now that I'm in the correct
folder let's go ahead
and and
commit and it's gone ahead and added
those files and so we can see the two
files that were created have been added
into the
master and we can now go ahead and
create a new Branch we call this one get
Branch
testore
branch and let's go ahead and create a
third file to go into that that
folder this
is file three into file save as we'll
call this one test 3.
text and we'll go ahead and
add that file and do get ADD test
3.txt
and we're going to move from the master
Branch to the test
Branch get check out
testore
branch and it's switched to the test
branch and we'll be able to list out all
of the files that are in the in that
Branch
now and we want to go through and merge
the files into one area so let's go
ahead and we'll do git merge
testore
branch and it's well we've already
updated everything so that's good
otherwise it would tell us what we would
be
merging and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master
Branch there we go all merge together
fantastic and so what we're going to do
now is move from Master Branch to test
Branch so get
checkout
testore
branch and we can modify the files the
test three file that we took out and
pull that file
up and we can
now
modified and we can
then
commit that
file back in and we've had been able to
then commit the file with one changes
and and see it's the text re change that
was
made and we can now go through the
process of checking the file back in
switching back to the master branch and
ensuring that everything is in sync
correctly we may at one point want to
rebase all of the work it's kind of a
hard thing you want to do but it will
allow you to allow for managing for
changes in the future so let's switch to
it back to our test branch which I think
we're actually on we're going to create
two more
files let's go to our folder here and
let's go copy
those and that's
created we'll rename those tests
four
and
five and so we now have additional
files and we're going to add those into
our branch that we're working on so
we're going to go in and select G add-
A and we're going to commit those files
get commit D
a-m
adding two new
files and it's added in the two new
files so we have all of our files now we
can actually list them out and we we
have all the files that are in the
branch and we'll switch then to our
Master Branch we want to rebase the
master so we do get
rebase
master and that will then give us the
command that everything is now
completely up to
dat we can go get
checkout Master to switch to the master
account this will allow us to then um
continue through and rebase the test
branch and then list all the files so
they're all in the same area so let's go
get
rebase
testore
branch and now we can list and there we
have all of our files listed in
correctly and now just a quick info for
you if you want to upskill yourself
master Dev skills and land your dream
job job or growing your career then you
must explore simply learn's cohort of
various devop program simply learn
offers various certification and
postgraduate program in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like ctech and Google Cloud
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like devs methodology deployment
automation cicd Pipeline and over a
dozen others and that's not all you also
get the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
working top TI product companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a Dos
role as a fresher or moved onto a higher
paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a devops program
that fits your experience and areas of
Interest what is
Maven if we talk in the literal sense m
m means accumulator of knowledge Maven
is a very powerful project management
tool or we can call it a build tool that
helps building documenting and managing
a project but before we move forward and
dive deep into the basics of Maven let's
understand what is meant by the term
build
tool a build tool takes care of
everything for building a project it
generates a source code generates do
documentation from a source code it even
compiles the source code and packages
the compiled codes into jar of zip files
along with that the build tool also
installs the packaged code in local
repository server repository or Central
repository coming back to Maven it is
written in Java or C and it is based on
Project object model or
pom again let's have a pause and
understand what is meant by this term
project object
model a project object model or p is a
building block in Maven it is an XML
file that contains information about the
project and configuration details used
by Maven to build a project this file
resides in the base directory of the
project as pom.xml
file the PM contains information about
the project and various configuration
details it also includes the goals and
plugins used by Maven in a
project M looks for the p in the current
directory while executing a task or a
goal it reads the P gets the needed
configuration information and then runs
the
goal coming back mavl is used to
building and managing any Java based
project it simplifies the day-to-day
work work or Java developers and helps
them in their
projects now when we know the basics of
Maven let's have a look at some reasons
to know why is Maven so popular and why
are we even talking about it so let's
have a look at the need for
Maven Maven as by now we know is
popularly used for Java based projects
it helps in downloading libraries or jav
files used in the
project to to understand the part of why
do we use Maven or the need of Maven
let's have a look at some problems that
Maven
solved the first problem is getting the
jar files in a project getting the right
jar files is a difficult task where
there could be conflicts in the versions
of the two separate packages however it
makes sure all the jar files are present
in its repositories and avoid any such
conflicting
scenarios the next problem it sorted was
downloading
dependencies we needed to visit the
official website of different software
which could be a TDS task now instead of
visiting individual websites we could
visit mvn repository. comom which is a
central repository of the jar
files then Maven plays a vital role in
the creation of the right project
structure in servlets struts Etc
otherwise it won't be executed
then Maven also helps to build and
deploy the project so that it may work
properly so the next point is what
exactly Maven
does it makes the building of the
project easy the task of downloading the
dependencies and jar files that were to
be done manually can now be done
automatically all the information that
is required to build the project is
readily available
now finally M helps manage all the
processes such as building documenting
releasing and other methods that play an
integral part in managing a
project now when we know everything
about Maven let's look at some companies
that use
Maven there are over 2,000 companies
that use Maven today the companies that
use Maven are mostly located in the
United States and in the computer
science Industry Maven is also used in
Industries other than computer science
like information technology and services
financial service banking hospital and
care and much more some of the biggest
corporations that use Maven are as
follows first we have vavo then comes
Accenture followed by JP Morgan Chas and
Company then comes craft base and
finally we have have red
hat now griddle is an kind of a build
tool which can be used for the uh build
automation performance and uh it can be
used for various programming languages
primary it's being used for the uh Java
base applications it's an kind of build
tool which can help you to see that how
exactly automatically you can prepare
the builds you can perform the
automations earlier we used to do the
build activity from the eclipse and uh
we used to do it manually right but with
the help of this build tool we are going
to do it like aut automatically without
any manual efforts as such here there
are like lot of activities which we will
be doing during the build process
primary there are different activities
like compilations linkage packaging
these are the different uh tasks which
we perform during the build process so
that we can understand that how the
build can be done and we can perform the
automations uh this uh process also it's
kind of uh standardized because again if
you want to automate something standards
or a standard process is something which
we require for that before being going
ahead with that part so that's the
reason why we are getting this build
tool because this pill tool helps us to
do an standardization process to see
that how the standards can be met and
how we can proceed further with that
part also it's something which can be
used with variety of languages
programming languages Java is the
primary language for which we use the
Gradle but again other languages like
Scala Android cc++ truy these are some
of the languages for which we can use
the same tool now it's actually using
like it's referring to as an gry based
domain specific language rather than XML
because ant and MAV these are the XML
based build tools but this one is not
that uh dependent on XML it's using the
gry based domain specific language DSL
language is being used here right now um
again U it's something which can be used
to do the build uh it can further on
used to perform the test cases
automotions also there and then further
on you can deploy to the artifa also
that okay I want to push the artif to
the artify so that also that part also
you you can get it done over here so uh
primary this tool is known for doing the
build automations for the big and large
projects the projects in which the
source code the amount of source code
and uh the uh efforts is more so in that
case this particular tool makes sense
now grle includes both the pros of Maven
and uh ant but it removes the drawbacks
or whatever the uh issues which we face
during these two build tools so it's
helping us to remove all the cons which
we face during the implementation of ant
and Maven and again again all the pros
of ant and Maven is implemented with
this crle tool now let's see that why
exactly this gridle is used because
that's a very valid question that what
is the activity like what is the reason
why we use the gdel because um the first
one is that it resolves issues faced on
other build tools that's a primary
reason because we all already having the
tools like Maven and andt which is
available there but primary this gdle
tool is something which is removing all
the issues which we are facing with the
implement mation of other tools so these
issues are getting uh removed as such
second one is that it focuses on
maintainability performance and uh
flexibility so it's giving the focus on
that how exactly we can manage the big
large projects and uh we can have
flexibility that what different kind of
a projects I want to build today I want
to build in different ways tomorrow the
source code modifies gets added up so I
have the flexibility that I can change
this build scripts I can perform the
automations so a lot of flexibility is
available which is being supported by
this tool and then the last one is like
uh it provides a lot of features a lot
of plugins now this is one of the uh
benefit which we get in the case of
Mayan also that we get a lot of features
but again when we talk about cradle then
it provides a lot of plugins like let's
say that normally in a build process we
do the compilation of the source code
but sometimes let's say that we want to
build an angular or a nodejs application
now in that case we may be involved in
running some command line executions
some command line commands just to make
sure that yes we are running the
commands and we are getting the output
so there are a lot of features which we
can use like uh there are a lot of
plugins which is available there and we
will be using those uh plugins in order
to go ahead and in order to execute
those build process and doing the
automations now let's talk about the
cradle and MAV because again when we
talk about MAV like it was like
something which was primary used for the
Java but again when we are talking about
cradle so again it's just uh being used
primary for the Java here but what is
the reason that we prefer Gradle over
the CR uh MAV so what are the different
uh reason for that let's talk about that
part because this is very important we
need to understand that what is the
reason that Gradle is preferred as an
better tool for the Java as compared to
MAV when we talk about for the build
automation here now the first one is
that the uh gridle using the groy DSL
language domain specific language
whereas the MAV is considered as in
project management tool which is uh
creating the palms or XML format files
so it's being used for the Java project
but XML format is being used here and on
the other hand griddle is something
which is not using the XML formats and
uh whatever the build scripts you are
creating that is something which is
there in the groupy based uh DSL
language and on the other hand in the
pal we have to create the xmls
dependencies whatever the attributes you
putting up in the May one that's
something which is available there in
the format of XML the overall goal of
the griddle is to add functionality to a
project whereas the goal of the m is to
you know to complete a project phase
like to work on different different
project phase like compilation test
executions uh then uh packaging so uh
then deploying to artifa so these are
all different phases which is available
there into the maven but on the other
hand gridle is all about adding the
functionality that how you want to have
some particular features added up into
the build scripes in gridle there are
like we usually specify that what are
the different tasks we want to manage so
different different tasks tasks we can
add up into the case of gridle and we
can override those tasks also in case of
Maven it's all about the different
phases which is being happening over
here and it's in sequence manner so
these phases happens in the sequence
order that how exactly you can uh build
up the sequence there but in case of
griddle you can have your own tasks
custom tasks also and you can disrupt
the sequence and you can see that how
the B different steps can be executed in
a different order so Maven is something
which is a phase mechanism there but
griddle is something which is according
to the features or the flexibilities now
griddle works on the tasks whatever the
task you want to perform you uh it works
directly on those task there on the
other hand uh May is something does not
have any kind of inbuilt cach so every
time you running the build so separate
uh things of the plugins and all these
information gets loaded up which takes
definitely a lot of time on the other
hand gdle is something which is uh using
its own internal cache so that it can
make the uh builds a little bit faster
because it's not something which is
doing the things from the scratch
whatever the uh things is already being
available in the cash so it just pick
that part and from there it will proceed
further on the build Automation and
that's the reason why Gradle performance
is much faster as compared to M because
it uses some kind of a cach in there and
then helps to improve the overall
performance now let's talk about the
gridle installation because this is an
very important aspect to be done because
when we are doing the installation we
have to download the Cradle executables
right so let's see that what are the
different steps is involved in the
process of the Cradle installation so
when we talk about the Gradle
installation so there are primary four
steps which is available the very first
one is that you have to check if the
Java is installed now if the uh Java is
not installed so you can go to the open
jdk uh or you can go for the Oracle Java
so you can do the installation of the
jdk on your system so jdk8 uh is
something you can uh most commonly used
nowadays so you you can install that
once the Java is downloaded and
installed then you have to do the Cradle
uh download cradle there now once the
gridle binaries are executable uh or the
Z file gets downloaded so you can add
the environment variables and then you
can validate if the Gradle installation
is working fine as expected not so we
will be doing the Gradle installation
into our local systems and uh into the
windows platform and we'll see that how
exactly we can go for the installation
of cradle and we'll see that what are
the different version we are going to
install here so let's go back to the
system and see that how we can go for
the Gradle installation so this is the
website of the jdk of java orle Java now
here you have different jdk so from
there you can do whatever the uh option
you want to select you can go with that
so jdk8 is something which is most
commonly used nowadays like it's most
comfortable or compatible version which
is available so um in case you want to
see that if the jdk is installed into
your system all you have to do is that
you have to just say like Java hyphone
version and that will give you the uh
output that whether the Java is
installed into your system or not so in
case my system the Java is installed but
if you really want to do the
installation you have to download the
jdk installer from this website from
this article website and then you can
proceed further on that part now once
the jdk is installed so you have to go
for the Cradle installation because
cradle is something the which will be
performing the build automations and all
that stuff so you have to download the
boundaries like uh the Z file probably
in which we have the executables and all
and then we have to have have some
particular environment variables
configured so that we will be able to
have the System modified over there so
right now we have got like the prequests
as in Java version installed now the
next thing is that we have to install or
download the execute tables so uh in
order to download the latest gradal
distribution so you have to click on
this one right now over here there are
different options like uh you want to go
for 6.7 now it's having like binary only
or complete we'll go for the binary only
because we don't want to have the source
we just want the binaries and the
executables now it's getting downloaded
it's around close to 100 MB of the
installer which is there now we have to
just extra into a directory and then the
same uh path we need to configure into
the environment variable so that in that
way we will be able to see that how the
uh gridle executables will be running
and uh it will give the uh complete
output to us over here in this case so
it may take some time and once the uh
particular modifications and the
download is done then we have to extract
it and once the extraction is done so we
will be able to go back and uh have some
particular version or have the
configurations established over there so
let's just wait for some time and then
we will be continuing with the
environment variables like this one so
once the installation and the extraction
is done now we just have to go to the
downloads where this one is downloaded
we have to extract it now extraction is
required so that we can have the setup
like we can set up this path into our
environment variables and once the path
is configured and established we you
will be able to start further on that
part on the execution so meanwhile these
files are getting extracted let's see so
we already got the folder structure over
here and uh we will see like we will
give this path here there is two
environment variables we have to
configure one is the grer underscore
home and one is the um in the path
variable so we'll copy this path here so
meanwhile this is getting uh extracted
we can save our time and we can go to
the environment variable so we can right
click on this one properties in there we
have to go for the advanced systems
settings then environment
variables now here we have to give it
like
Gradle uncore home now in this one we
will not be going giving it till the bin
directory so that only needs to be there
where the gdle is extracted so we'll say
okay and uh then we have to go for the
path variable where we will be adding up
a new entry in this one we will be
putting up till the pin directory here
because the Cal executable should be
there when I'm running the grle command
so these two variables I have to
configure then okay
okay and okay so this one is done so now
you have to just open the command prompt
and see that whether the execution or
the uh commands which you're running is
is from completely successful or not so
meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all those things it will
help us to understand that how the whole
build process or how the build tools can
be integrated over there now once the
extraction is done so you have to run
like CMD
Java I version to check the version of
the Java and then the
Cradle underscore version is what you're
going to see check the version of the
Cradle which is installed and now you
can see that show that 6.7 version is
being installed over here in this case
so that's a way that how we are going to
have the crle installation performed
into our particular system so let's go
back to the content let's talk about the
credle Core Concepts here now in this
one we we are going to talk about what
are the different Core Concepts of CR
all about the very first one is the
projects here now a project uh
represents uh item to be performed over
here to be done like uh deploying an
application to a staging environment
performing some build so gdle is
something which is required uh the
projects um the gdle project which you
prepare is not having multiple tasks
which is available there which is
configured and all these tasks all these
different tasks needs to be executed
into a sequence now sequences again is a
very important part because again if the
sequence is not met properly then the uh
execution will not be done in a proper
order so that's the very important
aspect here tasks is the one in which is
a a kind of an entity in which we will
be performing a series of steps these
tasks may be like compilation of a
source code preparing a jar file
preparing a web application archive file
or ER file also we can have like in some
task we can even publish our artifacts
to the artifactory so that we can store
the those artifacts into a Shar location
so there are different ways in which we
can have these uh particular tasks
executed now build scripts is the one in
which we will be storing all this
information what are the dependencies
what are the different tasks we want to
refer it's all going to be present in
the build. Gradle file there build. grle
file will be having the information
related to what are the different
dependencies you want to download and
you want to store there so all these
things will be a part of the build
scripts now let's talk about the
features of cradle what are the
different features which we can uh use
in case of cradle
here there are different Ty type of uh
features which is available there so
let's talk about them one by one so the
very first one over here is the high
performance then um high performance is
something which we can see that we
already discussed that in case you are
using a large projects so griddle is
something which is in better approach as
compared to Maven because of the high
performance which we are getting it uses
an internal cache which makes sure that
you are using like you are doing the
builds fast F and that can give you a
higher performance over there second one
is the support it provides the support
so it yes definitely provides a lot of
support on how you can perform the
builds and it's being a latest tool
which is available there so the support
is also quite good in terms of how you
want to prepare the build how you want
to download the plugins different plugin
supports and the dependencies uh
information also there next one is multi
project build software so using this one
you can have multiple projects in case
in your repository you have multiple
projects say so all of them can be
easily built up with the help of this
particular tool so it supports multiple
project to be built up using the same
Gradle project and uh Gradle scripts so
that support is also available with this
Gradle build Tool uh incremental builds
are also something which you can do with
the help of cradle so if you have uh
done only the incremental changes and
you want to perform only the incremental
build so that can also be possible with
the help of a griddle here the uh build
scans so we can also perform the build
scans so we can use some uh Integrations
with sonar and all where we can have the
uh scans done to the source code on
understand on how the build happens or
how the source code really happens on
there so that code scan or the build
scans can also be performed with this
one and then uh it's a familarity with
Java so for Java it's something which is
uh considered as in by default not even
Java in fact Android which is also using
the Java programming language is using
the uh particular cradle over here so
that the build can be done and it can
gain uh benefits out of that so in in
all the manners in all the different
ways it's basically helping us to see
that how uh we can make sure that this
tool can help us in providing a lot of
features and that can help us to make a
reliable build tool for our Java based
projects or any other programming based
project here right now let's see that
how we can unb a Java project with a
cradle here and uh for that we have to
go back and cradle is something which is
already installed we just have to create
a directory where we can have like how
we can perform some executions we can
prepare some build scripts and we can
have a particular execution of a gdle
build happened over there so let's go
back to the machine okay so we are going
to open the terminal here and we'll see
that how we can created so first of all
I have to create a directory structure
let's say that we'll say like
gdle hyphen project now once the project
is created so we can go inside this
directory so to uh create some uh CR
related projects and preparing the files
now uh in this one we let's first create
a particular one so we will be saying
like VI
build. cradle so in this one we are
going to put like uh two plugins we are
going to use so we are going to say like
apply
plugin Java and uh then we are going to
say like
apply
Plugin app
ation so these two plugins we are going
to use and when we got this file over
here in this one so it shows like build.
gridle which is available there in this
case so two these files are available
now if you want to learn like you know
what are the different tasks you can run
like griddle tasks command over there so
griddle task will help you know that
what are the different tasks which is
available over here by processing the
build scripts and all so um this will
definitely help you to understand on
giving you the output so here here all
the different tasks are being given and
it will help you to understand that what
are different tasks you can configure
and you can work over here just like jar
files clean and all that stuff build
compile then uh init is there then all
these different uh executions assemble
then Java dog then build then check test
all these different tasks are there and
if you really want to run the Gradle
build so you can run like gdle clean to
perform the clean activity because right
now you are doing like if a build so
before before that you can have a clean
and then you can run a a specific
command or you can run The Griddle clean
build which will perform the cleanup
also and it will at the same time will
have the build process also performed
over there so build and cleanup both
will be executed over here and what is
the status whether it's a success or a
failure that will be given back to you
now in this case in the previous one if
you see that when you ran the clean the
crle clean it was only running one task
but when you go for the uh build uh
process when you run the gradal clean
build it's going to give you much more
information in fact you can also give me
uh further information like you can have
the hyph I info flag also there so that
if you want to get the details about the
uh different uh tasks which we which is
being executed over here so that also
you're going to get over here in this
one so you just have to put like hyph
iPhone Info and then all these steps
will be given back to you that how these
uh tasks will be executed and the
response will be there so that's a way
that how you can create a pretty much
simple straightforward project in form
of cradle which can definitely help you
to run some couple of cradle commands
and then you can understand that what
are the basic commands you can run and
how the configurations really works on
there right let's go back to the main
content right now let's move on to the
next one so in the next one we are going
to see that how we can prepare a griddle
build project in case of eclipse now we
are not using the local system we are
not directly creating the folders and
the files here we are actually using the
eclipse for performing the creating a
new credle project over here so let's
move on that part okay so now the
eclipse is open and uh I have opened in
this one the very first thing is that we
have to do the Gradle plugin
installation so that we can create new
projects on Gradle and uh then we have
to uh configure the path that how the
Cradle plugin can be configured on the
pref uh preferences and all that stuff
and then then we will be doing the build
process so the very first thing is that
we have to go to the eclipse
Marketplace in there we have to search
for
griddle so once the search is
done it will show us the plugins related
to Gradle so we have to go for build
ship Gradle integration so we'll click
on the install it will proceed with
installation it will download it in some
cases maybe it's part of the eclipse as
in uh in the ID so you can go to the
installed Tab and you can see that also
that if this plug-in is already
installed or not but in this case we are
installing it and uh once the
installation is done we just have to
restart the uh specific uh ones we have
to restart this uh Eclipse so that the
changes can be
reflected so it's
downloading it's downloading the Cradle
here and once that is installed we will
be able to use it over here in this case
in this scenario so we have to just wait
for that part so still downloading the
jar files so once the jar file is done
it's over the areas and download it so
after that we will be able to proceed
further on that download aspect so it's
going to take some time to download it
and once it's done we will be able to
proceed further now once the progress is
done so it's asking us for the restart
now so uh before that uh we just have to
click on restart now and then the
eclipse will be restarted all together
again here so you can do it manually or
you can go for that options just require
a restart so that the new changes can be
reflected over here so the plugins can
be activated and can be referenced here
now we have to just uh put up like the
uh you know the configuration where we
can have the system so we can go for the
gridle configuration so we can go for
Windows and then preferences now in this
case we have to go for the uh for the
ones in which the Cradle option is
available there so cradle is what we are
going to select now user home the Cradle
user home is what we need need to use
right so you want to go for the gridle
you want to go for local installation so
so all these options you can use you can
if if you go for the griddle rapper then
it will be downloading The Griddle
locally and it is going to use the
griddle W or griddle W.B file but if you
already have an installation locally so
you can prefer that also right now uh in
the previous demo we have already got
the uh griddle uh extracted so we just
have to go for the downloads in the
downloads already gdle is available so
we are going to select that part here so
this is what we are going to
select right so this represents that
this is the directory structure in which
we are having the uh mechanism so you
can either go for the build scan so you
can select the build scan also so once
this uh is Ena then all the projects
will be scanned and will be you know
published and uh it's in kind of
additional option which is available if
you really want to disable it you can
disable it also and you can go with this
configuration also so uh this is where
the particular gridle folder is being
put over here in this case and uh then
we have to just click on
apply and we just have to click on apply
and close so with this one the
particular execution is done now we will
be going for the project creation so you
can right click over here or you can go
to the file also so here we going to go
for the CH project and in this we are
going to have a Gradle project so cradle
project is what we are going to create
here and
next so we are going to say like
Gradle
project and then
next so once that is done so
finish so uh with this one when you
create the project so what will happen
that uh automatically there will be a
folder structure will be available there
right and and uh there are some uh
Gradle scripts which will also be
created there so we will be doing the
modifications there and we'll see that
how the uh particular grd build script
looks like and how we can we will be
adding some couple of uh selenium
related dependencies and we'll see that
how we can have more and more
dependencies added and what will be the
impact of those dependencies on the
overall project so that also it's very
important aspect to be considered so let
this processing May happened over there
it just creating and uh some plugins and
boundaries are getting installed and
getting downloaded so we'll see that
once the project is uh imported
completely executed over here and got
created we can extract that now if you
see here the particular option is
available about The Griddle tasks so you
can extract it also and you will be able
to know that what are the different
tasks which is available there let's see
that in the build they are running like
build these are the different tasks
which is happening inside the build
process so g g executions will be also
available over here in this case and
griddle tasks will be different will be
represented over here in this one so you
just have to extract on the gdle project
okay this is the library which is
available now uh what happens that uh
you will be able to have like settings.
Gradle in this one you will be able to
have like okay Gradle hyphen project is
something which is available there in
this one so that's what being referring
then we have over here as in these
folder structures which is created like
Source main Java this is the one source
test Java is the one which is available
as in the folder structure and source
test resources are also available here
so the main source main resources are
also available now in this case what
happens that these are the dependencies
project and external these are the
different dependencies are available
there so let's see let's add an
dependency over here in this one in the
Bild do griddle script and see that how
we can do that if we open build. gridle
file so you can see that these
dependencies are there like test
implementation junit is available there
right and then we have a implementations
of this one which is available now these
jar files when you put up it will
automatically be added up as in part of
this one as in part of the uh particular
uh dependencies over here and uh which
means that you don't have to store them
as an within the repository and
automatically they can be happened over
there so let's open a dependency page so
we will be going to mvn repository where
we will be opening a dependency link so
this is the dependency link here so slum
hyphone Java is available and it can
give you the uh dependency for all the
different options now we have for this
is the one and for GLE this is the one
here so we have to just copy this one
and uh we have to use it as inde
dependency so this is the group and this
is the name and the version which we are
using here now we have copied this one
so we will go back to the eclipse so
here we have to just put that
dependency and uh we have to just save
it so uh this is something which is
providing like selenium dependencies
which is available so now we have to
just refresh the project so right click
over here then you will be able to see
the options in the Gradle saying that
refresh cradle project now once the
moment you do that so you will be able
to do like for the first time maybe it
will take some time to download all the
dependencies which is related to
selenium but after that you will be able
to see like the dependencies will be
simply added up over here in this case
so you can see that all the selenium
related dependencies are added up for
any reason if you comment these ones and
you say like synchronize
again so you will see that all the
dependencies which you adding up from
the selenium represent uh from the
selenium perspective will be gone back
again so this is the way that how you
can keep on adding the dependencies
which is required for preparing your
build for your source code and from
there you will be able to proceed
further on the execution part so that's
the best part about this uh griddle here
so that's a way that how we are going to
prepare a griddle project within the
eclipse and now you can keep on adding
like the source code in this one and
that's a way that how the code base will
be added up over here so when we talk
about the gridle installation so there
are primary four steps which is
available the very first one is that you
have to check if the Java is installed
now if the uh Java is not installed so
you can go to the open jdk uh or you can
go for the Oracle Java so you can do the
installation of the jdk on your system
so jdk8 uh is something you can uh most
commonly used nowadays so you can
install that once the Java is downloaded
and installed then you have to do the
gridle uh download Gradle there now once
the Gradle boundaries are executable uh
or the user file gets downloaded so you
can add the environment variables and
then you can validate if the Gradle
installation is working fine as expected
not so we will be doing the Gradle
installation into our local systems and
uh into the windows platform and we'll
see that how exactly we can go for the
installation of gradel and we'll see
that what are the different version we
are going to install here so let's go
back to the system and see that how we
can go for the Gradle installation so
this is the website of the jdk of java
orle Java now here you have different
jdk so from there you can do whatever
the uh option you want to select you can
go with that so jdk8 is something which
is most commonly used nowadays like it's
most comfortable a compatible version
which is available so um in case you
want to see that if the jdk is installed
into your system all you have to do is
that you have to just say like Java
hphone version and that will give you
the uh output that whether the Java is
installed into your system or not so in
case my system the Java is installed but
if you really want to do the
installation you have to download the
jdk installer from this website from
this article website and then you can
proceed further on that part now once
the jdk is installed so you have to go
for the Cradle installation because
cradle is something the which will be
performing the build automations and all
that stuff so you have to download the
bindar like uh the Z file probably in
which we have the execut tables and all
and then we have to have have some
particular environment variables
configured so that we will be able to
have the System modified over there so
right now we have got like the prequests
as in Java version installed now the
next thing is that we have to install or
download the executables so uh in order
to download the latest gradal
distribution so you have to click on
this one right now over here there are
different options like uh you want to go
for 6.7 now it's having like binary only
or complete we'll go for the binary only
because we don't want to have the source
we just want the binaries and the
executables now it's getting downloaded
it's around close to 100 MB of the
installer which is there now we have to
just extract into a directory and then
the same uh path we need to configure
into the environment variable so that in
that way we will be able to see that how
the uh gridle executables will be
running and uh it will give the uh
complete output to us over here in this
case so it may take some time and once
the uh particular modifications and the
download is done then we have to extract
it and once the extraction is done so we
will be able to go back and uh have some
particular uh version or have the
configurations established over there so
let's just wait for some time and then
we will be continuing with with the
environment variables like this one so
once the installation and the extraction
is done now we just have to go to the
downloads where this one is downloaded
we have to extract it now extraction is
required so that we can have the setup
like we can set up this path into our
environment variables and once the path
is configured and established we will be
able to start further on that part on
the execution so meanwhile these files
are getting extracted let's see so we
already got the folder structure over
here and uh we will see like we will
give this path here there is two
environment variables we have to
configure one is the crer under home and
one is the um in the path variable so
we'll copy this path here so meanwhile
this is getting uh extracted we can save
our time and we can go to the
environment variable so we can right
click on this one
properties in there we have to go for
the advanced systems settings then
environment
variables now here we have to give it
like
Gradle underscore home now in this one
we will not be going giving it till the
bin directory so that only needs to be
there where the gridle is extracted so
we'll say okay and uh then we have to go
for the path variable where we will be
adding up a new entry in this one we
will be putting up till the pin
directory here because the gdle
executable should be there when I'm
running the gdle command so these two
variables I have to configure then okay
okay and okay so this one is done so now
you have to just open the command prompt
and see that whether the execution or
the uh commands which you're running is
is completely successful or not so
meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all those things it will
help us to understand that how the whole
build process or how the build tools can
be integrated over there now once the
extraction is done so you have to run
like
CMD Java iph version to check the
version of the Java and then the
Cradle underscore version is what you
can to see check the version of the
Cradle which is installed and now you
can see that it shows that 6.7 version
is being installed over here in this
case so that's a way that how we are
going to have the crle installation
performed into our particular system
first topic that is the birth of
selenium selenium was primarily created
by Jason Huggins in 2004 Jason an
engineer at thought workk was working on
a web application that needed to be
tested frequently he realized that the
repeated manual testing of the
application is becoming inefficient so
he created a JavaScript language that
automatically controlled the browser's
actions this program was named
JavaScript test Runner after he realized
that his idea of automating the web
applications has a lot of potential he
made the JavaScript test Runner open
source and it was later renamed as
selenium core so we know that Jason was
a person who initially created selenium
but then we must also know that selenium
is a collection of different tools and
since there are different tools there
will be several developers too to be
exact about the number of different
tools there are four different tools
that have their own creators let's have
a look at all of them the first tool is
the selenium remote control or the
selenium RC
that was created by Paul
Hammond then comes selenium grid that
was developed by Patrick light body the
third tool is the selenium IDE that was
created by shinya katani and the fourth
tool that is the selenium web driver was
created by Simon
stward we shall be learning about all
these tools in great detail As you move
forth in our video first let's have a
look at what is selenium selenium is a
very popular open- Source tool that is
used for automating the test carried on
the web browsers there may be various
programming languages like Java C python
Etc that could be used to create
selenium test
scripts this testing that is done using
selenium tool is referred to as selenium
testing we must understand that selenium
allows the testing of web application
only we can neither test any computer
software nor any mobile application
using
selenium selenium is composed of several
tools with each having its own specific
role and serving its own testing
needs moving for let's have a look at
the features of selenium which will help
us understand the reason behind its
widespread popularity so here we have a
set of features of
selenium selenium is an open source and
portable framework that has a playback
and record feature it is one of the best
cloud-based testing platform and
supports various OS and languages it can
be integrated with several testing
Frameworks and supports parallel test
execution we will be talking about all
these features in detail as we move
forward so here the first feature that
we have is open source and portable
framework this feature States that
selenium is an open- source and portable
framework for testing web applications
in addition to that selenium commands
are categorized in terms of different
classes which make it easier to
understand and
implement the second feature is the
playback and record feature the feature
states that the tests can be authorized
without learning a test scripting
language with the help of playback and
record
features the next feature says is that
selenium is a cloud-based testing
platform selenium is a leading
cloud-based testing platform that allows
testers to record their actions and
Export them as a reusable script with a
simple to understand and easy to use
interface moving forth the next feature
states that selenium supports various
operating systems browsers and
programming languages the tool supports
programming languages such as C Java
python PHP Ruby Pearl and JavaScript if
we talk about the operating systems then
selenium supports operating systems like
Android iOS Windows Linux Mac and
Solaris and the tool also supports
various browsers like Google Chrome
Mozilla Firefox Internet Explorer Edge
Opera Safari
Etc then the next feature we have is the
integr ation with testing
Frameworks selenium can be well
integrated with testing Frameworks like
test NG for application testing and
generating reports and also selenium can
be integrated with Frameworks like ant
and Maven for source code compilation
the last feature in our list is the
parallel test execution selenium enables
parallel testing which reduces time and
increases the efficiency of the test
selenium requires fewer resources as
compared to other automation testing
tools now let's move further and get to
know different selenium tools by now we
know that there are four different tools
that come under the selenium suit the
four tools are selenium remote control
selenium grid selenium IDE and selenium
web
driver we shall have a look at these
four Tools in detail one after the
another beginning with selenium remote
control selenium remote control enables
the writing of automated web
applications in languages such as Java C
Pearl Python and PHP to build complex
tests such as reading and writing files
quering a database and emailing the test
results selenium RC was a sustainable
project for a very long time before
selenium web driver came into existence
and hence selenium RC is hardly in use
today as the web driver offers more
powerful
functionalities the second tool we shall
see is the selenium
grid selenium grid is a smart proxy
server that enables the running of test
in parallel on several
machines this is made possible when the
commands are rooted to the remote web
browser instances and one server acts as
the Hub The Hub here is responsible for
conducting several test on mult multiple
machines selenium grid makes cross
browser testing easy as a single test
can be carried on multiple machines and
browsers all together making it easy to
analyze and compare the
results here there are two main
components of selenium grid Hub and the
node Hub is a server that accepts the
access request from the web driver
client rooting the Json test commands to
the remote drivers on node
and here the node refers to the Remote
device that consist of a native OS and a
remote web driver it receives the
request from the Hub in the form of a
Json test commands and executes them
using the web driver moving forth the
third tool is the selenium IDE if you
want to begin with the selenium IDE it
needs no additional setup except
installing the extension of your
browser it provides an easy to ous tool
that gives instant feedbacks selenium
IDE records multiple locators for each
element it interacts with if one locator
fails during the playback the others
will be tried until one is successful
the IDE makes the test debugging easier
with features like setting break points
and pausing
exceptions through the use of the Run
command you can reuse one test case
inside one another and also selenium IDE
can be extended through the use of
plugins they can introduce new commands
to the IDE or integrate with a third
party service the last and the fourth
tool in the selenium suit is the
selenium web driver selenium web driver
is the most critical component of the
selenium tools suit that allows cross
browser compatibility
testing the web driver supports various
operating systems like Windows Mac Linux
Unix Etc it provides compatibility with
a range of languages including python
Java and pearl along with it it provides
supports different browsers like Chrome
Firefox Opera Safari and Internet
Explorer the selenium web driver
completes the execution of test scripts
faster when compared to other tools and
also it provides compatibility with
iPhone driver HTML unit driver and
Android driver now after you know about
the tools the question arises which tool
to choose so in the next topic we shall
see different factors on the basis of
which we may decide which tool would be
more suitable for us here we shall have
a look at the reasons why one should
choose that particular tool we shall
begin with selenium remote control
selenium remote control or selenium RC
should be chosen to design a test using
a more expressive language than
Selen Selen is a set of selenium
commands that are used to test our web
applications then the selenium RC might
be chosen to run tests against different
browsers on different operating systems
the RC may be chosen to deploy tests
across multiple environments using
selenium grid it helps in testing the
applications against a new browser that
supports JavaScript and web applications
with complex Ajax based
scenarios now the second tool for which
we shall see the reasons are selenium
grid selenium grid as we learned in the
reasons for selenium RC is used to run
selenium RC scripts in multiple browsers
and operating systems
simultaneously the grid is used to run a
huge test suit that needs to be
completed at the earliest possible time
now comes the third tool the third tool
is selenium IDE selenium IDE is used to
learn about Concepts on automated
testing and selenium these Concepts
include Selen commands such as type Open
click and wait assert verify
Etc the concepts also include locators
such as ID name XPath CSS selector
Etc selenium IDE enables the execution
of customized JavaScript code using
runscript and exporting test cases in
several different formats the IDE is
used to create tests with a limited
amount of knowledge in programming and
these test cases and test suits can be
exported later to RC or web driver now
finally let's have a look at the reasons
to choose a last tool that is selenium
web driver selenium web driver uses a
certain programming language in
designing a test case the web driver is
used to test applications that are rich
in Ajax based functionalities execute
tests on HTML unit browser and create
customized test results so this is what
we're going to be covering in this
session we're going to cover what life
is like before using Jenkins and the
issues that Jenkins specifically
addresses then we'll get into what
Jenkins is about and how it applies to
continuous integration and the other
continuous integration tools that you
need in your devops team then
specifically we'll Deep dive into
features of Jenkins and the Jenkins
architecture and we'll give you a case
study of a company that's using Jenkins
today to actually transform how their it
organization is operating so let's talk
a little bit about life before Jenkins
let's see this scenario I think it's
something that maybe all of you can
relate to as developers we all write
code and we all submit that code into a
code repository and we all keep working
away writing our unit tests and
hopefully we're running our unit tests
but the problem is that the actual
commits that actually gets sent to the
code repository aren't consistent us as
developer may be based in India you may
have another developer that's based in
the Philippines and you may have another
team lead that's based in the UK and
another development team that's based in
North America so you're all working at
different times and you have different
amounts of code going into the code
repository there's issues with the
integration and you're kind of running
into a situation that we like to call
development hell where things just
aren't working out and there's just lots
of delays being added into the project
and the bugs just keep mounting up the
bottom line is the project is delayed
and in the past what we would have to do
is we'd have to wait until the entire
software code was built and tested
before we could even begin checking for
errors and this just really kind of
increased the amount of problems that
you'd have in your project the actual
process of delivering software was slow
there was no way that you could actually
iterate on your software and you just
ended up with just a big headache with
teams pointing fingers at each other and
blaming each other so let's jump into
Jenkins and see what Jenkins is and how
it can address these problems
so Jenkins is a product that comes out
of the concept of continuous integration
that you may have heard of as power
developers where you'd have two
developers sitting next to each other
coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code Jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment so there
are two ways in which you can do
continuous delivery one is through
nightly builds and one is through
continuous so the approach that you can
look at continuous delivery is modifying
the Legacy approach to building out
Solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly builds and the
way that our nightly builds would work
and operate is that as Cod developers we
would all run and have a cut off time at
the end of the day um that was
consistent around the world that we
would put our codes into a single
repository and at night all of that code
would be run and operated and tested to
see if there were any changes and a new
build would be created and that would be
referred to as the nightly build with
continuous integration we're able to go
one step further we're able to not only
commit our changes into our source code
but we can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all of their code in at arbitrary
time you you can actually do a
continuous release because what you're
doing is you're putting your tests and
your verification Services into the
build environment so you're always
running Cycles to test against your code
this is the power that Jenkins provides
in continuous integration so let's dig
deeper into continuous integration so
the concept of continuous integration is
that as a developer you're able to pull
from a repository the code that you're
working on and then you'll be able to
then at any time submit the code that
you're working on into a continuous
integration server and the goal of that
continuous integration server is that it
actually goes ahead and validates and
passes any tests that a tester may have
created now if on the continuous
integration server a test isn't passed
then that code gets sent back to the
developer and the developer can then
make the changes it allows the developer
to actually do a couple of things it
allows the developer not to break the
build and we all don't want to break
break the builds that are being created
but it also allows the developer not to
actually have to run all the tests
locally on their computer running tests
particularly if you have a large number
of tests can take up a lot of time so if
you can push that service off to another
environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your developer
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that have come up that
may be Beyond just the standard CI test
so maybe there a code the way that you
write your code isn't consistent those
errors can then be passed on easily from
the tester back to the developer to the
goal from doing all of this testing is
that you're able to release and deploy
and your customer is able to get new
code faster and when they get that code
it simply just works so let's talk a
little bit about some of the tools that
you may have in your continuous
integration environment so the cool
thing with working with continuous
integration tools is that they are all
open source at least the ones that we
have listed here all open source there
are some that are private but typically
you'll get started with open-source
tools and it gives you the opportunity
to understand how you can accelerate
your environment quickly so bamboo is a
continuous integration tool that
specifically runs multiple builds in
parallel for faster compilation so if
you have multiple versions of your
software that runs on multiple platforms
this is a tool that really allows you to
get that up and running super fast so
that your teams can actually test how
those different builds would work for
different environments and this has
integration with an and mavin and other
similar tools so one of the tools you're
going to need is a tool that allows you
to automate the software build test and
release process and buildbot is that
open-source product for you again it's
an open-source tool so there's no
license associated with this so you
going actually go in and you can
actually get the environment up and
running and you can then test for and
build your environment and create your
releases very quickly so billboard is
also written in Python and it does
support power execution jobs across
multiple platforms if you're working
specifically on Java projects that need
to be built and test then Apache Gump is
the tool for you it makes all of those
projects really easy it makes all the
Java projects easier for you to be able
to test with API level and functionality
level testing so one of the popular
places to actually store code and create
a versioning of your code is GitHub and
it's a service that's available on the
web just recently acquired by Microsoft
if you are storing your projects in
GitHub then you'll be able to use Travis
continuous integration or Travis CI and
it's a tool designed specifically for
hosted GitHub projects and so finally
we're covering Jenkins and Jenkins is a
central tool for automation for all of
your projects now when you're working
with Jenkins sometimes you'll find
there's documentation that refers to a
product called Hudson Hudson is actually
the original version of the product that
finally became Jenkins and it was
acquired by Oracle when that acquisition
happened the team behind um Hudson was a
little concerned about the direction
that Oracle May potentially go with
Hudson and so they created a hard Fork
of Hudson that they renamed Jenkins and
Jenkins has now become that open-source
project it is one of the most popular
and continuously contributed projects
that's available as open source so
you're always getting new features being
added to it it's a tool that really
becomes the center for your CI
environment so let's jump into some of
those really great features that are
available in Jenkins so Jenkins itself
is really comprised of five key areas
around easy installation easy configur
configuration plugins extensibility and
distribution so as I mentioned for the
easy installation Jenkins is a
self-contained Java program and that
allows it to run on most popular
operating systems including Windows Mac
OS and Unix you even run it on Linux it
really isn't too bad to set up it used
to be much harder than it is today the
setup process has really improved the
web interface makes it really easy for
you to check for any errors in addition
you have great built-in help one of the
things that makes tools like Jenkins
really powerful for developers and
continuous integration teams and your
devops teams as a whole when you have
plugins that you can then add in to
extend the base functionality of the
product Jenkins has hundreds of plugins
and you can go and visit the update
Center and see which other plugins that
would be good for your Dev Ops
environment suddenly check it out
there's just lots of stuff out there in
addition to the plug-in architecture
Jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure Jenkins to fit in your
environment is almost endless now it's
really important to remember that you
are extending Jenkins not creating a
custom version of Jenkins and that's a
great differentiation because the core
Foundation remains as the core Jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of Jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of Jenkins and your extensions
mature with those core Foundation the
distribution and the nature of Jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network it really will become the center
of your CI environment and it's
certainly one of the easier tools and
more effective tools for devops so let's
jump into the standard Jenkins pipeline
so when you're doing development you
start off and you're coding away on your
computer the first thing you have to do
when you're working in the Jenkin
pipeline is to actually commit your code
now as a developer this is something
that you're already doing or at least
you should be doing you're committing
your code to a get server um or to an
SVN server or similar type of service so
in this instance you'll be using Jenkins
as the place for you to commit your code
Jenkins will then create a build of your
code and part of that build process is
actually going through and running
through tests and again as a developer
you're already comfortable with running
unit tests and writing those tests to
validate your code but there may be
additional tests that Jenkins is running
so for instance as a team you may have a
standard set of tests for how you
actually write out your code so that
each team member can understand the code
that's been written and those tests can
also be included in the testing process
within the Jenkins envir environment
assuming everything past the the tests
you can then get everything placed in a
stage and release ready environment
within Jenkins and finally you're
getting ready to deploy or deliver your
code to a production environment Jenkins
is going to be the tool that helps you
with your server environment to be able
to deploy your code to the production
environment and the result is that
you're able to move from a developer to
production code really quickly this
whole process can be automated rather
than having to wait for people to
actually test your codes or going
through a nightly build you're looking
at being able to commit your code and go
through this testing process and release
process continuously as an example
company's Etsy will release up to 50
different versions of their website
every single day so let's talk about the
architecture within Jens allows you to
be so effective at applying a continuous
delivery devops environment so the
server architecture really is broken up
into two sections on the left hand side
of section you have the code the
developers are doing and submitting that
code to a source code repository and
then from then Jenkins is your
continuous integration server and it
will then pull any code that's been sent
to the source code repository and will
run tests against it it will use a build
server such as mavin to actually then
build the code and every single stage
that we have that Jenkins manages there
are constant tests so for instance if a
build fails that feedback is sent right
back to the developers so that they can
then change their code so that the build
environment can run effectively the
final stage is to actually execute
specific test scripts and these test
scripts can be written in selenium so
it's probably good to mention here that
both mavin and selenium are plugins that
run in the Jenkins environment so before
we were talking about how Jenkins can be
extended with plugins mavin and selenium
are just two very popular examples of
how you can extend the Jenkins
environment the goal to go through this
whole process again it's an automated
process is to get your code from the
developer to the production server as
quickly as possible have it fully tested
and have no errors so it's probably
important at this point to mention uh
one piece of information around the
Jenkins environment that if you have
different code builds that need to be
managed and distributed this will
require that you need to have multiple
builds being managed Jenkins itself
doesn't allow for multiple files and
builds to be executed on a single server
you need to have a multiple server
environment with running different
versions of Jenkins for that to be able
to happen so let's talk a little bit
about the Master Slave architecture
within Jenkins so what we have here is
an overview of the Master Slave
architecture within Jenkins on the left
hand side is the remote source code
repository and that remote source code
repository could be GitHub or it could
be uh Team Foundation services or the
new Azure Dev Ops Code repository or it
could be your own G repository the
Jenkins server acts as the master
environment on the left hand side and
that Master environment can then push
out to multiple other Jenkin SL
environments to distribute the workload
so it allows you to run multiple builds
and tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so Jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and the server Master is controlling how
each of those builds operate so let's
step into a quick story of a company
that has used Jenkins very
successfully so here's a use case
scenario um over the last 10 or 15 years
there has been a significant shift
within the automotive industry where
manufacturers have shifted from creating
complex Hardware to actually creating
software we've seen that with companies
such as Tesla where they are creating uh
software to manage their cars we see the
same thing with companies such as
General Motors with their OnStar program
and Ford just recently have rebranded
themselves as a technology company
rather than just a automotive company
what this means though is that the
software within these cars is becoming
more complex and requires more testing
to allow more capabilities enhancements
to be added to the core software so
Bosch is a company that specifically ran
into this problem and their challenge
was that they wanted to be able to
stream streamline the increasingly
complex Automotive software by adopting
continuous integration and continuous
delivery best practices with the goal of
being able to delight and exceed the
customer expectations of the end user so
Bosch has actually used cloudbees which
is the Enterprise Jenkins environment so
to be able to reduce them the number of
manual steps such as building deploying
and testing Bosch has in introduced the
use of cloudbees from Jenkins and this
is part of the Enterprise Jenkins
platform has significantly helped
improve the efficiencies throughout the
whole software development cycle from
automation stability and transparency
because Jenkins becomes a self- auditing
environment now the results have been
tangible previously it took 3 days
before a build process could be done and
now it's taken that same 3-day process
and reduced it to Less Than 3 hours that
is significant large scale deployments
are now kept on track and have expert
support and there is clear visibility
and transparency across the whole
operations through using the Jenkins
tools hi there I'm Samuel a
multiplatform cloud architect and I'm
very excited and honored to walk you
through this learning series about AWS
let me start the session with this
scenario let let's imagine how life
would have been without Spotify for
those who are hearing about Spotify for
the first time uh Spotify is an online
music service offering and it offers
instant access to over 16 million
licensed songs Spotify now uses AWS
Cloud to store the data and share it
with their customers but prior to AWS
they had some issues imagine using
spotify before AWS let's talk about that
back then users were often getting
errors because Spotify could not keep up
with the incre increased demand for
storage every new day and that led to
users getting upset and users canceling
the subscription the problem Spotify was
facing at that time was their users were
present globally and were accessing it
from everywhere and uh they had
different latency in their applications
and Spotify had a demanding situation
where they need to frequently catalog
the songs released esterday today and in
the future and this was changing every
new day and the songs coming in rate was
about about 20,000 a day and back then
they could not keep up with this
requirement and needless to say they
were badly looking for way to solve this
problem and that's when they got
introduced to AWS and it was a perfect
fit and match for their problem AWS
offered a dynamically increasing storage
and that's what they needed AWS also
offered tools and techniques like
storage life cycle management and
trusted adviser to properly utilize the
resource so we always get the best out
of the resource used AWS address their
concerns about easily being able to
scale yes you can scale the AWS
environment very easily how easily one
might ask it's just a few button clicks
and AWS solved spotify's problem let's
talk about how we can help you with your
organization's problem let's talk about
what is AWS first and then let's bleed
into how AWS became so successful and
the different types of services that AWS
provides and what's the future of Cl and
awsn specific let's talk about that and
finally we'll talk about a use case
where you will see how easy it is to
create a web application with AWS all
right let's talk about what is AWS AWS
or Amazon web services is a secure cloud
service platform it is also pay as you
go type building model where there is no
upfront or Capital cost we'll talk about
how soon the service will be available
well the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with AWS you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the flight and almost
all the services are available on demand
and most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak Amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how AWS became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their it
environment in aw s Adobe adob uses AWS
to provide multi- terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with AWS Cloud
adob can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure Airbnb is another company
it's an Community Marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the rbnb community commity
users activities are conducted on the
website and through iPhones and Android
applications Airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in AWS and they're almost
using all the services in AWS and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be Autodesk Autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment Industries
using services like Amazon RDS or
rational database servers and Amazon S3
or Amazon simple storage servers
Autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure AOL or
American online uses AWS and using AWS
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14,000
in-house and collocated servers and move
Mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its Global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
Bit Defender is an Internet Security
soft software firm and their portfolio
of softwares include antivirus and
anti-spyware products Bit Defender uses
ec2 and their currently running few
hundred instances that handle about 5
tab of data and they also use elastic
load balancer to load balance the
connection coming in to those instances
across availability zones and they
provide seamless Global delivery of
service because of that the BMW group it
uses AWS for its new connected Car
application that collects sensor data
from BMW 7 Series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
canons offers Imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and Global reach by using AWS
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office Imaging products
division uses AWS such as Amazon S3 and
Amazon Route 53 Amazon cloudfront and
Amazon IM for their testing development
and Production service services Comcast
it's the world's largest cable company
and the leading provider of internet
service in the United States Comcast
uses AWS in a hybrid environment out of
all the other Cloud providers Comcast
chose AWS for its flexibility and
scalable hybrid infrastructure Docker is
a company that's helping redefine the
way developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in AWS the service called
the Amazon D2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
European Space Agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and Computing
infrastructure is built on Amazon web
services Esh AWS because of its
economical pay as youo system as well as
its quick startup time the Guardian
newspaper uses AWS and it uses a wide
range of AWS services including Amazon
kineses Amazon red shift that power and
analytic dashboard which editors use to
see how stories are trending in real
time Financial Times ft is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used Amazon red
shift to perform their analysis A Funny
Thing Happened Amazon red Sho performed
so quickly that some analysists thought
it was malfunctioning they were used to
running queries over night and they
found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
Amazon red Shi f is supporting the same
business functions with costs that are
80% lower than what was before general
electric GE is at the moment as we speak
migrating more than 9,000 workloads
including 300 desperate Erp systems to
AWS while reducing its data center
footprint from 34 to 4 over the next 3
years similarly Howard Medical School
HTC IMDb McDonald's NASA Kellogg and lot
more are using the services Amazon
provides and are getting benefited from
it and this huge success and customer
portfolio is just the tip of the Ice
book and if we think why so many adapt
AWS and if we let AWS answer that
question this is what AWS would say
people are adapting AWS because of the
security and durability of the data and
endtoend privacy and encryption of the
data and storage experience we can also
rely on aw's way of doing things by
using the aw's tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in AWS that allows us to
select the OS language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in AWS be
it a new application or migrating an
existing application into AWS
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scale down depending
on the user requirement cost saving we
only pay for the compute power stor
storage and other resources you use and
that to without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that AWS
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database Security customer engagement
desktop and streaming Mission learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because AWS
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within Computer Services
we have Amazon ec2 Amazon elastic beant
stock Amazon light sale and Amazon
lambdaa Amazon ec2 provides compute
capacity in the cloud now this capacity
is secure and it is resizable based on
the users's requirement now look at this
the requirement for the web traffic
keeps changing and behind the scenes in
the cloud ec2 can expand its environment
to three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resour Source elastic beanock it helps
us to scale and deploy web applications
and it's made with a number of
programming languages elastic beanock is
also an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services deployed be it in Java net
PHP nodejs python Ruby talker and a lot
other familiar services such as Apache
passenger and IIs we can simply upload
our code and elastic beanock
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity Pro iing to load balancing
to Auto scaling to application Health
monitoring an Amazon light sale is a
virtual private server which is easy to
launch and easy to manage Amazon
lightell is the easiest way to get
started with AWS for developers who just
need a virtual private server lightell
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like SSD based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer DNS
management and a static IP and that two
for a very low and predictable price a
WS Lambda has taken Cloud Computing
Services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers and AWS Lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing servers Lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your code is not
running let's look at some storage
services that Amazon provides like
Amazon S3 Amazon Glacier Amazon abs and
Amazon elastic file system Amazon S3 is
an object storage that can store and
drive data from anywhere websites mobile
apps iot sensors and so on can easily
use Amazon S3 to store and rrive data
it's an object storage built to store
and rrive any amount of data from
anywhere with its features like
flexibility and managing data and the
durability it provides and the security
that it provides Amazon simple storage
service or S3 is a storage for the
internet and Glacier Glacier is a cloud
storage service that's used for
archiving data and longterm backups and
this Glacier is an secure durable and
extremely lowcost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long-term backups
Amazon EBS Amazon elastic Block store
provides Block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic Block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability Zone ABS volumes that are
attached to the E2 instances are exposed
as storage volumes that persistent
independently from the lifetime of the
instance an Amazon elastic file system
or EFS provides an elastic file storage
which can be used with AWS cloud service
and resources that are on premises an
Amazon elastic file system it's an
simple it's scalable it's an elastic
file storage for use with Amazon cloud
services and for on premises resources
it's easy to use and offers a simple
interface that allows you to create and
configure file systems quickly and
easily Amazon file system is built to
elastically scale on demand without
disturbing the application growing and
shrinking automatically as you add and
remove files so your application have
the storage they need and when they need
it now let's talk about databases the
two major database flavors are Amazon
Aus and Amazon red shift Amazon auds it
really eases the process involved in
setting up operating and scaling a
rational database in the cloud Amazon
Aus provides cost efficient and
resizable capacity while automating
timec consuming administrative tasks
such as Hardware provisioning database
setup patching and backups it sort of
frees us from managing the hardware and
sort of helps us to focus on the
application it's also coste effective
and resizable and it's also optimized
for memory performance and input and
output operations not only that it also
automates most of the services like
taking backups you know monitor
monitoring stuff like that it automates
most of those Services Amazon red shift
Amazon red shift is a data warehousing
service that enables users to analyze
the data using SQL and other business
intelligent tools Amazon R shift is an
fast and fully managed data warehouse
that makes it simple and cost effective
analyze all your data using standard SQL
and your existing business intelligent
tools it also allows you to run complex
analytic queries against terabyte of
structured data using sophisticated
query optimizations and most of the
results they generally come back in
seconds all right let's quickly talk
about some more services that AWS offers
there are a lot more services that AWS
provides but we're going to look at some
more services that are widely used AWS
application Discovery Services help
Enterprise customers plan migration
projects by gathering information about
their un premises data centers you know
planning a data center migration can
involve thousands of workloads they are
often deeply interdependent server
utilization data and dependency mapping
are important early first step in
migration process and this AWS
application Discovery service collects
and presents configuration usage and
behavior data from your servers to help
you better understand your workloads Rod
53 it's a network and content delivery
service it's an highly available and
scalable Cloud domain name system or DNS
service and Amazon Route 53 is fully
compliant with IPv6 as well elastic load
balancing it's also a network and
content delivery service elastic load
balancing automatically distributes
incoming application traffic across
multiple targets such as Amazon ec2
instance containers and IP addresses it
can handle the varing load of your
application traffic in a single
availability zones and also across
availability zones a is auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using AWS Auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes autoscaling can be applied to
web services and also for DB Services
AWS identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to AWS
services and resources securely using IM
you can create and manage AWS users and
groups and use permissions to allow and
deny their access to AWS resources and
moreover it's a free service now let's
talk about the future of AWS well let me
tell you something cloud is here to stay
here's one in store for AWS in the
future as years pass by we're going to
have variety of cloud applications Bond
like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
Computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as I was mentioning some time
back lot or greater Focus will be given
to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies is
moving into the cloud all right let's
now talk about how easy it is to deploy
an web application in the cloud so the
scenario here is that our users like a
product and we need to have a mechanism
to receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and uh you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need all right though the setup
and the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because AWS has tools and Technologies
which can help us to achieve it now we
going to use services like Route 53
services like cloudwatch ec2 S3 and lot
more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
uh like using the services like Route 53
cloudwatch ec2 and S3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all I want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the new comings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intense of
the workloads we're also going to use S3
for storage and S3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloud watch for
monitoring the environment and Cloud
watch monitors the application and the
environment and it provides trigger for
scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we're also going to
use Route 53 for DNS and Route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and Technologies together all of them
put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
CS are need all right so I'm going to
use elastic beanock for this project and
the name of the application is going to
be as you see GSG signup and the
environment name is GSG signup
environment 1 let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that I have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic bean stock this
is going to launch an instance it's
going to launch uh the monitoring setup
or the monitoring environment it's going
to create a load balance as well and
it's going to take care of all the
security features needed for this
application all right look at that I was
able to go to that URL which is what we
gave and it's now having an default page
shown up meaning all the dependencies
for the soft software is installed and
it's just waiting for me to upload the
code or in specific the page required so
let's do
that let me upload the code I already
have the code saved
here that's my code and that's going to
take some time all right it has done its
thing and now if I go to the same URL
look at that I'm being thrown an
advertisement page all right so if I
sign up with my name email and stuff
like that you know it's going to receive
the information and it's going to send
an email to the owner saying that
somebody had subscribed to your service
that's the default feature of this app
look at that email to the owner saying
that somebody had subscribed to your app
and this is their email address stuff
like that not only that it's also going
to create an entry in the database and
Dynamo DB is the service that this
application uses to store data there's
my Dynamo DB and if I go to tables right
and go to items I'm going to see that
that a user with name Samuel and email
address so and so has said okay or has
shown interest in the preview of my site
or product so this is where or this is
how I collect those information right
and some more things about the
infrastructure itself is it is running
behind an load balancer look at that it
had created a load balancer it had also
created an autoscaling group now that's
the feature of elastic load balancer
that we have chosen it has created an
Autos Skilling group and now let's put
this URL you see this it's it's not a
fancy URL right it's an Amazon given URL
a dynamic URL so let's put this URL
behind our DNS let's do that so go to
Services go to rout
53 go to hosted Zone and there we can
find the DNS name right so that's a DNS
name all
right all right let's create an
entry and map that URL to to our load
balancer right and create now
technically if I go to this URL it
should take me to that application all
right look at that I went to my custom
URL and now that's pointed to my
application previously my application
was having a random URL and now it's
having a custom URL without further Ado
let's dive head first and before that if
you are one of the aspiring Cloud
Enthusiast looking for online training
and gradu from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers in cloud computing by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learns postgraduate
programming cloud computing in
collaboration with ctech Center for
technology and management education the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered so let's Dive Right In the
details and explore the magic behind AWS
step functions so the first thing we
will explore is
understanding the AWS step function
challenges so before we get into the
specifics of AWS step functions let's
understand the problem IT addresses as
you build larger applications with many
different parts managing and
coordinating them can become quite
tricky absolutely imagine you have a
bunch of different task that need to
happen in a specific order to complete a
big project for example if you want to
build a house you need to follow a
specific sequence of steps like laying
the foundation building the walls
putting on the roof and so on but what
if something goes wrong in the middle of
the process like the wall building part
doesn't work correctly or you run out of
bricks that's where the challenge lies
with traditional methods handling these
errors and coordinating everything can
become a nightmare and here comes the
AWS step functions now we'll have an
introduction to AWS stem functions so
here AWS stem function comes to rescue
with these challenges
so AWS St functions are like having a
master conductor who organizes and
orchestrates all the task in your
application it helps you build workflows
as a series of steps or tasks making it
easier to manage the entire process
that's right just like a conductor
guides the musicians in an orchestra to
play their instruments at the right time
AWS step functions guides you different
services and functions to work together
harmoniously it does this by using
something called State machines so a
state machine is like a big map that
shows all the different steps your
application needs to take to finish its
work each step in the state machine is a
specific task that your application
needs to do it could be running a piece
of code processing some data or even
making decisions based on certain
conditions and now we'll see the
components of AWS step functions now
that we have basic understanding let's
talk about the key components of a WS
step functions the first and most
important component is the state each
state represents a single task or a step
in your workflow and there are different
types of States like task choice and
parallel a task state does a specific
job like running a Lambda function or an
activity a choice State makes decisions
based on conditions and a parallel State
lets you do multiple task at once that's
right and what's really cool is that AWS
step functions automatically manages the
flow between these states it makes sure
that each task happens in the right
order just like following the steps to
build a house and here's the best part
if something goes wrong during one of
the task AWS step functions can handle
it it can retry the task a few times or
even go to different part of the
workflow to deal with the problem and
now you can see the state machine
diagram on the screen so this state
machine starts with the start state
which represents the beginning of the
workflow from the start state it goes to
the the check item stock that is a state
which is a task state that checks if the
requested item is available in the
stores inventory after completing the
check item stock task the state machine
proceeds to process payment State
another task test that processes the
customer's payment based on the choosen
payment method the notify method state
is a choice state that evaluates whether
the customer prefers to be notified via
email or SMS if the customer prefers
email the state machine goes to notify
customer email state which is a task
state that sends an order confirmation
email to the customer if the customer
prefers SMS the state machine goes to
notify customer SMS state which another
task State like which is another task
state that sends an order confirmation
SMS to the customer the parallel state
is responsible for running both notify
customer email and notify customer SMS
task simultaneously once the task in the
parallel state are completed the state
machine reaches the end state which
marks the end of the workflow the visual
representation of the state machine
provides a clear overview of how AWS
step functions coordinate in the
different task and branches in the
workflow it helps in understanding the
flow and logic of the serverless
application and enables developers to
manage and modify the workflow
efficiently and now we'll see how AWS
step functions work and now let's see
how they will work imagine you are a
chef and you want to bake a cake you
have different steps like mixing the
ingredients putting the batter in the
oven and decorating the cake with AWS
step functions you can define a state
machine for baking a cake the state
machine will list all these steps and
the order they need to happen in so when
you start the state machine it will take
you through each step one by one just
like following a recipe and if you
accidentally put too much sugar in the
ble AWS step functions can handle that
it can go back back and give you another
chance to mix the right amount of sugar
or if the oven suddenly stops working
AWS step functions can pae the baking
process and wait for the oven to be
fixed before continuing and now we'll
see the benefits of AWS step functions
AWS step functions offer several
benefits let's highlight a few of them
first they make your application more
reliable with built-in error handling
and automatic retries you can be
confident that your workflows will work
smoothly even if something goes wrong
absolutely and AWS step functions also
make your life as a developer easier the
visual workflow designer in the AWS
Management console allows you to see and
modify your workflows graphically plus
it's highly scalable as your application
grows AWS step functions can handle more
and more complex workflows without a
hitch and let's not forget about cost
Effectiveness you only pay for the state
Transitions and the time your work
workflows are running which means you
can save money while building powerful
applications so these were the benefits
of AWS step functions now we'll see the
real world use cases AWS step functions
are incredibly versatile and can be used
in many real world scenarios for example
if you have a big online store you can
use AWS step functions to handle the
entire order process from receiving the
order to receiving the payment checking
the inventory and finally shipping the
products and let's not forget about data
processing AWS step functions are
perfect for automating data pipelines
where you need to extract transform and
load data from one place to another it's
also a great tool for managing
microservices if you have different
parts of your application running
independently AWS step functions can
help you coordinate their interactions
and now we conclude this topic that is
AWS step functions so to wrap things up
AWS step functions are like having a
magical conductor for your application
they make it easier to manage and
coordinate all the different tasks in
your serverless workflows with AWS step
functions you get reliability Simplicity
scalability and cost Effectiveness all
in one package so if you're working on
AWS and want to simplify your serverless
architecture give AWS step functions a
try and now let's take a minute to hear
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in the
careers I will be permanently moving to
Europe with my family soon simply Lear
course has helped me back a great job
offer there with 60% salary hike we
cannot wait to start our new life in
Finland we are also excited hey I am
Salah quatra and I am currently living
in Algeria I'm working as Chief
Information Technology officer at aryes
after working for 23 years in it sector
in Algeria I felt that my career had
become stagnant here I wanted to
experience what is like to leave in
Europe so I started applying to various
jobs there as someone who is responsible
for making decision I wanted to upgrade
my skills I also realized that to get a
new job I needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the post graduate program
in cloud computing in association with
ctech from slear it's not easy to get
access to C but simply provided that
with this course I had a choice to study
while I continued with my
job I learned Technologies like ews and
aure during the C luckily my new
employers were looking for someone who
knew these Technologies I have just
completed the course but my new
employers were aware that I was taking
this course
and that is how I got this new job offer
with 60% salary high in Finland I will
be leading the cloud computing unit of
my new
company I'm really excited not just for
myself but for my family as well I have
three daughters I think I will be able
to help them with their higher studies
in Europe as a father you always want to
make decision not have a positive impact
on your children as for me I'm going to
live my dream now I think dreams come
through when you work hard to achieve
them welcome to this video about AWS
Bedrock if you're new to cloud or
looking to get up to the speed on AWS
this is the perfect place to start AWS
Bedrock is a foundation considering of a
set of AWS services that can be used to
build reusable and scalable applications
in this video we will will cover what
AWS Bedrock consists of and why it's
important to use it whether you are a
season developer or just getting started
you will learn about AWS bedrock in just
a minutes so let's dive in but before
that cloud computing is a highly
technical field and having a right
certification can set you apart from the
competition consider getting certified
in popular cloud computing platforms
like AWS aor or Google Cloud now to help
you with this step we have our keltech
postgraduate program in cloud computing
this course will help you become an
expert in edor AWS and gcp and let you
master fundamental architecture
principles and develop the skills needed
to become a cloud expert this
post-graduate program in cloud computing
will help you become an expert in
designing planning and scaling Cloud
implementations after completing this
course you will gain keltech ctme
postgraduate certificate with 40 plus
Hands-On projects you can check out its
Link in the description box below hey I
am Salah
and I am currently living in Nigeria I
wanted to experience what is like to
leave I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech with this course I had the
choice to study while I continue and
that is how I got this new job offer
with 60% Sal hi in Finland I will be
leading the cloud computing unit of my
new company we cannot wait to start our
new life in Finland we are also EXC now
let's see the agenda for this video in
this video we will see what is Amazon
bedro after that we will see what can
Amazon bedro do moving ahead we will see
what is a foundational model and then we
will see the use cases of AWS bedrock
and conclude this video so there is no
doubt that major tech companies are
actively completing to gain a
significant share of a rapidly expanding
artificial intelligence Market the
release of open AI revolutionary chart
GPT service has further intensify this
race capturing the both interest of it
and non-it professionals according to
various reports the IT industry is
predicted to survey to a value of $90
billion or more than that by
2025 now let's see what is a Amazon
bedro Amazon bedro is a recently
launched machine learning platform by
Amazon web services that provides user
with a convinced way to build and expand
AI application using foundational model
also known as FMS this platform greatly
accelerates the development process by
leveraging foundational model without
the need of handle physical
infrastructure or the Associated
operational
complexities also users have the
flexibility to choose from a variety of
foundational models including those
offered by AI 21 Labs atropic or
internally by AWS additionally
organization can customize these
Foundation model using their own data
and utilize similar AWS tools and
capabilities ensuring the development of
scalable and highly secure generative AI
applications now let's see what Amazon
Bedrock can do Amazon Bedrock a
userfriendly machine learning platform
similar to Amazon Sage maker enables the
building and scaling of a generative AI
application using Foundation model
unlike the sage maker which ml Engineers
primarily use for custom model
development Bedrock focuses on
leveraging FMS for ease of use now you
must be thinking what FM is now now
let's see what is a foundation
model foundational model also known as
FMS are models that are trained on
diverse data and can be adapted by
multiple Downstream tasks unlike High
Learning model designed for specific use
cases foundational models serve as a
foundation that can be utilized across
various applications instead of
investing extensive time and resources
into training separate custom models for
spefic specific task the focus is on the
building adaptable and versatile model
capable of Performing multiple functions
this approach promotes efficiency by
creating a model that can handle various
tasks rather than a specified model
limited to a single process now you must
have gotten the idea what foundational
model is now let's see the use cases of
Amazon
bedro text generation it enables the
generation of or originally written
content such as short stories social
media post articles web page copy and
even School
essays now we have chat boards Bedrock
facilitates the creation of conventional
interfaces like chat boards and virtual
assistance to ensure user experience
integration with Amazon Le AWS chatboard
Services may be possible next we have
search in search user can easily search
find and get the information from a
diverse data sources allowing various
questions moving ahead we have text
summarization this platform offers the
capability to summarize text content
from sources like blog post essays books
and documents providing conscious
summaries without the need for lengthy
reading next we have image generation
Amazon bedro can generate the real istic
and artistic image based on specific
subject environment and scenes next we
have personalization the platforms AI
service enables personalized customer
interaction allowing user to search for
exactly what they are looking for with
the relevant product key recommendations
now Amazon Bedrock empowers user to
build and scale generative AI
application for TAS such as text
generation chat boards search and text
summarization image generation and
personalization of approach to
leveraging foundational models now in
conclusion Amazon Bedrock is a powerful
machine learning platform offered by AWS
along user to build and scale generative
AI application using foundational model
with the rapid growth of the AI Market
Amazon Bedrock position itself as a
valuable tool for organization looking
to of generative AI without the
complexities of custom model development
by leveraging foundational model user
can unlock the potential of AI in areas
such as text generation chat boards
search summarization image generation
and personalization driving Innovation
and ensuring user experience welcome to
the realm of cutting Ed technology have
you ever wondered what it would like to
harness the immense power of Google's
Computing infrastructure right at your
fingertips look no further for in
digital run that there exist a Phenom
known as Google collab an interesting
Fusion of cloud computing and
collaborative progess imagine a world
where you can effortlessly explore the
Limitless possibilities of artificial
intelligence machine learning and data
analysis without the need for expensive
Hardware or complex setups Google collab
emerges as Celestial Century offering
you a virtual laboratory to experiment
create and collaborate with like-minded
enthusiasts from every corner of the
globe in this exciting video we will
understand what is Google collab and
then we will have a complete overview of
it so let's start with the first topic
what is Google
collab so Google collab is a free online
tool that lets you do coding and data
related work on the Internet it's like
having a virtual notebook where you can
write and run python code without
needing to install anything on your
computer with collab you can also get
data from different places and share
your work with others easily another
cool thing is that it gives you access
to powerful processors like gpus and
tpus which make t like machine learning
and data science faster and more
efficient so it's a great tool for
Learning and working on coding and data
projects all right now let's have a look
at Google collab let's have a complete
overview of
it so first of all Google collab
requires a Google account for access to
begin visit the link welcome to
collaboratory write
welcome to collaboratory as you can see
we'll click on
this then we'll click on this open this
one and sign in using our Google account
or credentials if we have already have a
Google account then you can just sign in
with
that all right now let's start with the
Google collab we'll simply
WR Google
cab we'll click on
this all right so this is the window
that appears when it click on that first
of all here we have is example tab so
the example tab offers some initial
examples to help you begin using collab
for a comprehensive understanding of
collaborative features and efficient
usage of collab documents refer to the
document title overview of collaboratory
features it covers the fundamental
aspects to get you started
efficiently then there is recent tab all
right so the recent tab displays a
collection of all the latest latest
documents you have been working on all
right now next is our Google Drive tab
the Google Drive tab features allows you
to import any of your previous notebooks
directly from your Google Drive all
right then next is GitHub tab so with
the GitHub tab you have the option to
import notebooks from your own GitHub
repository or any public repository
simply provide the GitHub URL and you
can easily import notebooks from the
desired public Repository then we have
is upload tab so the upload feature
allows you to bring and work on your own
J notebooks that you have created on
your computer you can easily upload any
file from your local Machine by
selecting the choose file option here it
is choose file option now next is our
creating a notebook as you can see
here's a new notebook option and there's
a cancel option so creating a notebook
so to create a new notebook you have the
option to use the new notebook button
located at the bottom Bottom by clicking
on this button a new Untitled notebook
will be generated to give it a specific
name and simply click on the current
untitle name if we want to name it so as
we have clicked on it yeah to give it a
specific name as we just said simply
click on the current untitle name on The
Notebook and make the desired changes so
let's say we want to make
it
sp1 let's just say it name all right so
next is our
cell here we can see this is a cell in a
notebook cell serve as the fundamental
building blocks encompassing everything
within there are two types of cells
actually one is code cell as we can see
it contains executable code and has a
run button on the left side to execute
its
content this one all right the output is
displayed its output is displayed below
the code cell after running right then
the next one is other one is text cell
so a text cell can include text images
links and more you can edit its content
by double clicking it the text cell
supports markdown markup language but
you can also use the provided options on
top on the top for formatting the right
half of the cell shows you how your edit
text will
appear all right now the next point
would be add adding a new cell like how
to add a new cell to add a new code or
text cell use the respective option at
the top of the work area as you can see
these code or text by clicking on these
we can add code cell and text cell so
clicking on any of these buttons creates
a new cell right below the current one
you can like let's say we want to add
this so now we want to add this you can
add this also now you can rearrange the
cell order using the arrow option
located at the top right corner of each
cell as you can
see by using these we can do
that yeah the up Arrow moves the cell
one position up while the down arrow
moves it down by one
position as we can see now adding and
running a code let's talk about this so
by default Google collab provides One
initial code cell which can be
supplemented with additional cells as
desired these cells serve as a platform
for writing and executing python code
for instance let's consider the
following code let's say first of all I
have to let us delete all
these this one
also yeah so first of all we'll try one
code let's see how it goes so we'll
simply write the code
print yeah
print my favorite
color is yellow all right so now let's
try to execute it we can run it by
clicking on this it is running executing
so as you can see my favorite color is
yellow is being printed so you can
either press on this play button to run
the code or you can press control+ enter
to run the code as you can see control+
enter to run the cell now next is
changing the order of the cell so in
Google collab you have multiple options
for rearranging cells you can utilize
the upell and down cell buttons located
in the toolbar above the notebook as we
discussed previously alternate itively
you can employ keyboard shortcuts such
as control shift up or control shift
down to move the chosen cell up or down
Additionally you have the flexibility to
reorder cells by clicking on the cell
number in the left Gutter and dra
dragging it to a different position all
right now deleting the current tab so to
delete the current tab in Google collab
you can use the delete icon available
over the top of the cell this icon looks
like a trash can and it will remove the
selected cell from The Notebook as we
can see this is the trash can and this
is just at the right above corner of the
cell by clicking on this we can delete
the tab alternately you can also use the
keyboard shortcut control+ m and d to
delete the current cell you can also
right click on the cell and select
delete cells from the context menu as
you can see delete cell all right now we
will understand how to add data sets so
to add data sets from your local device
go to the left corner and click on the
folder icon as we can see this is the
left corner and this is the folder icon
we'll click on that now click on the
upload icon and upload the desired file
this is the upload icon we'll click on
that now we can upload the desired file
whichever we
want all right you can also upload files
by writing a particular command let's
try writing that command okay so we'll
write
from
will
collab import files let's import files
right after that we'll
write upload
equals files
do
upload after that we'll put on
brackets all right now we'll press
control and
enter and here we can see choose files
now from here you can choose files so
both the ways you can upload files I'm
just
telling now let's understand how to like
import libraries in Google
collab so first of all we have to cancel
we click on this all right so to import
it we'll
write import
pandas as
PD all right after that
we'll write pd.
read so here we are importing the CSV
files actually so we have to write like
xd. rore
CSV and inside this we'll write
a file let's say I have to check what
what all files like this is the sample
data files right so you have to write
the file name actually which you want to
import that CSV file name I'm writing
sample undor data I'll
write test the location you have to
put do
CSV so this is the
location all right so if we want to
display 10 rows we'll
write DF do
head right
10 we'll press control and
enter and we can see 10 rows are being
displate so this is how you can import
and like showcase the data and
all so this was about the Google collab
we have covered major things in that
many important things in that there are
there must be many more things in that
that you will explore when you will
start using it so after understanding
about Google collab and hearing about
various Cloud Technologies if you want
to become a cloud engineer then check
our postgraduate program in cloud
computing our comprehensive course
covers Microsoft AO AWS and gcp
empowering you to deploy Dynamic and
independable application seamlessly
discover the Ines of these leading Cloud
platforms and master the core skill sets
needed for Success join us to transform
your career and step confidently into
the world of cloud computing enroll now
and embark on an exciting Journey
towards a bright future in the cloud
industry don't miss this opportunity
so let's take a little scenario of a
developer and a tester before you had
the world of Docker a developer would
actually build their code and then they
send it to the tester but then the code
wouldn't work on their system the code
doesn't work on the other system due to
the differences in computer environments
so what could be the solution to this
well you could go ahead and create a
virtual machine to be the same of the
solution in both areas but we think
docker as an even better solution so
let's kind of break out what the main
big differences are between Docker and
virtual machines as you can see between
the left and the right hand side both
look to be very similar what you'll see
however is that on the docker side what
you'll see as a big difference is that
the guest OS for each container has been
eliminated Docker is inherently more
lightweight but provides the same
functionality as a ver virtual machine
so let's step through some of the pros
and cons of a virtual machine versus
Docker so first of all a virtual machine
occupies a lot more memory space on the
host machine in contrast Docker occupies
significantly less memory space the boot
up time between both is very different
Docker just boots up faster the
performance of the docker environment is
actually better and more consistent than
the virtual machine Docker is also very
easy to set up and very easy to scale
the efficiencies therefore are much
higher with a Docker environment versus
a virtual machine environment and you'll
find it is easier to Port Docker across
multiple platforms than a virtual
machine finally the space allocation
between Docker and a virtual machine is
significant when you don't have to
include the guest OS you're eliminating
a significant amount of space and the
docker environment is just inherently
smaller so after Docker as a developer
you can build out your solution and send
it to a tester as long as we're all
running in the docker environment
everything will work just great so let's
step through what we're going to cover
in this presentation we're going to look
at the devops tools and where Docker
fits within that space we'll examine
what Docker actually is is and how
Docker works and then finally we'll step
through the different components of the
docker environment so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development team the operation team
allowing you to continuously deliver
Solutions and applications and services
that both delight and improve the
efficiency of your customers if you look
at the vend diagram that we have here on
the left hand side we have development
on the right hand side we have operation
and then there's a crossover in the
middle and that's where the devops team
sits if we look at the areas of
integration between both groups
developers are really interested in
planning code building and testing and
operations want to be able to
efficiently deploy operate and monitor
when you can have both groups
interacting with each other on these
seven key elements then you can have the
efficiencies of an excellent devops team
so planning and cbase we use tools like
jit and gear ER for building we use
gradal and Maven testing we use selenium
the integration between Dev and Ops is
through tools such as Jenkins and then
the deployment operation is done with
tools such as Docker and Chef finally
nagas is used to monitor the entire
environment so let's step deeper into
what Docker actually is so Docker is a
tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in a
lightweight container so the application
can work efficiently in different
environments now it's important to note
that the container is actually a
software package that consists of all
the dependencies required to run the
application so multiple containers can
run on the same Hardware the containers
are maintained in isolated environments
they're highly productive and they're
quick and easy to configure so let's
take an example of what doger is by
using a house that may be rent for
someone using Airbnb so in the house
there are three rooms and only one
cupboard and kitchen and the problem we
have is that none of the guests are
really ready to share the cupboard and
kitchen because every individual has a
different preference when it comes to
how the cupboard should be stocked and
how the kitchen should be used this is
very similar to how we run software
applications today each of the
applications could end up using
different Frameworks so you may have a
framework such as rails perfect and
flask and you may want to have them
running for different applications for
different situations this is where
Docker will help you run the
applications with the suitable
Frameworks so let's go back to our
Airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers Docker provides
the suitable Frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space could also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that Al and since every
application has its own framework and
suitable version the area that we had
previously stored for a framework can be
used for something else now we can
create a new application in this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder Docker is the right choice so
let's take a closer look to how Docker
actually works so when we look at Docker
and we call something Docker we're
actually referring to the base engine
which actually is installed on the host
machine that has all the different
components that run your Docker
environment and if we look at the image
on the left hand side of the screen
you'll see that Docker has a client
server relationship there is a client
installed on the hardware there is a
client that contains the docker product
and then there is a server which
controls how that Docker client is
created the communication that goes back
and forth to be able to share the
knowledge on that Docker client
relationship is done through a rest API
and this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that API so we look here in
the animation we see that the docker
client is constantly communicating back
to the server information about the
infrastructure and it's using this rest
API as that Communication channel the
docker server then will check out the
requests and the interaction necessary
for it to be the docker demon which runs
on the server itself will then check out
the interaction and the necessary
operating system pieces needed to be
able to run the container okay so that's
just an overview of the docker engine
which is probably where you're going to
to spend most of your time but there are
some other components that form the
infrastructure for Dockers let's dig
into those a little bit deeper as well
so what we're going to do now is break
out the four main components that
comprise of the docker environment the
four components are as follows the
docker client and server which we've
already done a deeper dive on Docker
images Docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest API in between now
if we start digging into that rest API
particularly the relationship with the
docker Damon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using Windows it's going to be
Powershell on Mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to to
run the dock demon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your Docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within Docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
Docker file you'll store that image in
the docker Hub or reg stre and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a Docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
Docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple Docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your Solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
Consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that Docker image
and to get access to that image we use a
Docker registry which is an open-source
server side service for hosting and
distributing the images that you have
defined you can also use Docker itself
as its own default registry and Docker
Hub now something it has to be bear in
mind though is that for publicly shared
images you may want to have your own
private images in which case you would
do that through your own registry so
once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and I really
encourage you to go out to Docker and
see the other Docker images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands that you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
commands to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write Docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pools so so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your Docker
environment and that command will be
Docker pull with the image name and any
Associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in Reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with a new
information You' do a push command where
you would take the script that youve
written about the docker container that
you define and push it to the repository
and as you can imagine the commands for
that are also fairly simple in terminal
window you would write Docker push the
image name any Associated tags and then
that would then push that image to the
docker repository again either a public
or a private repository so if we recap
the docker file creates a Docker image
that's using the build commands a dock
image then contains all of the
information necessary for you you to be
able to execute the project using the
docker image any user can run the code
in order to create a Docker container
and once a Docker image is built it's
uploaded to a registry or to a Docker
Hub where it can be shared across your
entire team and from the docker Hub
users can get access to the docker image
and build their own new containers so
let's have a look at what we have in our
current environment so today when you
actually have your standard machine you
have the infrastructure you have the
host operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a Docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce
significantly the different elements
that you would normally have within a
virtualized environment so we able to
get rid of the the bins and the so we're
able to get rid of the guest OS and
we're able to eliminate the hypervisor
environment and this is really important
as we actually start working and
creating environments that are
consistent because we want to be able to
make it so it's really easy and stable
for the environment that you have within
your uh Dev and Ops environment now
critical is getting rid of that
hypervisor element it's just a a lot of
overhead so let's have a look at a
container as an example so here we
actually have a couple of examples on
the right hand side we have different
containers we have one container running
a Pache Tomcat in a with Java a second
container is running SQL server in a
microsoft.net environment the third
container is running python with my sqle
these are all running just fine within
the docker engine and sitting on top of
a host OS which could be Linux it really
could be any host OS within a consistent
infrastructure and you're able to have a
solution that can be shared easily
amongst your teams so let's have a look
at an example that you'd have today if a
company is doing a traditional Java
application so you have your developers
working in JBoss on his system and he's
coding away and he has to get that code
over to a tester now what will happen is
that tester will then typically in your
traditional environment then have to
install J boss on their machine and get
everything running and and hopefully set
up identically to the developer chances
are they probably won't have it exact
exctly the same but they're try to get
as close as possible and then at some
point you want to be able to test this
within your production environment so
you send it over to a system
administrator who would then also have
to install JBoss on their environment as
well yeah this just seems to be a whole
lot of duplication so why go through the
problem of installing JBoss three times
and this is where it things get really
interesting because the challenge you
have today is that it's very difficult
to almost impossible to have identical
environment if you're just installing
software locally on devices the
developer probably got a whole bunch of
development software that could be
conflicting with the Jos environment the
tester has similar testing software but
probably doesn't have all the
development software and certainly the
system administrator won't have all the
tools that the developer and tester have
their own tools and so what you want to
be able to do is kind of get away from
The Challenge you have of having to do
local installations on three different
computers and in addition what you see
is that this uses up a lot of effort
because when you're having to install
software over and over again you just
keep repeating doing really basic
foundational challenges so this is where
Docker comes in and Docker is the tool
that allows you to be able to share
environments from one group to another
group without having to install software
locally on a device you install all of
the code into your Docker container and
simply share the container so in this
presentation we're going to go through a
few things we're going to cover what
Docker actually is and then we're going
to dig into the actual architecture of
Docker and kind of go through what
Docker container is and how to create a
Docker container and then we'll go at
through the benefits of using Docker
containers and then the commands and
finalize everything out with a brief
demo so what is darker so darker is as
you'd expect because all the software
that we cover in this series is an
open-source solution and it is a
container solution that allows you to be
able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution you're building so
you can share it from different people
in your team whether it's a developer
tester or system administrator and this
allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into that
architecture so you understand why
Docker runs effectively so the docker
architecture itself is built up of two
key elements there is the docker client
and then there is a rest API connection
to a Docker demon which actually hosts
the entire environment within the docker
host and the docker Damon you have your
different containers and each one has a
link to a Docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest API that sends
command line to the docker Damon through
a terminal window or command line
interface window and we'll go through
some of these demos later on so you can
actually see how you can actually
interact with Docker the docker Dam then
checks the request against and the
docket components and then performs the
service that you're requesting now the
docker image itself all it really is a
collection of instructions used to
create a container and again this is
consistent with all the devops tools
that we have the devops tools that we're
looking to use throughout this series of
videos are all environments that can be
scripted and this is is really important
because it allows you to be able to
duplicate and scale the environments
that you want to be able to build very
quickly and effectively the actual
container itself has all of the
applications and the dependencies of
those applications in one package you
kind of think of it as a really
effective and efficient zip file it's a
little bit more than that but it's one
file that actually has everything you
need to be able to run all of your
Solutions the actual Docker registry
itself is is an environment for being
able to host and distribute different
Docker images among your team so say for
instance you had a team of developers
that were working on multiple different
solutions so say you have a team of
developers and you have 50 developers
and they're working on five different
applications you can actually have the
applications themselves the containers
shared in the docker registry so each of
those teams at any time check out and
have the latest container of that latest
image of the code that you're working on
so let's dig into what actually is in a
container so the important part of a
ducking container is that it has
everything you need to be able to run
the application it's like a virtualized
environment it has all your Frameworks
and your libraries and it allows the
teams to be able to build out and run
exactly the right environment that the
developer intended what's interesting
though is the actual applications then
will run in isolation so they're not
impacting other applications that's
using dependencies on other libraries or
files outside of the container because
of the architecture it really uses a lot
less space and because it's using less
space it's a much more lightweight
architecture so the files the actual
folder itself is much smaller it's very
secure highly portable and the bootup
time is incredibly fast so let's
actually get into how you would actually
create a Docker container so the docker
container itself is actually built
through command line and it's built of a
file and Docker image so the actual um
Docker file is a text file that contains
all the instructions that you would need
to be able to create that Docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with inside of that
image then the image becomes the item
that you would share through the docker
registry you would then use the command
line and we'll do this later on select
docker run and then the name of the
image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally and
again once you've created the document
you can store that in the docker
registry making it available to anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that Docker itself has its
own registry called dockerhub and that
is a public registry so you can actually
go out and see other dock images that
have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private um Repository
so you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of dock Hub where you
can actually then share those files now
something that's also very interesting
to know is that you can have multiple
versions of a Docker image so if you
have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that with within your
Docker registry environment okay so
let's go ahead and we're going to create
a Docker image using some of our basic
Docker commands and so there are
essentially really you know kind of just
two commands that you're going to be
looking for one is the build command and
another one is to actually put it into
your registry which is a push command so
if you want to get a image from a Docker
registry then you want to use the pull
command and a pull command simply pulls
the image from the registry um in this
example using
NG as our rry and we can actually then
pull the image down to our test
environment on our local machine so
we're actually running the container
within our Docker application on um a
local machine we're able to then have
the image run exactly as it would in
production and then you can actually use
the Run command to actually use the
docker image on your local machine so
just a you know a few uh interesting
tidbits about the docking container once
the container is created a new layer is
formed on top of the dock image layer is
called the container layer each
container has a separate readr container
layer and any changes made in that
docking container is then reflected upon
the particular container layer and if
you want to delete the container layer
the container layer also gets deleted as
well so you know why would using Docker
and containers be of benefit to you well
you know some of the things that are
useful is that containers have no
external dependencies for the
applications they run once you have the
container running locally it has
everything it needs to be able to run
the application so there's no having to
install additional pieces of software
such as the example we gave with Jake
boss at the beginning of the
presentation now the containers are
really lightweight so it makes it very
easy to share the containers amongst
your teams whether it's a developer
whether it's a tester whether it's
somebody on your operations environment
it's really easy to share those
containers amongst your entire team
different data volumes can be easily
reused and shared among multiple
containers and again this is another big
benefit and this is a reflection of the
lightweight nature of your containers
the container itself also runs in
isolation uh which means that it is not
impacted by any dependencies you may
have on your own local environment so
it's a completely sandboxed environment
so some of the questions you might ask
is you know can you run multiple
containers together without the need to
start each one individually and you know
what yes you can with Docker compose
Dock and compose allows you to run
multiple containers in a single service
and again this is a reflection on the
lightweight nature of containers within
the docker environment so we're going to
end our presentation by looking at some
of the basic commands that you'd have
within Docker so we have here on the
left hand side we have a Docker
container and then the command for each
item we're actually going to go ahead
and use some of these commands in the
demo that we're going to do after this
presentation you'll see that in a moment
but just you know some of the basic
commands we have are committing the
docket image into the Container kill is
a you know standard kill command to you
know terminate one or more of the
running containers so they stop working
then restart those containers but
suddenly you can look at all the image
all of the commands here and try them
out for yourself so we're going to go
ahead and start a demo of how to use the
basic commands to run Docker so to do
this we're going to open up terminal
window or command line depending whether
you're running Linux PC or Mac and we're
going to go ahead and the first thing we
want to do is see what our Docker image
lists are so we're can go pseudo Docker
images and this will give us well first
we entering our password so let's go
enter that in and this one now gives us
a list of our Docker images and here are
the doc images have already been created
in the system and we can actually go
ahead and actually see the processes
that are actually running so I'm going
to go ahead and open up this window a
little bit more but this will show you
the actual processes and the containers
that we actually have and so on the far
left hand side you see under names we
have learn simply learn bore cool these
are all just different ones that we've
been working on so let's go ahead and
create a Docker image so we're going to
do
pseudo docker
[Music]
run-
d-p
0.0.0.0
callon 80 callon
80 obuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run
ananto image and this will run the
latest image and what we have here is a
hash number and this hash number is a
unique name that defines the container
container that we've just created and we
can go ahead and we can check to make
sure that the container actually is
present so we're going to do so sud sudo
doer. PS and this actually show us on
there so it's not in a running state
right now but that doesn't mean that we
don't have it so let's list out all the
containers that are both running and in
the exit seate so let's do sucker ps- a
and this lists all the containers that I
have running on my
machine and this shows all the ones that
have been in the running State and in
the exit State and here we see one that
we just created about a minute ago and
it's called
learn and these are all running Ubuntu
and this is the one that we had created
just a few seconds
ago let's open it up and there we go so
let's change that to that new Doc
container to a running state so scroll
down and we're going to type
pseudo
[Music]
Docker
run Dash it Das
Dash name
my um so this is going to be the new
container name it's going to be my
Docker so this is how we name our Docker
environment and we'll put in the image
name which is
Ubuntu and Dash bin Dash
bash and it's now in our rout and we'll
exit out of
that so now we're going to go ahead and
start the new my Docker container so PSE
sudo
Docker
start
my and we'll get the container image
which will be my Docker my
Docker return and that started that
Docker image and let's go ahead and
check against the other running Docker
images to make sure it's running
correctly so pseudo Docker
PS and there we are underneath name on
the right hand side you actually see my
Docker along with the other Docker
images that we created and it's been
running for 13 seconds quite fast so if
we want to rename the container let's
use the command
pseudo
Docker rename we can take another Docker
image this it's great grab this one and
we'll put it in rename and we'll rename
and we'll put in the old container name
which is image and then we'll put in the
new container name and let's call
it
purple so now the container image that
had previously been called image is now
called Purple so we do PSE sudo Docker
PS to list all of our Docker
images and and if we scroll up and there
there we go purple how easy is that to
rename an
image and we can go ahead and use this
command if we want to stop container so
we're going to write pseudo
Docker
stop and then we have to put in the
container
name and we'll put in my docko the
container that we originally
created and that image has now
stopped and let's go ahead and prove
that we're going to list out all the the
docket images and what you see is that
it's not listed in the active images
it's uh not on the list on the far right
hand side but if we go ahead and we can
list out all of the dock images so you
actually see it's still there as an
image it's just not in an active stage
just what's known as in an exit state so
here we
go and there's my dock it's in an exited
state so that happened 27 seconds
ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command so
pseudo
Docker
RM we
remove my Docker and that will remove it
from the exited
State and we're going to go ahead and
we're going to double check that
and
yep yep there not not listed there under
exit State
anymore it's
gone there we go there that's where it
used to be all right
let's go
back so if we want to exit a container
in the running state so we do pseudo
kill and then the name of the
container I think one of them is called
yellow let's just check and see if
that's going to kill
it oops no I guess we don't have one
called yellow so let's find out the name
of container that we actually have so
Pudo Docker kill oh we're going to list
out the ones that are running oh okay
there we go yellow isn't in that list so
let's take I know let's take simply
learn and so we can actually go ahead
and let's write pseudo Docker kill
simply learn and that will actually kill
an active Docker
container boom there we
go and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now
that's they simply learn container is
not active
anymore and these are all the basic
commands for dock
container and now just a quick info for
you if you want to upskill yourself
master devop skills and land your dream
job or grow in your career then you must
explore simply learn's cohort of various
devop program simply learn offers
various certification and postgraduate
program in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
celtech and Google Cloud through our
courses you will gain knowledge and Work
Ready expertise in skills like devs
methodology deployment automation cicd
Pipeline and over a dozen others and
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in top TI product companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a Do's
role as a fresher or moved on to a
higher paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a devops program
that fits your experience and areas of
Interest we're going to break up this
presentation into four key areas we're
going to talk about life before
kubernetes which some of you are
probably experiencing right now what is
kubernetes the benefits that kubernetes
brings to you particularly if you are
using containers in a Dev Ops
environment and then finally we're going
to break down the architecture and
working infrastructure for kubernetes so
you understand what's happening and why
the actions are happening the way that
they are so let's jump into our first
section of life before kubernetes so the
way that you have done work in the past
or you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
Solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a Data Center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is deploying code
out to Virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
going to have issues where applications
may be running effectively and not not
effectively and not load balanced um
effectively across the environment the
problem that you have with this kind of
infrastructure is that it gets very
expensive uh you can only install one
piece of software one service on one
piece of Hardware so your Hardware is
being massively underutilized this is
where virtual machines have become
really popular with a virtual machine
you're able to have better resource
utilization and scalability at much less
cost and this allows you to be able to
run multiple virtual machines on a
single piece of Hardware the problem is
is that VMS of for virtual machines are
not perfect either some of the
challenges you run with VMS is that the
actual hardware and software need needed
to manage the VM environment can be
expensive there are security risks with
virtual with VMS there are security
risks with VMS there have been data
breaches recorded about solutions that
run in virtualized environments you also
run into an issue of availability and
this is largely because you can only
have a finite number of virtual machines
running on a piece of hardware and this
results in limitations and restrictions
in the types of environment you want to
be running and then finally setting up
and managing a virtualized environment
is timec consuming
it can take a lot of time and it can
also get very expensive so how about
kubernetes well kubernetes is a tool
that allows you to manage containerized
deployment of solutions and inherently
kubernetes is a tool that is really a
Next Level maturity of deployment so if
you can think of your maturity curve as
deploying code in directly to Hardware
in a Data Center and then deploying your
solutions to virtual machines the next
evolution of that deployment is to use
containers and kubernetes so let's kind
of go through and look at the
differences between a virtual machine
and kubernetes and we've got a few here
that we want to highlight and you'll get
an understanding of what the differences
are between the two so first of all with
virtual machines there is inherently
security risks and what you'll find as
we get dig through the architecture
later in the presentation is that
kubernetes is in ently secure um and
this is largely because of the Legacy
code uh the legacy of kubernetes and
where it came from we'll talk about that
in just a moment but kubernetes is
inherently secure uh virtual machines
are not easily portable now with that
said they they are technically portable
they're just not very easily portable
whereas with kubernetes it's working
with darker container Solutions it is
extremely portable that means that you
can actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a timec consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few other
areas that we want to kind of um
highlight differences virtual machines
use much less isolation when than
building out the uh encapsulated
environment than kubernetes does uh for
instance with a virtual machine you have
have to run hypervisor on top of the OS
and hardware and then inside of the
virtual machine you also have to have
the operating system as well whereas in
contrast on a kubernetes environment
because it's leveraging a darker
container and or container like
Technologies it only has to have the OS
and the hardware and then inside of each
container doesn't need to have that
additional OS layer it's able to inherit
what it needs to be able to run the
application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of Hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
Hardware so as we highlighted here VMS
are not as portable as kubernetes and
kubernetes is portable directly related
to the use of containerization and
because kubernetes is built on top of
containers it is much less time
consuming because you can actually
script and automatically allocate
resource to nodes with in your
kubernetes environment this allows the
infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
why we are running into a solution where
kubernetes had to come about because the
demand for having more highly scalable
solutions that are more efficient was
just really a natural evolution of this
software deployment model that started
with pushing out code to physical
hardware and then pushing code out to
Virtual machines and then then needing
to have a solution much more
sophisticated kubernetes would have come
about at some point in time I'm just
really glad it came about when it did so
what is kubernetes let's let's dig into
the history of kubernetes and how it
came about so in essence kubernetes is
an open-source platform that allows you
to manage and deploy and maintain groups
of containers and the container is
something like darker and if you're
developing code you're probably already
using darker today consider kubernetes
as the tool that manages multiple Docker
environments together now we talk a lot
about Docker and as a container solution
with kubernetes the reality is is that
kubernetes can actually use other
container tools out there but Docker
just simply is the most popular
container out there both these tools are
open source that's why they're so
popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility and being able
to scale up your Solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live and exist in today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
Google and the original project was
Google Bor um Google Bor it does exactly
what kubernetes done does today but
kubernetes was Rewritten from the ground
up and then released as an open-source
project in 2014 so that people outside
of Google could take advantage of the p
of kubernetes containerization
management tools and today it is managed
by the cloud native Computing foundation
and there are many many companies that
support and manage kubernetes so for
instance if you're signing up for
Microsoft Azure aw as Google Cloud all
of them will leverage kubernetes and
it's just become the the de facto tool
for managing large groups of containers
so let's kind of Step through some of
the key benefits that you'd experience
from kubernetes and so we have nine key
benefits and the first it is highly
portable and is 100% open-source code
and this means that you can actually go
ahead and contribute to this code
project if you want to through GitHub uh
the ability to scale up the solution is
incredible um what's um the the history
of kubernetes being part of a Google
project for managing the Google network
and infrastructure uh kind of really
sets the groundwork for having a
solution that is highly scal able the
out of the high scalability also comes
the need for high availability and this
is the desire to be able to have a
highly efficient and highly energized
environment that also you can really
rely on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management to um environment
you know that it's going to be um
available for the solutions that you're
maintaining and it's really designed for
deployment so you can script out the
environment and actually have it as part
of your devops model so you can scale up
and meet the demands of your customer
then what you'll find is that the um
load bouncing is extremely efficient and
it allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across your entire network
so your network remains stable and then
also the tool um allows you to U manage
the orchestration of your storage so you
can have local storage such as an SSD on
the hardware that the kubernetes is M
maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public Cloud such as Azure or AWS you
can actually go ahead and make that
available to your entire system and you
can inherit the security that goes back
and forth between the cloud environments
and one of the things you'll find
consistent with kubernetes is that it is
designed for a cloud first environment
um kubernetes as well is that it's it's
really a self-healing environment so if
something happens or something fails um
kuat will detect that failure and then
either restart the process kill the
process or replace it and then because
of that you also have automated roll
outs and roll backs uh in case you need
to be able to manage the state of the
environment and then finally uh you have
automatic bin packaging so you can
actually specify the compute power
that's being used from CPU and RAM for
each container so let's dig into the
final area which is the actual
kubernetes architecture and we're going
to cover this at a high level there's
actually another video uh that you can
that simply learn has developed which
digs deeper into the kubernetes
architecture and so the kubernetes
architecture is a cluster based
architecture and it's really about two
key areas you have the kubernetes master
which actually controls um um all of the
activities within your entire kuber
infrastructure and then you have nodes
um that actually are running on Linux
machines um out that are controlled by
the master so let's kind of go through
some of these um areas so if we look at
the kubernetes m Master uh to begin with
and then we'll start with etet this is a
tool that allows for the configuration
and the information and the management
of nodes within your cluster and one of
the key features that you'll find with
all of the tools that are managed within
either a the master environment or
within a node is that they are all
accessible via the API server um and
what's interesting about the API server
is that it's a restful based
infrastructure which means that you can
actually secure each connection with SSL
um and other um security models to
ensure that your entire infrastructure
and the communication going back and
forth across your infrastructure is
tightly secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect actually um
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster and then you
have the controller and the controller
is a Damon server that actually manages
and pushes out the instructions to all
of your nodes so uh the other tools
really are the uh the infrastructure and
you can consider them the administration
side of the master whereas controller is
the management it actually pushes out
all of the controls via the API server
so let's actually dig into um one of the
actual nodes themselves and there are
three key areas of the noes one is the
do environment which actually helps and
manage and maintain the container that's
actually inside um of the node and then
you have the kuet which is responsible
for information that goes back and forth
and it's going to do most of the
conversation with the API server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node now the
kubernetes master has the instructions
of what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those instructure to
an indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way let's have an overview of the
kubernetes architecture so kubernetes is
really broken up into three key areas
you have your workstation where you
develop your commands and you push out
those commands to your master and the
master is comprised of four key areas um
which essentially control all of your
nodes and and the node contains multiple
pods and each pod has your Docker
container built into it so consider that
you could have really almost an infinite
number of PODS sorry infinite number of
nodes being managed um by the master
environment so you have your cluster
which is a collection of servers that um
maintain the AV availability and the
compute power such as RAM CPU and disk
utilization um you have the master which
is really components that control and
schedule uh the activities of your
network and then you have the node which
actually hosts the actual Docker virtual
machine itself um and be able to
actually control and communicate back to
the master the health of that pod and
we'll get into more detail on the
architecture later in the presentation
so you know you keep hearing me talk
about um containers but they really are
the center of the work that you're doing
with kubernetes and the concept around
kubernetes and containers is really just
a natural evolution of where we've been
with internet and digital Technologies
over the last uh 10 15 years so before
kubernetes um you had tools where you
either running virtual machines or
you're running uh data centers that had
to maintain and and U manage and notify
you of any interruptions in your network
kubernetes is the tool that actually
comes in and helps address those
interruptions and manages them for for
you so the solution to this is the use
of containers so uh you can think of
containers as that Natural Evolution
from you know uh 15 20 years ago you
would have written your code and posted
it to a data center uh more recently you
probably post your code to a virtual
machine and then move the virtual
machine and now you actually just work
directly into a container and everything
is self-contained and can be pushed out
to your um environment um the thing
that's great about containers they're
they're isolating environments very easy
for developers to work in them but it's
also really easy for uh operations teams
to be able to move a container into
production so let's kind of step and
back and look at a competing product to
kubernetes which is Docker swarm now one
of the things that we have to um
remember is that Docker um containers
which are extremely popular um built by
the company Docker and made open source
and Docker actually has other products
one of those other products uh is Docker
swarm and docker swarm is a tool that
allows you to be able to manage multiple
containers uh so if we look at some of
the uh the benefits of using Docker
swarm versus kubernetes and one of the
things that you'll find is that both
tools have strengths and weaknesses but
it's really good that they're both out
there U because it helps keep it really
kind of justifies uh the importance of
having these kind of tools so kubernetes
was designed originally from the ground
up to be autoscaling whereas Ducker
swarm isn't the load balancing is
automatic on Docker Swan whereas with
kubernetes you have to manually
configure load balancing across your
nodes the installation for Docker swarm
is really fast and easy I mean you can
be up and running within minutes
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll get there um I mean
it's not like it's going to take you
days and weeks but it's it is a tool
that's a when you compare the two dockor
swarm's much easier to get up and
running now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable and
it's you know that's its real strength
is its ability to have strong clusters
whereas with doer swarm it's cluster
strength isn't um as strong when
compared to kubernetes now you compare
it to anything else on the market it's
really good um so this is kind of a
splitting hairs kind of comparison um
but kubernetes really does have the
advantage here if you're looking at the
two compared to each other for
scalability I mean kubernetes was
designed for by Google to scale up and
support uh Google Cloud Network
infrastructure they uh both allow you to
be able to share um uh storage volumes
with do you can actually do it with um
any container U with u that is managed
by the docker swamp whereas with
kubernetes it manages the storage with
the Pod and a pod can have multiple
containers within it but you can't take
it down to the level of the container
interestingly uh kubernetes does have a
graphical user interface um for being
able to control and manage uh the
environment the reality however is that
you're likely to be using terminal uh to
actually make the controls and Commands
to control your um either Dr swarm or
kubernetes environment um it's great
that it has a a goey and to get you
started but once you're up and running
you're going to be using terminal window
for those fast quick administrative
controls that you need to make so let's
look at the hardware components for uh
kubernetes so um what's interesting is
that kubernetes is extremely light of
all the systems that we looking at it's
extremely lightweight um it's allows you
to have if you compare it to like a
virtual machine which is very heavy you
know um kumes is extremely lightweight
and hardly uses any resources at all
interesting enough though is that if you
are looking at the usage of CPU it's
it's better to actually take it for um
uh the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes uh because uh the nodes
will actually combine together to give
you that whole compute power again this
this is why kubernetes works really well
in the cloud where you can do that kind
of activity rather than if you're
running in your own data center um so
you can have persistent volumes um such
as a local SSD um or you can actually
attach to a cloud data storage again
kubernetes is really designed for the
cloud I would encourage you to use cloud
storage wherever possible rather than
relying on physical storage uh the
reason being is that if you connect to
cloud storage and you need to flex your
your storage the cloud will do that for
you I mean that's just an inherent part
of why you would have cloud storage
whereas if you're connecting to physical
storage you're always restricted to the
limitations of the physical Hardware so
let's um kind of pivot and look at the
software components as compared to the
hardware components so the main part of
the um components is the actual
container and all of the software
running in the container runs on Linux
so if you um have Docker installed as a
developer on your machine it's actually
running inside of Linux um that's what
makes it so lightweight and really one
of the things that you'll find is that
most data centers and Cloud providers
now are running predominantly on Linux
inside of the um the the container
itself is then managed inside of a pod
and a pod is really just a group of
containers bundled together and um the
kubernetes scheduler and proxy server
then actually manage what um how the
pods are actually pushed out uh into
your kubernetes environment the the pods
can actually then share resources both
networking and storage so pods aren't um
pushed out manually they're actually
managed through a layer of abstraction
and part of their deployment and and
this is the strength of kubernetes you
use use um to find your um
infrastructure and then kubernetes will
then manage it for you and there isn't
that problem of um manual management of
PODS uh if you have to manage the
deployment of them and you that's simply
taken away and it's completely automated
and the the final area of software
Services is on Ingress and this is
really the secure way of being able to
have communication from outside of the
cluster and passing of information into
that cluster um and again this is done
securely through SSL layers and it
allows you to ensure that security is at
the center of the work that you have
within your kubernetes environment so
let's dive now into the actual
architecture before we start looking at
a use case of how kubernetes is being
employed so kubernetes again is um we
looked at this uh diagram at the
beginning of the presentation and there
are really three key areas there's the
workstation where you develop your
commands and then you have your master
environment which uh controls the uh
scheduling the communication um and the
actual um commands that you have created
and pushes those out and manages the
health of your entire node Network and
each node has uh various pods so we like
break this down uh so the mark Master
node is the most vital component um with
the master uh you have four key controls
you have etcetra controller manager
schedule and API server the cluster
store Etc this actually manages the
details and values that you've developed
on your local workstation um and then
we'll work with the out the control
schedule on API server to communicate
that out those instructions of how your
infrastructure should look like to your
entire network uh the control manager is
really an API server and again um this
is all about security so we use restful
fpis um which can be packaged in SSL to
communicate back and forth um across
your uh pods and the master and indeed
the services within each of them as well
uh so um at every single layer of
extraction uh the communication is
secure uh the schedule as the name would
imply release schedules um when tasks
get sent out to the actual nodes
themselves the nodes themselves are are
dumb nodes they just have uh the
applications um running on them the
master and the um is really doing all of
the work uh to make sure that your
entire network is running um efficiently
and then you have the API server which
has your res commands and the
communication um back and forth across
your network that is secure and
efficient so your node environment is
where all the work that you do with your
containers gets pushed out too so um a a
work is really it's a combination of
containers and each container will then
Al run together on that node so you'd
have a collection of containers on a
node that all make logical sense to have
together within each node um you have a
Docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
uh you have your cuet which is a service
for conveying information back and forth
um to the service about the actual
health of the kubernetes node itself and
then finally you have the proxy server
and the proxy server is able to manage
the nodes the volumes the the creation
of new containers um and actually helps
pass the communic the the health of the
container back up to the master to see
whether or not the container should be
either killed stop started or um updated
so finally let's look at see where uh
kubernetes is being used by other
companies so you know kubernetes is
being used by a lot of companies and
they're really using it to help manage
complex existing systems so that they
can have uh greater performance and with
the end goal of being able to Delight
the customer and increase value to the
customer and hence increased value and
revenue into the organization so an
example of this is a company called
Black Rock uh where they actually went
through the process of implementing
kubernetes uh so they could so Black
Rock had a challenge where they needed
to be able to have much more Dynamic
access to their resources uh they were
running complex installations on
people's desktops and it was just really
really difficult to be able to manage
their entire infrastructure and so they
actually went and pivoted to using cetes
and this allowed them to be able to be
much more scalable and expansive in the
management of their uh infrastructure
and as you can imagine kubernetes was
then hooked into their entire existing
system and has really become a key part
of the success that Black Rock is now
experiencing of a very stable
infrastructure um and the bottom line is
that black rock is now able to have
confidence in their infrastructure and
be able to give that confidence um as
back to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services so
now what is azure what's the big cloud
service provider all about so Azure is a
cloud computing platform provided by
Microsoft now it's basically an online
portal through which you can access and
manage resources and services now
resources and services are nothing but
you know you can store your data and you
can transform the data using services
that Microsoft provides again all you
need is the internet and being able to
connect to the Azo portal then you get
access to all of the resources and their
services in case you want to know more
about how it's different from its rival
which is AWS I suggest you click on the
top right corner and watch the AWS
versus AO video so that you can clearly
tell how both these cloud service
providers are different from each other
now here are some things that you need
to know about a your if was launched in
February 1st 2010 which is significantly
later than when AWS was launched it's is
free to start and has a pay per use
model which means like I said before you
need to pay for the services you use
through aor and one of the most
important selling points is that 80% of
Fortune 500 companies use Azure Services
which means that most of the bigger
companies of the world actually
recommend using AZ and then azir
supports a wide variety of programming
languages the C noj Java and so much
more another very important selling
point of aure is the amount of data data
centers it has across the world now it's
important for a cloud service provider
to have many data centers around the
world because it means that they can
provide their services to a wider
audience now Azor has 42 which is more
than any cloud service provider has at
the moment it expects to have 12 more in
a period of time which brings its total
number of regions it covers to 54 now
let's talk about Azor Services now Azo
Services have 18 categories and more
than 200 services so we clearly can't go
through all of them it has services that
cover compute a machine learning
integration management tools identity
devops web and so much more you're going
to have a hard time trying to find a
domain that Azure doesn't cover and if
it doesn't cover it now you can be
certain they're working on it as we
speak so first let's start with the
compute Services first virtual machine
with this service what you're getting to
do is to create a virtual machine of
Linux or Windows operating system it's
easily configurable you can add RAM you
can decrease RAM you can add storage
remove it all of it is possible in a
matter of seconds now let's talk about
the second service cloud service now
with this you can create a application
within the cloud and all of the work
after you deploy it deploying the
application that is is taken care of by
Azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all of the other
things are handled by aure next up let's
talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micros service is greatly simplified
so you might be wondering what exactly
is a microservice now a microservice is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
Ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
Azure all you need is to provide the
code to Azure and it'll execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking Services first up we have
Azor CDN or the content delivery Network
now the Azo CDN service is basically for
delivering web content to users now this
content is of high bandwidth and can be
transferred or can be delivered to any
person across the world now these are
actually a network of servers that are
placed in strategic positions across the
world so that the customers can obtain
this data as fast as possible next up we
have expess R now with this you can
actually connect your on promise Network
onto the Microsoft cloud or any of the
services that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on promise
Network and the service that you want
then you have virtual Network now with
virtual Network you can have any of the
a your Services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have azur DNS so azur DNS
is a hosting service which allows you to
host their DNS or domain name system
domains in Azure so you can host your
application using Azure DNS now for the
storage Services first up we have dis
storage with dis storage you're given a
costeffective option of choosing HDD or
solid state drives to go along with your
virtual machines based on your
requirements then you have blob storage
now this is actually optimized to ensure
that they can store massive amounts of
unstructured data which can include Text
data or even binary data next you have
file storage which is a managed file
storage and can be accessible via the
SMB protocol or the server message block
protocol and finally you have q storage
now with Q storage you can provide
durable message queuing for an extremely
large workload and the most important
part is that this can be accessed from
anywhere in the world now now let's talk
about how aor can be used firstly for
application development it could be any
application mostly web applications then
you can test the application see how
well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like I mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual Machines of any size or
Ram that you want you can integrate and
Sync features you can collect and store
matrices for example how the data Works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and you have virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored
let's talk about Azia Services as I told
you Azia provides services for a wide
range of domains now let's have a look
at some of these domains there's Ai and
machine learning compute containers
database identity management tools
networking Security Storage and so much
more now let's have a look at some of
the individual servic services within
these domains firstly you have AZ
virtual machines with Az virtual
machines what you get is the opportunity
to create Windows or Linux virtual
machines now all of this is possible in
a matter of seconds with a large amount
of customization now let's have a look
at some of its features firstly you can
choose from a wide variety of virtual
machine options then you have a large
amount of optimization available to you
for example what size of operating
system do you want how much size do you
want allocated to it what version of the
system is it and so much more then it
provides low cost and per minute billing
now azer provides you per minute billing
which means that you're only charged for
how much time you use the service and
finally you have enhanced security and
protection for your virtual machines
next we have service fabric now with
service fabric you have a platform which
enables you to create microservices now
this also makes the process of
application life cycle management a
whole lot easier as a direct result you
can create applications with a faster
time to Market it supports Windows Linux
on from promises or other clouds and it
enables you to do a tremendous amount of
scaling up depending on your requirement
and finally we have functions now with
functions you can build applications
with the help of serverless computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used you can
create applications in any language that
you want and the only thing you need to
worry about is the code of the
application everything other than that
that is the hardware requirements are
taken care of by Azure now let's have a
look at the networking Sy Services
firstly we have the Azor CDN or the
content delivery network with Azor CDN
what you get is the ability to deliver
your content with reduced load times
fast responsiveness and less bandwidth
now CDN can be integrated with several
other AZ services so that the process
can move at a fast rate it can handle
heavy loads and traffic spikes with
these it also provides a robust security
system now with the content that's
delivered you can get Advanced analytic
data with which you can understand how
customers are using your content next we
have express route with express route
you can connect your on premisis network
to aure through a private Network Now by
default this lowest latency it increases
the emphasis on reliability and speed
and it can be of great use when you have
to transfer large amounts of data
between networks now another way this
can be useful is if it's used to add
compute or storage capacity to Data
Centers next we have Azure DNS domain
name server or Azure DNS can be used to
host your domains on Azure this provides
High availability and great performance
it provides fast responses to DNS
queries by taking advantage of
Microsoft's Global Network it also
provides High availability next we have
virtual Network Azo virtual Network
allows the Azo resources to communicate
with each other or other on promised
networks via the Internet and all of
this is kept extremely secure now with
this users can create their own private
Network for communic communication it
provides users with an isolated and
extremely secure environment for their
applications to run now all of the
traffic stays entirely within the Azure
Network and it also allows users to
design their own networks next we have
traffic manager now with traffic manager
you can route incoming traffic to
improve your performance and
availability now one thing it provides
is multiple failover options so if a
particular situation goes wrong there's
always an option to consider to salvage
the situation it helps reduce
application runtime and enables the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations it also helps the
people who are using it to know where
the customers connecting from across the
world next we have load balancer with
this you have provided the ability to
instantly scale applications at the same
time providing High availability and
improved Network performance for users
applications it can be integrated into
virtual machines and cloud services it
provides highly reliable applications it
also allows users users to secure and
integrate security groups finally we
have a VPN Gateway now this allows users
to connect their enomis networks to aure
using a s tosite VPN now this allows
users to connect their virtual machine
to anywhere in the world through a point
to site VPN and also it's very easy to
manage and is highly available now let's
talk about the storage Services first we
have data Lake storage now with this
what you get is a scalable data storage
with an emphasis on cost effective
and scalability now it comes of Maximum
use when you've integrated with other
services so that you can get analytics
on how the data is being used it is also
integrated with other services like the
Azo blob storage now it is also
optimized for Big Data analysis tools
like Apache spark and Hadoop next up we
have blob storage The Blob storage
provides a storage capacity for data now
depending on how often a particular data
is used it is classified into different
tiers now now all the data that is
within the blob storage is unstructured
data now it has a way of ensuring that
the data Integrity is maintained every
time a particular object is being
changed or the data is being accessed
and it also helps improve app
performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption next we have queue storage
now with this you have a message queuing
system for large workloads this allows
users to build flexible applications and
separate functions not to mention with
this you can be sure that your your
individual components will not fail it
also makes sure that your application is
scalable Q storage provides Q monitoring
which helps ensure that the customer
demands are met then we have file
storage now with file storage you can
perform file sharing with the help of
the SMB protocol or the server message
block protocol now this data is
protected by SMB 3.0 and the https
protocol in this CL like we mentioned in
functions Azor takes care of all the
hardware needs and the operating system
deployments on its own it also improves
on promises performance and other
capabilities lastly we have table
storage with table storage you can
deploy semi structured data sets and an
osql key value store now this is used
for creating applications which have a
flexible data schema and also
considering how it has a very strong
consistency model it's mainly aimed for
Enterprises next let's have a look at
some web and mobile services first we
have the AZ search now with Az search
you get a cloud search service which is
powered by artificial intelligence with
this you can develop web applications as
well as mobile applications now one big
Advantage is that you don't have to set
up or manage your search indices as your
takes care of that and by extension it
increases your development speed the
artificial intelligence also will
provide insights and structured
information that you can use to improve
the search and structured information
next we have logic apps now with this
you can create integration Solutions
which can connect applications that are
important to your business now with this
you can visually create business
processes and workflows you can
integrate SAS or software as a service
applications and Enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data within a firewall and
securely connect to services next we
have web applications now with web apps
you can create deploy and scale web
applications according to business
requirements now it supports both
windows and Linux platforms and it helps
with continuous integration or
deployment abilities another very
important aspect of this is that the
data can be deployed and hosted across
multiple locations in the world and
finally we have mobile apps with mobile
apps you can create applications for iOS
Android and Windows platforms one
advantage is that it automatically
scales Up and Down based on your
requirements now in situations where you
have network issues offline data syncing
ensures that your applications work
anyway and you can create crossplatform
applications or native applications for
iOS Android and Windows next let's have
a look at some container services first
let's talk about ACS or AO container
services it is also known as the Azia
kubernets Services as it's a fully
managed kubernets container
orchestration service now what this
means is that it eases the process of
container integration and deployment it
also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your container is kept
secure next we have container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers now applications can be
developed here without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is a Z's problem to take care of and it
enables building applications without
having to manage the infrastructure that
is all you need to worry about is
running the container trer next let's
have a look at some database Services
first we have the SQL database now with
SQL database what you get is a
relational Cloud database service now
this means that it helps accelerate your
app development and makes it easier for
you to maintain your application now SQL
database is also used extensively in
migrating workloads to the cloud and
hence saves time and cost it also helps
improve your performance by integrating
machine learning and Adaptive
Technologies into your database next we
have Azure Cosmos DB now this is a
globally distributed multimodel database
service now what this means is that with
this you can create application with
support nosql it provides a high-grade
security system has high availability
and low latency now this is usually used
in situations where you have a diverse
and highly unpredictable workload now
let's have a look at some security and
identity Services firstly we have the
Azure active directory now if if you
want to know more about Azor active
directory I suggest you click on the top
right corner and watch our video on the
Azor active directory this is just an
introduction so with this you can manage
user identities and you can make sure
the resources are kept safe with the
help of access policies most of these
are intelligence driven now one of the
main features is that you can have
access to your applications from any
location or device it helps increase
your efficiency and helps down cutting
costs when it comes to having a help
desk it can also help improve security
and can respond to Advanced threats in
real time next you have a your active
directory b2c it helps provide customer
identity and access management in the
cloud now protecting customer identity
is extremely important for an
organization and that's what a your ad
b2c does now it also enables the
application to be scaled to great
amounts even billions of customers next
we have the Azure security Center this
is basically like a command post with
which you get a complete view of the
security across users on your own
premises and Cloud workloads so with
this you are given thread protection
method that adapts to situations and
helps reduce exposing you to threats it
also has rapid threat response and makes
the process of finding and fixing
vulnerabilities a whole lot easier next
up let's talk about monitoring and
Management Services so first let's have
a look at Azure advisor now Azure
advisor is basically a guide for the
best practices when it comes to Azure
now when you follow these it improves
performance security cost and increases
availability now it also learns from how
you use the services on your
configuration and usage pattern and the
adjustments that it suggests can be
implemented very quickly and easily next
we have Network Watcher now with this
you can monitor diagnose and understand
the working of your network now you can
monitor your network without actually
having to log in to your virtual machine
now you can also use something known as
network security flow logs to understand
the traffic pattern how much traffic is
coming towards you how much you're
giving and so much more it also helps
diagnose VPN problems that you might
have with detail logs and finally you
have the Azo resource manager now with
this you can ensure that the resources
that you have are managed and deployed
at a consistent rate now this makes it
extremely easy for you to manage and
visualize your resources that are used
in your applications or some other
requirements and you can control who can
access your resources as well as perform
actions on it it's going to be six
things that we're going to step through
the first is really looking at what is
the world that many of you already work
in today how do you administer your
networks and your systems today then
we're going to look at how Chef can be
the tool that really helps improve the
efficiencies of creating a consistent
operations environment we're going to
look at the tools and the components and
the architecture that takes to construct
chef and then finally we're going to
take a use case of one of the many
companies that is using Chef today to
improve the efficiency of their
operations environment so let's take a
step back at what life was like before
Chef this may well be the life that
you're experiencing right now so as a
system administrator typically the way
that you work is that you are
responsible for the uptime of all of the
systems within your network and you may
have many many systems that you are
responsible for now if one system goes
down that's not a problem because as a
system administrator you can get
notifications and you can jump right
onto the problem and solve it when
things start getting really difficult
however is when you have multiple
systems and you are not able as a single
person to get to all those systems and
solve them as quickly as possible the
problem that you start having is that
your environments are not in sync if
only this could all be automated well
this is where Chef comes to the rescue
for you so let me take some time and
introduce you to the concepts behind
chef and why it's a tool that you would
probably want to be using in your
environment so what actually is Chef so
Chef is a way in which you can use code
to fix your physical Hardware
environment and so what does that look
like well the way that we write out
scripts in Chef is that you can actually
code your entire environment so you
don't have to actually be managing your
environment on a hardware by Hardware
basis but actually use scripts called
recipes that will actually manage the
environment for you so Chef will
actually ensure that every system is
automatically set to the right states
that meet the requirements you have
defined in your code so you don't have
any issues where Hardware starts to fail
because it references the code to reset
the state within that environment and
that makes you a happy system
administrator so let's go through the
mechanics of how this actually works
with Chef so Chef is ultimately an
automation tool that converts
infrastructure to code and you'll often
hear the term infrastructure as code or
IAC and this really starts as a output
of the work that Chef has done cuz you
take the policies that you as an organ
gation have created and you convert that
into a scripted language that can then
be implemented automatically this
enables shf to be able to manage
multiple systems very very easily and
considering how broad and deep our
systems become it's very easy to see how
this can help you as a system
administrator the code is then tested
continuously and deployed by Chef so
that you're able to guarantee that your
standards and appropriate States for
your hardware and operating environment
are always maintained so let's step
through the different components that
are available in Chef so the first one
is actually creating uh the actual
recipes for Chef so you actually work on
these on a workstation and you'll write
out your code which is referred to as a
recipe and that recipe will be written
using a language called Ruby good thing
for you is that there are lots of
examples of Ruby recipes that have been
created by the open-source Community a
lot of examples knife is the command
tool that you use that communicates
between the recipes and the server so
your recipe is the instruction and knife
is the tool that makes that instruction
work and sets the appropriate State on
the server environment when you create
more than one recipe you start creating
a collection those collections are
referred to as cookbooks and you can
make take an environment such as a large
Network where you have multiple CES
potentially hundreds of servers that
have to all have a consistent and equal
State environment and you would put that
cookbook and use that cookbook to ensure
with Chef that the state of each of
those codes is consistent and then ohigh
feetures the current state of your nodes
and then the chef client configures the
nodes as find within your cookbook so
let's step through the architecture and
working environment of Chef so for an
administrator a systems administrator
you only have to allow work from your
workstation and from that workstation
you can then configure all the nodes of
your environment you can use uh
different recipes that you create and
those recipes can be compiled into a
cookbook that can be then applied to a
node the thing that's of value is that
as you change the environment As you
move and mature as an organization and
your nodes need to mature consistently
and quickly with your organization all
you have to do is roll out a different
recipe to your nodes and then the nodes
will use the tools within Chef to make
the updates so you can create a second
recipe or even a third recipe to be
deployed out to your server environment
knife is going to be the tool that does
the hard work of doing the updates on
the server with the server you have your
collection of recipes in a single
cookbook however understanding the state
of the individual nodes is important to
ensure that the information is broadcast
from the server with the instructions on
how to set up the network within those
nodes in this instance we use ohigh and
ohigh will fetch the state of the nodes
and send that back to the server and get
the information from The cookbook using
the chef client in your Chef node
Network there is the potential at times
that maybe one of your node fails if
there are two failed nodes then a
request is sent back to the server and
information on the latest node structure
that is identified and defined in the
cookbook will be sent to the failed
nodes if that fails to reset the nodes
then the workstation is notified and you
as the administrator will receive a no
ification to manually reset those nodes
it should be noted that this is a very
rare occasion within the chef network
setup so let's step through a use case
in this instance we're going to look at
holum and how they used Chef so um holum
is a bank and it's the largest bank in
Israel and they have a mixture of Linux
and windows servers that they have to
maintain and as you can imagine this
requires a l lot of constant
configuration and work and this has led
to issues in the past so the challenge
that the team polium face was creating
and hardening software that ran the
major tasks and was repeatable on those
servers that it didn't matter who the
people were forming the jobs that there
was consistency in the work that was
being done and address the problem that
the servers including the hard run the
servers was not consistent throughout
the organization Chef addresses those
specific problems and became the go-to
product for holum they were able to
write the recipes and the cookbooks that
could be deployed out to the network
effectively and it didn't matter what
the system was the recipes reflected the
standards that the system administration
team put together and they were able to
ensure and test each script and use
standard testing tools for those scripts
it didn't matter what kind of
environment that holum had if certain
ports need to be closed or if a firewall
needs to be uh installed or modified or
if custom strong passwords had to be
created all of this could be done using
the recipes that Chef offers and once
those recipes had been finalized they
could be packaged into a common cookbook
that could then be deployed to the
entire network ensuring a consistency in
results for the company and also it
didn't matter whether the cookbooks were
being deployed to Linux or Windows
machine because the scripts were being
put together in the recipes and were
written in Ruby you could actually go
through and update and modify those
scripts depending on the environment so
if you needed to make a modification for
Linux you could make those modifications
so they were consistent across all the
Linux servers or all the windows servers
and this really drove in the ability to
harden and secure the environment in the
entire network within a matter of
minutes using Chef versus the days and
weeks that it previously took so if we
take a before and after scenario using
uh Chef before Chef tasks were repeated
multiple times and it was just hard to
keep track of all the people doing the
work and the reality is because so many
people were touching all the different
systems specific standards the banks had
established was simply not being met
after Chef all of the tasks could be
scripted using Ruby and using the recipe
and cookbook model that Chef has created
the chef tool was able to deploy out to
the entire network specific cookbooks
that provided a consistent experience
and consistent setup and operation
environment for all the hardware the end
result is that the system administration
team could guarantee that the standards
of the bank were being met consistently
in this session what we're going to do
is we're going to cover what and why you
would use puppet what are the different
elements and components of puppet and
how does it actually work and then we'll
look into the companies that are
adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write a manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where puppet shows its strand with
puppet all you have to do is write a
simple script that can be written with
Ruby and write out and deploy to the
servers your settings for each of those
servers the code gets pushed out out to
the servers that are having problems and
then you can choose to either roll back
to those servers to their previous
working States or set them to a new
state and do all of this in a matter of
seconds and it doesn't matter how large
your server environment is you can reach
to all of these servers your environment
is secure your able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this all
through infrastructure as code which is
the advanced devops model for building
out Solutions so let's dig deeper into
what puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like Chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable State pu can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed accurately so let's go
through those components of puppet so
here we have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network so if we look at the top
part of the screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
the clients we have templates that
combine our codes together to render a
final document and you have files that
will be deployed as content that could
be potentially downloaded by the clients
wrapping this all together is a module
of manifest templates and files you
would apply a certificate authority to
sign the actual documents so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate and authorized
modules outside of the master server
where you'd create your manifest
templates and files you would have
public client is a piece of software
that is used to configure a specific
machine there are two parts to the
client one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the master server to
ensure that the certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact of that the current state of
the client that is used and communicated
back to through the agent so let's step
through the workings of puppet so the
puppet environment is a Master Slave
architecture the clients themselves are
distributed across your network and they
are constantly communicating back to a
Master server environment where you have
your puppet modules the client agent
sends a certificate with the ID of that
server back to the master and then the
master will then sign that certificate
and send it back to the client and this
authentication allows for a secure and
verifiable communication between client
and master the factor then collects the
state of the client and sends that to
the master based on the facts sent back
the master then compiles manifests into
the cataloges and those cataloges are
sent back to the clients and an agent on
the client will then initiate the
catalog a report is generated by the
client that describes any changes that
have been made and sends that back to
the master with the goal here of
ensuring that the master has full
understanding of the hardware running
software in your network this process is
repeated at regular intervals ensuring
all client systems are up to date so
let's have a look at companies that are
using puppet today there are a number of
companies that have adopted puppet as a
way to manage their infrastructure so
companies that are using puppet today
include Spotify Google AT&T so why are
these companies choosing to use puppet
as their main configuration management
tool the answer can be seen if we look
at a specific company Staples so Staples
chose to take and use puppet for their
configuration management tool and use it
within their own private Cloud the
results were dramatic the amount of time
that the it organization was able to
save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppet
enable them to open up time to allow
them to experiment with other and new
projects and assignments a real tangible
benefit to a company so let's look at
how you write a manifest in puppet so so
manifests are designed for writing out
in code how you would configure a
specific node in your server environment
the manifests are compiled into
cataloges which are then executed on the
client each of the manifests are written
in the language of Ruby with a PP
extension and if we step through the
five key steps for writing a manifest
they are one create your manifest and
that is written by the system
administrator two compile your manifest
and it's compiled into a catalog three
deploy the catalog is then deployed onto
the clients four execute the catalogs
are run on the client by the agent and
then five and clients are configured to
a specific and desired state if we
actually look into how manifest is
written it's written with a very common
syntax if you've done any work with Ruby
or really configuration of systems in
the past this may look very familiar to
you so we break out the work that we
have here you start off with a package
file or service as your resource type
and then you give it a name and then you
look at the features that need to be set
such as IP address then you're actually
looking to have a command written such
as present or start the man manifest can
contain multiple resource types if we
continue to write our manifest and
puppet the default keyword applies a
manifest to all clients so an example
would be to create a file path that
creates a folder called sample in a main
folder called Etc the specified content
is written into a file that is then
posted into that folder and then we're
going to say we want to be able to
trigger an Apache service and then
ensure that that Apache service is
installed on an earth so we write the
Manifest and we deploy it to a client
machine on that client machine a new
folder will be created with a file in
that folder and an Apache server will be
installed you can do this to any machine
and you'll have exactly the same results
on those machines remember to hit that
subscribe button and tap the
notification Bell so you are always in
the know and before we begin if you
someone who is interested in building a
career in cloud computing by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with cloud computing by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learns postgraduate programm
in cloud computing with certificates
aligned with AWS partner Network and
silver Microsoft partner the link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page and you can have a complete
overview of the program being offered
now let's Dive Right In so first we'll
see the career with Cloud associate
Cloud engineer leave the server X behind
and Venture into the dynamic world of
cloud computing the perfect moment has
arrived and now let's talk about what
this certification means for you your
associate Cloud engineer certification
is like a bon signaling to prospective
employers your progress in Google Cloud
as an associate Cloud engineer you will
be adapt at deploying and securing
applications and infrastructure you'll
maintain Enterprise solutions to meet
performance standards and keep a
watchful eye on the operations of
multiple Cloud projects but that's not
all associate Cloud engineers also prove
their Mastery in using the Google Cloud
console and command line interface you
will effortlessly manage and scale Cloud
Solutions leveraging Google managed or
self-managed services on Google cloud
and many of our peers once dwell in the
own premises realm meticulously setting
up servers now they're prepared to level
up their skills for the cloud era the
associate Cloud engineer certification
is your stepping stone to a flourishing
it career so picture yourself as a cloud
developer architect security engineer ER
systems engineer or network engineer the
possibilities are endless so let's get
started with the benefits of doing gcp
AC so the first benefit you can gain by
acing this certification is you will
have the membership to Google credential
holder portal so I will show you so this
is the Google Cloud certified directory
here you can find all the people who
have cleared this certification and you
can just click on the LinkedIn profile
and see what skills they process and you
have other filters also that is you can
search by the credentials locations or
skills so this is the first benefit of
doing gcp AC now moving back second
benefit is exposure to all gcp services
while preparation will boost your
confidence and then this will set a good
foundation for professional architect
exam and Google certification and badge
to be used in your profile for
visibility that will uphold your profile
and will gain you many opportunities and
now we'll see steps what you can follow
to Ace the gcp AC certification exam so
before we dive in it's essential to
grasp the exam structure the Google
associate Cloud engineer certification
exam consists of 50 multiple choice
questions and you have a total of 2
hours to complete it a passing score
requires at least 70% correctness this
exam evaluates your knowledge of Google
Cloud platform Services basic networking
Concepts and cloud computing
fundamentals and the recommended
experience for this certification is 6
Plus months and the prerequisites are
none for this certification exam and the
link to register for this exam I will
mention that link in the description box
below and I will show you the link also
so this is the link here you have to go
and make your profile if you don't have
an account and after that you can log in
so this is here where you will register
for the exam and moving back now we'll
see the step two that is getting
familiar with gcp so to succeed you need
to become best friends with Google Cloud
platform luckily Google offers a free
tire that allows you to explore gcps
product and services without cost and
don't forget about the comprehensive gcp
documentation it's your treasure throw
of insights into various services and
functionalities so you can just go to
the documentation and read it and the
third is enroll in a course or training
program so education is the key here
enroll in in a course or training
program tailored to the Google associate
Cloud engineer exam the simply learn CCH
cloud computing boot camp course lets
you master key architectural principles
and develop the skills needed to become
a cloud expert and provides in-depth
coverage of exam topics or if you prefer
hands-on experience the associate Cloud
engineer exam prep Quest from Quick
laabs is a great choice and I will
mention the link for the boot camp in
the description box you can go there and
you can enroll in a course or training
program to Ace the preparation and now
the step four take practice test sharpen
your skills with practice test Google
Cloud offers official practice test for
purchase which give you a real feel for
the exam environment Cloud Guru and Wiz
laabs also provide valuable practice
exams and if you're budget conscious
exam Labs offer free practice test and
now moving on to the step five review
exam objectives and resources so stay
focused by reviewing the exam objectives
outlined by Google Cloud these guides
serve as your road map to success dive
deep into Google Cloud's documentation
and white papers for additional study
materials don't forget to engage with
the Google Cloud community on Reddit for
valuable insights and tips and now
talking about the cabus I will move to
the website directly only so this is the
cabus for Google Cloud architect so here
you will learn and you should know the
setting up a Cloud solution environment
or setting up organization
resources that is then you should have a
knowledge on planning and configuring a
Cloud solution deploying and
implementing a Cloud solution and
ensuring successful operation of a Cloud
solution so these all are the things
that are covered in the cabus so you
should have a hands on that as I told
you about the boot camp so all these
labus topics are covered in that boot
camp or the postgraduate program that I
mentioned in the starting so if you want
to a that program you can just enroll in
the course or training program and now
moving back now we'll just have a look
at the tips to a this exam so the first
tiep is book the exam in advance before
starting preparation so you don't miss
out and the second tip is practice
practice and practice that will help you
clear that certification and the third
tip is start the exam with relaxed mind
and take poses after five questions each
time that really helps and then we have
the fourth tip that that is understand
intention of question look for keywords
in questions and answers and the tip
five while choosing options focus on
available option do not worry about
perfect answer and there you have a tech
explorers your gateway to a cloud
powered future awaits the cloud engineer
learning path crowned by the revamp
preparing for the associate Cloud
engineer certification course is a
compass to steer your career toward New
Horizons now let's take a minute to hear
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers cloud
computing has completely changed our
world it allows us to store and access
our data from anywhere making our life
more convenient plus we can now work
with people from all over the world
without a hitch all thanks to cloud
computing so Cloud projects are a big
part of this change they help us learn
and try out new things with Cloud
technology which is really important
it's like a playground for Learning and
solving real world problems so whether
you making an intelligent Gadget
creating a website or even predicting
the weather cloud computing does play an
important role so here we are with
another video on top 10 cloud computing
projects in 2024 whether you are a
beginner an intermediate level cloud
Enthusiast or an advanced level cloud
expert we have got you covered here so
hey everyone and you are already
watching simply Lear before starting
with the top 10 cloud computing projects
for 2024 subscribe to our Channel
because we bring the best videos for you
daily also hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn also
do check out the cloud architect Masters
program by simply Lear this program will
help you build your AWS Microsoft Azure
and Google Cloud platform expertise from
the ground you'll learn to master the
architectural principles and services of
the top Cloud platforms design and
deploy highly scalable fall tolerant
applications and develop skills to
transform yourself into an AWS and Azure
Cloud export this program will give you
an in-depth understanding of cloud
services such as AWS cloud formation
asure resource manager ec2 S3 Route 53
VPC as your app services gcp and much
more you'll acquire the Knowledge and
Skills for passing Cloud architect
certifications such as AWS architect and
Azure architect candidates with one plus
year of work experience are preferred to
enroll in this program by simpl so check
out the link mentioned in the
description box below for more details
moving on to the top 10 cloud computing
projects we have divided this video into
three parts the first part is for
beginners moving on to the first project
for beginners we have a cloud-based file
storage in this project you will create
a simple cloud-based file storage system
similar to a Dropbox or a Google Drive
users can upload download and manage
files stored in the cloud the part to
create this project will start by
choosing a cloud storage service select
a cloud storage service provider like
awss 3
Google Cloud Storage or Azure blob
storage the next step is creating an
account sign up for an account with the
choosen cloud provider if you don't
already have one the next step is to set
up a bucket or a container create a
storage bucket or container to store
your files the next step is to develop a
web interface create a web- based
interface for users to interact with
your storage system you can use HTML CSS
and JavaScript for this the next step is
to implement file upload and download
add functionality for users to upload
and download files to or from their
storage bucket using the cloud providers
SDK or API the next step is user
authentication Implement user
authentication to secure access to files
you can use services like Firebase
authentication or build one of your own
the next step is testing and deployment
test your file storage system locally
and once satisfied deploy it to the
cloud make it publicly accessible if
needed the key learning points of this
project is you will learn the basics of
cloud storage Services file uploading
and downloading and user authentication
moving on to project number two we have
a website hosting service this project
involves setting up an essential website
on a cloud platform like AWS Azure or
Google Cloud you'll deploy a static or
dynamic website and make it accessible
to users worldwide let's move on to the
path to create this project the first
step is to select a cloud hosting
Service choose a cloud hosting platform
like Amazon web services Azure or Google
Cloud the next step is to design your
website create the content and design
for your website you can use HTML CSS
and JavaScript for static websites or
web Frameworks for dynamic ones then
register a domain name purchase a domain
name from a domain register for example
GoDaddy name chep Etc the next step is
to configure DNS configure the DNS
setting to point to your Cloud hosting
servers I address the next step is to
set up a virtual Server create a virtual
server instance on your chosen Cloud
platform for example AWS ec2 Azure VM
and Google compute engine the next step
is to install web server software
install and configure web server
software like Apache on your virtual
server and the last step is to upload
website files upload your website files
to the server and then you are done with
the project the key learning points of
this project you will learn how to
configure a web server you will deploy
web applications and manage domain names
and finally you will ensure High
availability the next project we have
for beginners is a cloud-based
calculator create a simple web-based
calculator application and deploy it on
a cloud platform like hero users can
perform basic calculations using this
calculator let's talk about the path to
create this project you will start by
selecting a cloud platform choose a
cloud platform like Haku AWS or Azure
for deployment then develop the
calculator create a simple web-based
calculator you can use HTML CSS and
JavaScript for this then set up a
development environment install
necessary development tools and
libraries on your local machine then
move ahead with Version Control use
Version Control Systems like git to
manage your project then create a cloud
account sign up for an account with your
chosen Cloud platform then comes the
deployment part deploy your calculator
application to the cloud platform of
your choice for Heroku this might
involve pushing your code to a g
repository and then comes the testing
part ensure that the calculator
functions correctly on the Cloud Server
let's talk about the key learning points
of this project you'll gain experience
in setting up Cloud Server environments
deploying web applications and
understanding server client interactions
moving on to intermediate level projects
these projects are for people with
decent knowledge of cloud computing
Basics the first project we have in this
category is an iot data analytics
project build a system that collects
data from iot devices sensors smart
devices Etc and stores it in Cloud
databases for example AWS Dynamo DB or
Azure Cosmos database Implement
analytics to gain insights from the
collected data let's talk about the path
to create this project the first step is
iot device setup set up iot devices or
sensors to collect data then choose a
cloud database select a cloud database
service for example AWS Dynamo database
asure Cosmos database for data storage
then comes the data injection part write
code to send data from iot devices to
the cloud database then comes data
analytics Implement data analytics tools
or scripts to analyze the collected data
then comes data visualization create
visualizations to present insights from
the data using tools like AWS quick site
or data visualization libraries and then
the last part is monitoring and scaling
Implement monitoring and scaling
mechanisms to handle increased data
volumes so let's talk about the key
learning points of this project you will
explore iot data inje Cloud database
management data analytics and of course
data visualization moving on to the next
project we have a video streaming
service so you will create a video
streaming service where users can upload
and stream videos from the cloud
Implement features like video encoding
content delivery and user authentication
let's talk about the path to create this
project you will start by selecting
cloud services choose cloud services for
video storage for example AWS S3 for
encoding you can choose AWS elastic
transcoder and for Content delivery you
can choose AWS Cloud front the next step
is to design the application plan the
architecture of your video streaming
platform including user interfaces for
uploading and streaming the next step is
user authentication Implement user
Authentication using services like AWS
Cognito then comes the video uploading
part allow users to upload videos to the
cloud storage and then comes the video
encoding Implement video encoding to
create different quality versions of
uploaded videos then comes the content
delivery use a Content delivery Network
or CDN to distribute videos efficiently
to the users and the last step is
testing and scalability Test video
streaming and ensure its skills to
handle concurrent users and varing
network conditions let's talk about the
key learning points for this project
you'll learn about video processing
content delivery networks and secure
user access control moving on to the
next project we have cloud-based
e-commerce website build an e-commerce
platform hosted on cloud develop
features like product listing shopping
carts and secure Payment Processing
let's talk about the path to create this
project you'll start by selecting Cloud
platform choose a cloud platform for
example AWS or EO to host your
e-commerce application then comes the
e-commerce framework choose an
e-commerce framework for example
woocommerce or Shopify or build a custom
solution then comes the product listings
part at product listings and
descriptions with images then comes the
shopping cart Implement a shopping cart
functionality for users to add products
then comes the secure Payment Processing
set up secure Payment Processing using
payment gateways like stripe or PayPal
then comes the user authentication part
implement user authentication for
customer accounts and finally the
testing and security thoroughly test
your e-commerce website ensuring it
secure and capable of handling
transactions what are the key points of
this project you will gain experience in
building scalable web applications
handling online transactions securely
and managing customer data talking about
advanced level cloud computing projects
for advanced level cloud computing
projects you should Master Cloud
infrastructure and cloud services the
first advanced level project we have for
today is machine learning with Cloud
develop a machine learning model and
deploy It On A Cloud Server for scalable
processing this project involves working
with large data sets and real-time data
analysis the first step is machine
learning model develop a machine
learning model using libraries like
tensorflow or CET learn then comes the
data preparation part prepare and clean
the data for training and testing then
choose a cloud machine learning service
select a cloud machine learning service
for example example AWS Sage maker
Google AI platform and Etc then comes
the model deployment part deploy your
machine learning model on the cloud
platform and finally the scalability
ensure the model can handle real-time
predictions and scale as needed let's
talk about the key learning points of
this project you will delve into machine
learning cloud-based data processing and
model deployment the next project we
have in this list is the cloud-based
virtual desktop create a system that
allows users to access virtualized
desktop environments hosted on the cloud
this project focuses on remote desktop
Solutions talking about the path to
create this project you should start by
selecting cloud service choose a cloud
service for virtual desktop for example
Amazon workspace Windows Virtual desktop
or Azure then comes the configuration
part configure virtual desktop instances
with desired specifications user
management create and manage user
accounts for accessing virtual desktops
security Implement security measures for
data protection during remote desktop
access then comes the access control
part set up Access Control policies to
restrict user permissions and lastly
testing test the remote desktop access
from different devices and locations
talking about the key learning points of
this project you'll learn about
virtualization remote desktop
Technologies and user Management in a
cloud-based context moving on to the
third advanced level cloud project we
have a cloud gaming service build a
cloud-based gaming service similar to
Google stadia this project involves GPU
virtualization low latency streaming and
multiplayer game server management
talking about the path to create this
project you should start by selecting
Cloud infrastructure choose a cloud
infrastructure you can either choose AWS
or Azure for hosting Game servers then
comes the game server setup set up Game
servers for hosting games then comes the
low latency streaming implement low
latency streaming Technologies for
gameplay then comes the multiplayer
support add multiplayer support for
users to play together then comes the
user management create user accounts and
manage players profiles and finally
comes load balancing Implement load
balancing to handle increased player
loads talking about the key learning
points of this project you will explore
cloudbased gaming infrastructure server
management and real-time multiplayer
networking moving on to the last cloud
computing project we have a healthcare
data management system develop a
cloud-based system for storing and
managing healthcare related data such as
patient records ensure compliance with
healthcare industry standards for
example
hiaa talking about the path to create
this project you should start by
ensuring compliance with healthcare
industry standards Hippa compliance
understand and are there to HIPAA
compliance regulations Cloud platform
selection choose a HIPAA compliant Cloud
platform for example AWS Healthcare apis
and Azure for healthcare then comes the
data storage part cre create a secure
cloud-based data storage system for
healthcare records then comes the access
control Implement strict access controls
and encryption for data security then
comes the audit trials maintain audit
trials for data access and modifications
and then at last comes the user training
ensure staff are trained on hipa
compliance and data handling protocols
talking about the key learning points of
this project you will gain expertise in
Cloud security data privacy and
compliance while addressing real world
Healthcare data challenges these
projects provide a progressive learning
path allowing individuals to start with
basic Cloud Concepts and gradually
Advanced to more complex and impactful
cloud computing applications each
project offers valuable experience and
skills that can be applied to real life
scenarios and career development in the
cloud computing field so in this
explanation of the top 10 devops
projects we'll delve into the innovative
solutions and tools that are catalyzing
progress from Automation and
containerization to continuous
disintegration and deployment these
projects not only facilitate agility but
also Drive excellence in software
delivery ensuring that devops remains at
the Forefront of modern technology so
join us as we embark on a journey
through the most influential devops
initiatives of her time with that said
if these are the types of videos you
would like to watch then hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
get notified and if you're are a
professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring devops
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no simply
lears postgraduate program in devops
from CCH University in collaboration
with the IBM should be your right choice
for more details use the link mentioned
in the description box below so let's
start with why are devops skills
crucial understanding devops is vital
for optimizing the software development
life cycle devops Engineers need to
master several key skills lenux
proficiency many firms prefer Linux for
hosting apps and managing configuration
systems it's essential for devops
engineers to be well vered in Linux as
it's the foundation of tools like chef
anible and puppet continuous integration
and continuous delivery CI ensures teams
collaborate using a single version
control system while CD automates design
testing and release improving efficiency
and reducing errors number three
infrastructure as code automation
scripts provide sft access to necessary
infrastructure a critical aspect with
containerization and Cloud Technologies
ISC manages configuration executes
commands and swiftly deploys application
infrastructure configuration management
tracking software and operating system
configurations ensures consistency
across servers tools like anible chef
and puet simplify this process making it
efficient at number five we have
automation devops aims for minimal human
intervention maximizing effic efficiency
familiarity with automation tools like
grel git jenin and Docker is essential
for devops and genius so these tools
streamline development processes and
enhance productivity moving on to the
first project of the day we have
unlocking efficiency of Java application
with griddle meet griddle The Versatile
build automation tool transcending
platforms and languages this project
helps you start on a journey of Java
application creation breaking it into
modular sub projects and more the main
aim of this project is to help you
master project initiation as a Java
application adaptly build it and
generate meticulous test reports you
will be well versed in running Java
applications crafting archives and
elevating your Java development Pros so
dive in to transform your coding skills
with grle the source code for this
project is linked in the description box
below moving on to project number two
unlock robust applications with Docker
for web servers Docker the go-to
container technology revolutionizes
services and app hosting by virtualizing
operating systems and crafting Nimble
containers this project focuses on
creating a universal base image and
helping you collaborate with fellow
developers in diverse production
Landscapes you will be dealing with
taking web apps foundations in Python
Ruby and Meo so Master this project and
you will yield docka file efficiency
like a pro slashing build times and
simplifying setups so say goodbye to
lendy docka file creation and resource
heavy downloads the source code for this
project is also mentioned in the
description box below so don't forget to
check out moving on to project number
three we have Master cicd pipelines
using Azure in this Azure project we
harness Azure devops to create efficient
cicd pipelines this project mainly
focuses on leveraging Azure devops
project we deploy applications
seamlessly across Azure services like
app service virtual machines and Azure
kuber service or AKs utiliz in azur
devop starter we set up asp.net sample
code explore pre-configured cicd
pipelines commit code changes and
initiate cicd workflows additionally we
fine tune monitoring with Azure
application insight for enhanced
performance insights the source code for
this project is also mentioned in the
description box below moving on to the
next project elevating Jenkins
communication the remoting project the
Jenkins remoting project is all about
enhancing Jenkins communication cap
capabilities it's an Endeavor to bolster
the Jenkins remoting Library creating a
robust communication layer this project
incorporates a spectrum of features from
TCP protocols to efficient data
streaming and procedure calls as a part
of this project you will start on the
exciting journey of making Jenkins
remoting compatible with bus
Technologies like active mq and rabbit
mq to succeed in this project a strong
grasp of networking fundamentals Java
and message cues is your arson d and
join us in elevating the way Jenkins
communicates with the world check out
the link mentioned in the description
box below for the source code moving on
to project number five automated web
application deployment with AWS your CD
pipeline project in this project you
will create a seamless continuous
delivery pipeline for a compact web
application your journey begins with the
source code management through a Version
Control System next discover the art of
configuring a CED pipeline enabling
automatic web application deployment
whenever your source code under goes
changes embracing the power of giup AWS
elastic bean stock AWS code buil and AWS
code pipeline this project is your
gateway to streamline efficient software
delivery the source code for this
project is linked in the description box
below moving on to the next project
containerized web app deployment on gke
scaling with Docker this project will
help you discover the power of
containerization with this project you
will learn how to package a web
application as a Docker container image
and deploy it on a Google kubernetes
engine or gke cluster you can watch your
app scale effortlessly to meet user
demands this Hands-On projects cover
packaging your web app into a Docker
image uploading it to artifact registry
creating a gke cluster managing
autoscaling exposing your app to the
world and seamlessly deploying newer
versions you get to unlock the world of
efficient scalable web app deployment on
gke the source code for this project is
linked in the description box below
moving on to project number seven
mastering Version Control with kit in a
world of software development mastering
a version control system is Paramount
version controlling enables you for code
tracking version comparison seamless
switching between versions and
collaborating among developers your
journey in this project will begin with
the fundamental art of saving code in a
VCS taking the scenic rout to set up a
repository you can then start on a quest
through code history and reving the
mysteries of Virgin navigation
navigating through branching a
deceptively intricate task is next on
your path by the end of this project you
will be fully equipped to conquer G one
of the most powerful version control
system tools in the developers Arsenal
the source code for this project is
mentioned in the description box below
moving on to the next project effortless
deployment running applications with
kubernetes the major focus of this
project is to help you harness a
straightforward web service that handles
user messages AK to a voicemail system
for leaving messages your mission you
ask you get to deploy this application
seamlessly with kubernetes then
dockerize it by mastering this
fundamental step you will unlock the
power to run your application in Docker
containers simplifying the deployment
process the source code for this project
is mentioned in the description box
below so don't forget to check it out
moving on to the project number nine
mastering terraform project structure
this project will help you maintain and
extend the efficiency of terraform
projects in everyday operations a well
structured approach is essential this
project unveils the art of organizing
terraform projects based on their
purpose and complexity so harness the
power of key terraform features
including variables data sources
provisionals and locals to craft a
streamline project structure by the end
your project will effortlessly deploy an
Ubuntu 20.04 server on digital ocean
configure an Apache web server and
seamlessly Point your domain to it level
up your tform game with proper project
structuring and practical application
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below for the sour code
moving on to the last project of the day
we have efficient selenium project
development and execution in the world
of test automation selenium projects
play a pivotal role they enable seamless
test execution report analysis and Bug
reporting this proficiency not only
accelerates product delivery but also
elevates client satis faction by the end
of this project you will Master the art
of building selenium projects whether
through a Java project or a maven
project showcasing your ability to
deliver high quality results efficiently
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below for the source
code through this project understand
what is devops devops is like a teamwork
approach for making computer programs
better and faster it combines the work
of software developers and operation
team the goal is to help them work
together and use tools that speed up the
process and make few mistakes
they also keep an eye on the programs
and fix problems early This Way
businesses can release programs faster
with few errors and everyone works
better together if you want to learn
more about this then check postgraduate
program in devops to understand from the
basics to advanced concepts this
post-graduate program in devops is
crafted in partnership with Caltech ctme
this comprehensive course allign your
expertise with industry benchmarks
experience are Innovative Blended
learning merging live online daop
certification sessions with immersive
labs for practical Mastery Advance your
career with Hands-On training that meets
industry demands all right now let's
move on to the first question of devops
interview question which is what do you
know about devops so think of a devops
like teamwork in the IT world it's
become really important because it helps
teams work together smoothly to make
computer programs faster and with fewer
mistakes imagine a soccer team every
everyone works together to win the game
devops is similar it's when computer
developers and operations people team up
to make software better they start
working together from the beginning when
they plan what the software will be like
until they finish and put it out for
people to use this Teamwork Makes sure
things go well and the software works
great so this was about devops now
moving on to the second question which
is how is devops different from agile
methodology devops is like a teamwork
culture where the people who create the
software and the people who make it work
smoothly join forces this helps in
always improving and updating the
software without any big breaks agile is
a way of making softwares that's like
taking small steps towards instead of
big jumps it's about releasing small
parts of the software quickly and
getting feedback from the users this
helps in solving any issues or
differences between what users want and
what developers are making so you can
answer this question in this way all
right moving on to the third question
which is what are the ways in which a
build can be scheduled SL run in Jenkins
so as you can see there are four ways by
source code management commits second is
after the completion of other builds
third is schedule to run at a specified
time and fourth one is manual belt
requests so if the interviewer asks then
you can answer this ways in which a
build can be scheduled in Jenkins all
right now the fourth question is what
are the different phases in devops so
the various phases of devops life cycle
are as follows so as you can see first
is plan so initially there should be a
plan for the type of application that
needs to be developed getting a rough
picture of the development process is
always a good idea then code the
application is coded as per the end user
requirements then there is build build
the application by integrating various
codes formed in previous steps after
that there is test this is the most
crucial step of the application
development test the application and
rebuild if necessary then there is
integrate so multiple codes from
different programmers are integrated
into one after integrate there is deploy
so code is deployed into a cloud
environment for further usage it is
ensure that any new changes do not
affect the functioning of a high traffic
website after that there is operate so
operations are performed on the code if
required
then there is Monitor application
performance is monitored changes are
made to meet the end user requirements
so these all were the different phases
of devops and here we have explained
each one of these you can go through it
and if the interviewer have asked you
this question you can answer it in a
similar way all right now moving on to
the next question which is mention some
of the core benefits of devops so the
core benefits of devops are as follows
first of all we'll see technical
benefits first technical benefit of
devops is continuous software delivery
then second is less complex problems to
manage third is early detection and
faster correction of defects then here
comes the business benefits the first
benefit of devops that is business
benefit of devops is faster delivery of
features so it allows faster delivery of
features then there is stable operation
environment then third one is improved
communication and collaboration between
the teams so these were the business
benefits so here we have discussed both
technical benefits and business benefits
all right now the next question is how
will you approach a project that needs
to implement devops so here are the
simpler terms here's how we can bring
devops into a specific project using
these Steps step one would be first we
look at how things are currently done
and figure out where we can make them
better this makes about 2 to 3 weeks
then we can plan for what changes to
make then step two would be we create a
small test to show that our plan works
when everyone agrees with it we can
start making the real changes and put
the plan into action then third step
would be we are all set to actually use
devops we do things like keeping track
of different versions of our work
putting everything together testing it
and making it available to the users we
also watch How It's Working to make sure
everything goes smoothly by doing these
steps right the keeping track of changes
putting everything together testing and
watching how it's going we are all set
to use devops in our project so this is
how you can approach a project that
needs to implement in devops and this is
how you can answer this question all
right moving on to the question number
seven which is what is the difference
between continuous delivery and
continuous deployment all right so first
would be continuous delivery so it
ensures code can be safely deployed on
production whereas continuous deployment
here every change that passes the
automated test is deployed to production
automatically then in continuous
delivery it ensures business
applications and services functions as
expected whereas in continuous
deployment it makes software development
and the release process faster and more
robust in continuous delivery delivers
every change to a production like
environment through rigorous and
automated testing whereas in continuous
deployment there is no explicit approval
from a developer and requires a
developed culture of monitoring so these
were the three points that you can
highlight while differentiating between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment all right so this was the
question number seven now moving on to
the question number eight which is name
three security mechanisms of Jenkins
uses to authenticate users so here we
have to name three security mechanisms
first one would be genkins uses an
internal database to store user data and
credentials second is genkins can use
the lightweight directory access
protocol that is ldap server to
authenticate users third one is genkins
can be configured to employ the
authentication mechanism that the
deployed application server uses so
these were the three mechanisms that Jen
can uses to authenticate users all right
now moving on to the question number
nine which is how does continuous money
monitoring help you maintain the entire
architecture of the system so continuous
monitoring within devops involves the
ongoing identification detection and
reporting of any anomalies or security
risk across the entire system
infrastructure it guarantees the proper
functioning of services applications and
resources on servers by overseeing
server statuses it accesses the accuracy
of application operations this practice
also facilitates uninterrupted audits
transaction SC
and regulated surveillance so this was
about the question number nine that was
how does continuous monitoring help you
maintain the entire arure of the system
now moving on to the question number 10
which is what is the role of AWS in
devops so in the realm of devops AWS
assumes several rules first one would be
adaptable services so it offers
adaptable pre-configured Services
eliminating the necessity for software
installation or configuration second one
is designed for expansion whether
managing one STS or expanding to th000
AWS Services accommodate seamless
scalability then there is automated
operations AWS empowers task and process
automation freeing up valuable time for
inventing Pursuits the next one is
enhanced security AWS identity and
accesses management that is I am allows
precise user permissions and policy
establishment then the last one is
extensive partner Network so AWS Fosters
a vast partner Network that integrates
with and enhances its service offerings
so these were the role of awfs in the
realm of devops all right now moving on
to the question number 11 name three
important devops kpis the three
important kpis are as follows first one
is meantime to failure recovery this is
the average time taken to recover from a
failure second Ki is deployment
frequency the frequency in which the
deployment occurs is called deployment
frequency third one is percentage of
failed deployments the number of times
the deployment fails is called
percentage of failed deployments so
these were the three important devops
kpis this question can also be asked all
right moving on to question number 12
which is how is IAC implemented using
AWS so commence by discussing
traditional methods involving scripting
commands into files followed by testing
in isolated environments prior to
deployment M notice how this practice is
giving way to infrastructure as code IAC
comparable to code for various Services
IAC aided by AWS empowers developers to
craft accesses and manage infrastructure
components descriptively utilizing
formats like Json or yl this Fosters
streamlined development and expeditious
implementation of alterations in
infrastructure all right now moving on
to question number 13 which is describe
the branching strategies you have used
they'll ask you this question so to test
our knowledge the purpose of branching
and our experience of branching at a
past job this question is usually asked
so here we will discuss topics that can
help you answering this devops interview
question so release branching we can
clone the develop Branch to create a
release Branch once it has enough
functionality for a release this Branch
kicks off the next release cycle th no
new features can be contributed Beyond
this point the things that can be
contributed are documentation generation
bug fixing and other release related
tasks the release is merged into master
and given a version number once it is
ready to ship it should also be merged
back into the development branch which
may have evolved since the initial
release so this was the first one then
there is feature branching this
branching model maintains all
modifications for a specific feature
contained within a branch the branch
gets merged into into Master once the
feature has been completely tested and
approved by using test that are
automated then the third branching is
Task branching in this branching model
every task is implemented in its
respective Branch the task key is
mentioned in the branch name we need to
Simply look at the task key in the
branch name to discover which code
implements which tasks so these were the
branching strategies that you can say
that you have used or if you have really
used it otherwise you can say something
something else all right moving on to
question number 14 which is can you
explain the shift left to reduce failure
Concept in devops so shifting left
within the devops framework is a concept
aimed to enhance security for
performance and related aspects to
illustrate consider the entity of divos
processes currently security valuations
occur before the deployment stage by
employing the left ship approach we can
introduce security measures during the
earlier development phase denoted as the
left this integration spans a multiple
phases incensing pre-development and
testing not confined to development
alone this holistic integration is
likely to elevate security measures by
identifying vulnerabilities at initial
stage leading to a more fortified
overall process now moving on to the
question number 15 which is what is
blue/ te deployment pattern so this
approach involves seamless deployment
aimed at minimizing downtime it entails
shifting traffic from one instance to
another requiring the replacement of
outdating code and a new version to
integrate fresh code the updated version
resides in a green environment while the
older one remains in a blue environment
after modifying the existing version a
new instance is generated from the old
one to execute the updated instance
ensuring a smoother transition so the
main focus of this approach is smooth
deployment all right so this was
question number 15
now moving on to the question number 16
which is what is continuous testing so
continuous testing involves the
automated execution of tests within the
software delivery pipeline offerings
immediate insights into potential
business risk within the latest release
by seamlessly integrating testing into
every stage of the software developing
Li I repeat by seamlessly integrating
testing into the every stage of software
delivery life cycle continuous testing
minimizes issues during transition
phases and empowers development teams
and instant
feedback this approach accelerates
developer efficiency by obtaining the
need to rerun all test after each update
and project rebuild culminating in
notable gains in speed and productivity
so this was about continuous
testing now moving on to question number
17 what are the benefits of automation
testing so some some of the benefits of
automation testing includes first it
helps to save money and time second is
unattended execution can be easily done
third one is huge test matrices can be
easily tested the next one is parallel
execution is enabled then there is
reduced human generated errors which
results in improved accuracy and last
one is repeated test task execution is
supported so these are the benefits of
of automation
testing coming to question number 18
which is what is a Docker file used for
so a Docker file is used for creating
Docker images using the build command
with a Docker image any user can run the
code to create Docker containers once
Docker image is built it's uploaded in
Docker registry from the docker registry
users can get the docker image and build
new containers whenever they want so
this is what Docker file is used for
coming to question number 19 which is
what is the process for reverting a
commit that has already been pushed and
made public so there are two ways to do
that to revert a commit so first would
be remove or fix the bad file in a new
commit and push it to the remote
repository then commit it to the remote
repository using get commit minus M
commit
message again
get commit minus M commit message so
this is the first way then second is
create a new commit that undo all the
changes that were made in the bad commit
then use the command get rever commit ID
as you can see in the screen First
Command also and the second command also
the second command says get revert
commit ID commit ID you'll have to put
the commit ID all right so question
number 19 this was now moving on to the
last question which is question number
20 how do you find a list of files that
have been changed in a particular
comment so the answer would be the
command to get a list of files that have
been changed in a particular comit is
get diff tree minus r then there is
commit hash so this command as you can
see on the screen get diff3 minus r
commit hash you can put it then examples
also there like commit hash 87e
6735 F21 B so this is example as you can
see on the screen then there is minus r
flag instruct so the command to list
individual files and commit hash will
list all the files that were changed to
or added in that commit so there's
telling about the as we can see minus r
functionality minus r is a flag that
instructs the command to list individual
files and commit hash will list all the
files that were changed or added in that
comment so these are the top 20 devops
interview questions that you must
understand if you're planning to give a
devops interview so in this video we
have explored key Concepts methodologies
and best practices that are crucial in
fostering collaboration between
development and operations teams by
understanding the principles discussed
here you are well equipped to navigate
the dynamic landscape of devops and
drive successful software delivery and
now just a quick info for you if if you
want to upskill yourself master devop
skills and land your dream job or grow
in your career then you must explore
simply learn cohort of various devop
program simply learn offers various
certification and postgraduate program
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like
celtech and Google Cloud through our
courses you will gain knowledge and work
ready expertise in skills like devs
methodology deployment automation cicd
Pipeline and over a dozen others and
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in top TI product companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a doops
role as a fresher or moved onto a higher
paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a devops program
that fits your experience and areas of
Interest hi there I'm Samuel and I'm
here to walk you through some of the AWS
interview questions which we find are
important and our hope is that you would
use this material in your interview
preparation and be able to crack that
cloud interview and step into your dream
Cloud job by the way I'm an Cloud
technical architect trainer and an
interview panelist for cloud Network and
devops so as you progress in watching
you're going to see that these questions
are practical scenario based question
questions that tests the depth of the
knowledge of a person in a particular
AWS product or in a particular AWS
architecture so why wait let's move on
all right so in an interview you would
find yourself with a question that might
ask you define and explain the three
basic types of cloud services and the
AWS products that are built based on
them see here it's a very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously uh
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application these basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as Advanced Services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitor monitoring of and
for analytics so they're not considered
as Basics so when we talk about Basics
they are compute storage and networking
and the second part of the question says
explain some of the AWS products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is Lambda
autoscaling and light sale are also part
of compute services so the compute
domain it really helps us to run any
application and the compute service
helps us in managing the scaling and
deployment of an application again
Lambda is a compute service so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that's
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so a storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are S3
object storage Glacier for archiving EBS
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
EFS file share for the ec2 instance so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be Glacier and any object
files and any requirement for Block
storage can be met through elastic Block
store and S3 which is again an object
storage talking about uh networks it
it's just not important to answer the
question with the name of the services
and the name of the product it'll also
be good if you could go in depth and
explain how they can be used all right
so that actually proves you to be a
person knowledgeable enough in that
particular service or product so talking
about networking domain VPC networking
can't imagine networking without VPC in
in the cloud environment especially in
AWS Cloud environment and then we have
Route 53 for domain resolution or uh for
DNS and then we have cloudfront which is
an edge caching service that helps
customers get or customers to read their
application with low latency so
networking domain helps with some of the
following use cases it controls and
manages the connectivity of the AWS
services within our account and we can
also pick an IP address range if you're
a network engineer or if if you are
somebody who works in networks or are
planning to work in network you will
soon realize the importance of choosing
your own IP address for easy remembering
so having an option to have your own IP
address in the cloud own range of IP
address in the cloud it really helps
really really helps in Cloud networking
the other question that get asked would
be the difference between the
availability Zone and the region
actually the question generally gets
asked so to test how well you can
actually differentiate and also
correlate the availability Zone and the
region relationship right so a region is
a separate geographic area like the US
West one I mean which represents North
California or the AP South which
represents Mumbai so regions are a
separate geographic area on the contrary
availability Zone resides inside the
region you shouldn't stop there you
should go further and explain about
availability zones and availability
zones are isolated from each other and
some of the services will replicate
themselves within the availability zone
so availability Zone does replication
within them but regions they don't
generally do replication between them
the other question you could be asked is
uh what is Autos scaling what do we
achieve by Autos scaling so in short
autoscaling it helps us to automatically
provision and launch new inst senses
Whenever there is an demand it not only
helps us meeting the increasing demand
it also helps in reducing the resource
usage when there is low demand so Autos
scaling also allows us to decrease the
resources or resource capacity as per
the need of that particular AR now this
helps business in not worrying about
putting more effort in managing or
continuously monitoring the to see if
they have the needed resource or not
because autoscaling is going to handle
it for us so business does not need to
worry about it and Autos scaling is one
big reason why people would want to go
and pick a cloud service especially an
AWS service the ability to increase and
Shrink based on the need of that art
that's how powerful is Autos scaling the
other question you could get asked is
what's Doo targeting in Cloud front now
we know that cloud front is caching and
it caches content globally in the Amazon
caching service globalwide the whole
point is to provide users worldwide
access to the data from a very nearest
server possible that's the whole point
in using or going for cloud front then
what do you mean by geot targeting geot
targeting is showing customer and
specific content based on language we
can customize the content based on
what's popular in in that place we can
actually customize the content the URL
is the same but we could actually change
the content a little bit not the whole
content otherwise it would be dynamic
but we can change the content a little
bit a specific a file or a picture or a
particular Link in a website and show
customized content to users who will be
in different parts of the globe so how
does it happen cloudfront will detect
the country where the viewers are
located and it will forward the country
code to the origin server and once the
origin server gets the specialized or
specific country code it will change the
content and it'll send to the caching
server and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a Content
which is personalized for them for the
country they are in the other question
you could get asked is the steps
involved in using cloud formation or
creating a cloud formation or backing up
an environment with an cloud formation
template we all know that if there is a
template we can simply run it and it
Provisions the environment but there is
a lot more going into it so the first
step in moving towards infrastructure as
a code is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports Json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an S3 bucket S3 bucket
serves as the Repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the S3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloud formation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which this service let's say Service A
and B service B is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision resource B what happens if we
inverse the order if he inverse the
order resource B first gets provision
and because it does not have dependency
chanes that the Cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly something is
not healthy it would roll back chances
that the environment provisioning will
roll back so to avoid that cloud
formation first Provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent on
that's depended by another service so it
Provisions those service first and then
Provisions the services that has
dependencies and if you are being hired
for a devops or you know if if the
interviewer wanted to test your skill on
systems side this definitely would be a
question in his list how do you upgrade
or downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now everybody's moving towards
zero downtime or near zero down time all
of them want their application to be
highly available so the question would
be how do you actually upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now we all know that I can
upgrade an ec2 instance to a better ec2
instance by changing the uh instance
type stopping and starting but stopping
and starting is going to cause a down
time right so that's you shouldn't be
answering or you shouldn't be thinking
in those terms because that's a wrong
answer specifically the interviewer
wants to know how do you upgrade a
system with zero downtime so upgrading
system with zero downtime it includes
launching another system parall with the
bigger ec2 instance typ type with a
bigger capacity and install all that's
needed if you are going to use an Ami of
the old machine well and good you don't
have to go through installing all the
updates and installing all the
application from the Ami once you've
launched it in a bigger instance locally
test the application to see if it is
working don't put it on production yet
working and if the application works we
can actually swap if your server is
behind and behind uh 53 let's say all
that you could do is go to R 53 update
the uh information with the new IP
address new IP address of the new server
and that's going to send traffic to the
new server now so the cutover is handled
or if you're using static IP you can
actually remove the static IP from the
old machine and assign it to the new
machine that's one way of doing it or if
you are using elastic Nick card you can
actually remove the Nick card from the
old machine and attach the card to the
new machine so that way we would get
near zero downtime if you're hired for
an architect level you should be
worrying about cost as well along with
the technology and this question would
test how well you manage cost so what
are the tools and techniques we can use
in AWS to identify and correct identify
and know that we are paying the correct
amount for the resources that we are
using or how do you get a visibility of
your AWS resources running one way is to
check the building there's a place where
you can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid Service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost Management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used services so looking at it
you can get it all right so I'm using
lot of storage I'm using lot of ec2 why
is storage high you can go ahead and try
to justify that and you will find if you
are storing things that shouldn't be
storing and then clean it up why is
compute capacity so high why is data
transfer so high so if you start
thinking in those levels you'll be able
to dig in and clean up unnecessary and
be able to save your bill and there are
cost Explorer services available which
will help you to view your usage pattern
or view your spending for the past 30
months or so and it will also forecast
for the next 3 months now how much will
you be using if your pattern is like
this so that will actually help and will
give you a visibility on how much you
have spent how much you will be spending
if the trend continues budgets are
another excellent way to control cost
you can actually set a budget all right
this is how much I am willing to spend
for this application for this team or
for this month for this particular
resource so you you can actually put a
budget Mark and anytime it exceeds
anytime it's nearing you would get an
alarm saying that well we're about to
reach the allocated budget amount stuff
like that that way you can go back and
know and you know that how much the bill
is going to be for that month or you can
take steps to control bill amount for
that particular month so aw's budget is
another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags helps in
identifying which team or which resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of looking at the bill as one
list with no specifications into it and
looking at it as an expenditure list you
can actually break it down and tag the
expenditure to the teams with cost
allocation taxs the dev team has spent
so much the uh production team has spent
so much the training team has spent more
than the dev and the production team why
is that you'll be able to you know think
in those levels only if you have cost
allocation tags now cost allocation tags
are nothing but the tags that you would
put when you create error source so for
Production Services you would put as a
production tag you would create a
production tag and you would associate
that resources to it and at a later
point when you actually pull up your
bill that's going to show a detailed a
list of this is the owner this is the
group and this is how much they have
used in the last month and you can move
forward with your investigation and
encourage or stop users using more
services with the cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing AWS resource other than
the console console is GUI right so in
other words other than GUI how would you
use the AWS resource and how familiar
are you with those tools and
Technologies the other tools that are
available that we can leverage and
access the AWS resource are of course
puty you can configure puty to access
the AWS resources like log to an ec2
instance and ec2 instance does not
always have to be logged in through the
console you could use puty to log into
an ec2 instance and like the jump box
like the proxy machine and like the
Gateway machine and from there you can
actually access the rest of the
resources so this is an alternative to
the console and of course we have the aw
CLI in any of the Linux machines
or Windows machines we can install so
that's 2 3 and 4 we can install AWS CLI
for Linux Windows also for Mac so we can
install them and from there from your
local machine we can access run AWS
commands and access provision monitor
the AWS resources the other ones are we
can access the uh AWS resource
programmatically using AWS SDK and
Eclipse so these are bunch of options we
have to use the AWS resource other than
the console if you're interviewed in a
company or by a company that focuses
more on security and want to use AWS
native services for their security then
you would come across this question what
services can be used to create a
centralized logging solution the basic
Services we could use are cloudwatch
logs store them in S3 and then use
elastic search to visualize them and use
kin is to move the data from S3 to
elastic search right so log management
it actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs instead of
logging into an instance or instead of
logging into the environment and
checking the resources physically I can
come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system will scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
Cloud watch pushes it to S3 Kinesis
pushes the data from S3 to elastic
search and uh I can do a Time based
filter and I would get an a fair
understanding of what was going on in
the environment for the past one or or
whatever the time window that I wanted
to look at so it helps in getting a good
understanding of the infrastructure as a
whole all the logs are getting saved in
one place so all the infrastructure logs
are getting saved in one place so it's
easy for me to look at it in an
infrastructure perspective so we know
the services that can be used and here
are some of the services and how they
actually connect to each other it could
be logs that belongs to One account it
could be logs that belongs to multiple
accounts doesn't matter you know those
three services are going to work fairly
good and they going to inject or they
going to like suck logs from the other
accounts put it in one place and help us
to monitor so as you see you have Cloud
watch here that actually tracks the
metrics you can also use cloud trail if
you want to log API calls as well push
them in an S3 bucket so there are
different types of log flow logs are
getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same VPC from a different VPC
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elastic search using the kibana
client so step one is to deploy the ECS
cluster step two is to restrict access
to the ECS cluster because it's valid
data you don't want anybody to put their
hands and access their data so restic
access to the ECS dashboard and we could
use Lambda also to push the uh data from
cloud watch to the elastic search domain
and then kibana is actually the
graphical tool that helps us to
visualize the logs instead of looking at
log as just statements or in a bunch of
characters a bunch of files kibana helps
us to analyze the logs in a graphical or
a chart or a bar diagram format again in
an interview the interviewer is more
concerned about testing your knowledge
on AW security products especially on
the logging monitoring event management
or Incident Management then you could
have a question like this what are the
native AWS security logging capabilities
now most of the Services have their own
logging in them like have their own
loging like S3 S3 has its own login and
cloudfront has its own loging DS has its
own loging VPC has its own loging in
additional there are account level
logins like a cloud trail and AWS config
services so there are variety of logging
options available in the AWS like cloud
trail config Cloud front red shift
logging RDS logging VPC flow logs S3
object object logging S3 access logging
stuff like that so we're going to look
at two servers in specific cloud trail
now this cloud trail the very first
product in that picture we just saw the
cloud trail provides an very high level
history of the API calls for all the
account and with that we can actually
perform a very good security analysis a
security analysis of our account and
these logs are actually delivered to you
can configure it they can be delivered
to S3 for long time archival and based
on a particular event it can also send
an email notification to us saying hey
just got this error thought I'll let you
know stuff like that the other one is
config service now config service helps
us to understand the configuration
changes that happened in our environment
and we can also set up notifications
based on the configuration changes so it
records the cumulative changes that are
made in a a short period of time so if
you want to go through the lifetime of a
particular resource what are the things
that happened what are the things that
went through they can be looked at using
AWS config all right the other question
you could get asked is if uh you know
your role includes taking care of cloud
security as well then the other question
you could get asked is the native
services that Amazon provides to
mitigate dos which is denial of service
now not companies would go with Amazon
native services but there are some
companies which want to stick with
Amazon native Services just to save them
from the headache of managing the other
softwares or bringing in another tool a
third party tool into managing DS they
simply want to stick with Amazon
proprietary Amazon native services and a
lot of companies are using Amazon
service to prevent dos denial of service
now denial of service is if you already
know what denial of services well and
good if you do not know then let's know
it now denial of service is a user
trying to or maliciously making attempt
to access a website or an application
the user would actually create multiple
sessions and he would occupy all the
sessions and he would not let legimate
users access the servers so he's in turn
denying the service for the user a quick
uh picture review of what denial of
service is now look at it these users
instead of making one connection they
are making multiple connections and
there are cheap software programs
available that would actually trigger
connections from different computers in
the internet with different Mac
addresses so everything kind of looks
legimate for the uh server and it would
accept those connections and it would
keep the sessions open the actual users
won't be able to use them so that's
denying the service for the actual users
denial of service all right right and
distributed denial of service is uh
generating a tax from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to prevent the denial of service
attacks in AWS is cloud shield and web
access firewall aw SF now they are the
major ones they are designed to mitigate
a denial of service if your website is
often bothered by denial of service then
we should be using aw Shield or AWS WF
and there are a couple of other tools
that also does when I say that also does
denial of services not their primary job
but you could use them for denial of
service route 53's purpose is to provide
DNS cloudfront is to provide caching
elastic load balancer elb's work is to
provide load balancing VPC is to create
an secure a virtual private environment
but they also support mitigating denial
of service but not not to the extent you
would get in AWS shield and AWS wav so
AWS shield and WF are the primary ones
but the rest can also be used to
mitigate distributed denial of service
the other tricky question is uh this
actually will test your familiarity with
the region and the services available in
the region so when you're trying to
provision a service in a particular
region you're not seeing the service in
that region how do we go about fixing it
or how do we go about using the service
in the cloud it's a tricky question and
if you have not gone through such
situation you can totally blow it away
you really need to have a good
understanding on regions the services
available in those regions and what if a
particular servic is not available how
to go about doing it the answer is not
all services are available in all
regions anytime Amazon announces a new
service they don't immediately publish
them on all regions they start small and
as in when the the traffic increases as
in when it becomes more likable to the
customers they actually move the service
to different regions so as you see in
this picture within America North
Virginia has more services compared to
Ohio or Compared to North California So
within North America itself North
Virginia is the preferred one so
similarly there are preferred regions
within Europe middle easn Africa and
preferred regions within Asia Pacific so
anytime you don't see a service in a
particular region chances that the
service is not available in that region
yet we got to check the documentation
and find the nearest region that offers
that service and start using the service
from that region now you might think
well if I'm looking for a service in
Asia let's say in Mumbai and if it is
not available why not simply switch to
North Virginia and start using it you
could but you know that's going to add
more latency to your application so
that's why we need to check for
application which is check for region
which is very near to the place where
you want to serve your customers and
find nearest region instead of always
going back to North Virginia and
deploying an application in North
Virginia again there's a place there's a
link in aws.com that you can go and look
for services available in different
region and that's exactly what you're
seeing here and if your service is not
available in a particular region switch
to the other region that provides your
service the nearest region that provides
that service and start using service
from there with the uh coming up of
cloud a lot of companies have turned
down their monitoring team instead they
want to go with the monitorings that
cloud provides you know nobody wants to
or at least many people don't want to go
through the hassle of at least new
startups and new companies that are
thinking of having a monitoring
environment now they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage aw
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor to
website I mean how do you set up a
Monitor to Monitor the uh website
metrics in real time in AWS the simple
way anytime you have a question about U
monitoring Cloud watch should strike
your mind because Cloud watch is meant
for monitoring is meant for collecting
metrics is meant for providing graphical
representation of uh what's going on in
a particular Network at a particular
point of time so Cloud watch Cloud watch
helps us to monitor applications and
using cloudwatch we can monitor the
state changes not only the state changes
the autoscaling life cycle events
anytime there there are more services
added there is a reduction in the number
of servers because of less usage and
very informative messages can be
received through cloudwatch any Cloud
watch can now support scheduled events
if you want to schedule anything
cloudwatch has an event that would
schedule an action right schedule a
Trigger Time based not incident based
you know anything happening and then you
get an action happening that's incident
based on the other hand you can simply
schedule few things on time based so
that's possible with Cloud watch So This
Cloud watch integrates very well with a
lot of other services like notifications
for notifying uh the user or for
notifying the administrator about it and
it can integrate well with Lambda so to
trigger an action anytime you're
designing an auto healing environment
this cloudwatch can actually monitor and
send an email if we are integrating it
with SNS simple notification service or
this Cloud watch can monitor and uh
based on what's Happening it can trigger
an event in Lambda and that would in
turn run a function till the uh
environment comes back to normal so
cloudwatch integrates well with a lot of
other aw Services all right so
cloudwatch has uh three statuses green
when everything is going good yellow
when the service is degraded and red
when the service is not available green
is good so we don't have to do anything
about it but anytime there's an lello
the picture that we're looking at it's
actually calling an Lambda function to
debug the application and to fix it and
anytime there's a red alert it
immediately notifies the um owner of the
application about well the service is
down and here is the report that I have
here is the metrics that I've collected
about the service stuff like that if the
job role requires you to manage the
servers as well there are certain job
roles which are on the system side there
are certain job roles which is
development plus system side now you're
responsible for the application and the
server as well so if that's the case you
might be tested with some basic
questions like the different types of
virtualization in AWS and what are the
difference between them all right the
three major types of virtualization are
hvm which is Hardware virtual machine
the other one is PV par virtualization
and the third one is PV on hbm par
virtualization on Hardware virtual
module all right the difference between
them or actually describing them is
actually the difference between them hvm
it's actually a fully virtualized
Hardware you know the whole Hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
uh separate from each other and these
VMS are booted by executing Master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about par virtualization parag grub
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the uh PV Amis and when we
talk about PV on hvm it's it's actually
the the marriage between hvm and PV and
this par virtualization on hvm in other
words PV on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host another good
question is name some of the services
that are not region specific now you've
been thought that all services are
within a region and some services are
within an availability zone for example
ec2 is within an availability Zone EBS
is within an availability Zone S3 is
region specific Dynamo DB is region
specific stuff like that VPC is both
availability and a region specific
meaning you know subnets are
availability Zone specific and vpc's
region specific stuff like that so you
might have thought you might have
learned in that combination but there
could be some tricky questions that
tests you how well you have understood
the region non region and availability
non-availability
Services I should say there are services
that are not region specific that would
be IM am so we can't have IM am for
every availability Zone and for every
region which means you know users will
have to use one username and password
for one region and anytime they switch
to another region they will have to use
another username and password that
that's more work and that's not a good
design as well authentication has to be
Global so IM is a global Service and
which means it's not Regional specific
on the other hand Route 53 is again a
regional specific so we can't have Route
53 for every region Route 53 is not a
region specific service it's a global
Service and it's one application users
access from everywhere or from every
part of the world so we can't have one
URL or one DNS name for each region if
your application is a global application
and then web application firewall works
well with cloudfront and Cloud front is
a region based service so the web
application firewall it's not region
specific service it's a global Service
and Cloud front is again a global
Service though you can uh you know cash
content on a continent and country basis
it's still considered global Service all
right it's not bound to any region so
when you activate cloudfront you're
activating it away from region or
availability zone so when you're
activating a web application firewall
because it's not a region specific
service you're activating it away from
availability Zone and regions so a quick
recap I am users groups roles and
accounts they are Global Services they
can be used globally R 53 services are
offered at Edge locations and they are
Global as well web application firewall
a service that protects our web
application from common web exploits
they are global Service as well
cloudfront cloudfront is global content
deliv delivery Network CDN and they are
offered at Edge locations which are a
global Service in other words non region
specific service or Beyond region
service all right this is another good
question as well in the project that you
are being interviewed if they really
want to secure their environment using
natat or if they are already securing
their environment using natat by any of
these two methods like Nat Gateway or
natat instances you can expect this
question what are the difference between
a Nat Gateway and Nat instances now they
both serve the same thing all right
they're not two different Services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them right
on a high level they both achieve
providing nting for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about the availability of it Nat Gateway
is a managed service by Amazon whereas
Nat instance is managed by us now I'm
talking about the third Point
maintenance here Nat Gateway is managed
by Amazon Nat instance is managed by us
and availability of n Gateway is very
high and availability of nat instance is
less compared to the N Gateway because
it's managed by us you know it's on an
E2 instance which could actually fail
and if it fails we'll have to relaunch
it but if it is not Gateway if something
happens to that service Amazon would
take care of reprovision it and talking
about bandwidth it can burst up to 75
gigabits now traffic through the N
Gateway can burst up to 75 gbits but for
Nat instance it actually depends on the
server that we launch and if we are
launching a T2 micro it barely gets any
bandwidth so there's a difference there
and the performance because it's highly
available because of the bigger pipe 75
gbits the performance of the N Gateway
is very high but the performance of the
natat instance is going to be average
again it depends on the size of the
natat instance that we pick and billing
a billing for Nat Gateway is the number
of gateways that we provision and the
duration for which we use the NAT
Gateway but billing for Nat instance is
number of instance and the type of
instance that we use of course number of
instance duration and the type of
instance that we use Security in N
Gateway cannot be uh assigned meaning it
already comes with full packed security
but in that instance security is a bit
customizable I can go and change the
security because it's a server managed
by me or managed by us I can always
change the security well allow this
allow don't allow this stuff like that
size and load of the N Gateway is
uniform but the size and the load of the
U that instance changes as per a that
Gateway is a fixed product but not
instance can be small instance can be a
big instance so the size and the load
through it varies right the other
question you could get asked is what are
the difference between stopping and
terminating an ec2 instance now you will
be able to answer only if you have
worked on environments where you have
your instance stopped and where you have
your instance terminated if you have
only used lab and are attending the
interview chances are that you might
your ways lost when answering this
question it might look like both are the
same well stopping and terminating both
are the same but there is a difference
in it so when you stop an instance it
actually performs a normal shutdown on
the instance and it simply moves the
instance to the stopped state but when
you actually terminate the instance the
instance is mooved to this stop State
the EVS volumes that are attached to it
are deleted and removed and we'll never
be able to recover them again so that's
a big difference between stopping and
terminating an instance if you're
thinking of using the instance again
along with the data in it you should
only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever if you are
being interviewed for an architect level
position or a junior architect level
position or even an Cloud consultant
level position or even in an engineering
position this is a very common question
that get asked what are the different
types of E2 instances based on their
cost or based on how we pay them right
they're all computer capacity for
example the different types are on
demand instances spot instances and
reserved instances it kind of looks the
same they all provide the compute
capacity they all provide the same type
of Hardwares for us but if you're
looking at Cost saving or optimizing
cost in our environment we got to be
very careful about which one are we
picking now we might think that well
I'll go with on demand instance because
I pay on a per hour basis which is cheap
you know I can use them anytime I want
and anytime I don't want I can simply
get rid of it by terminating it you're
right but if the requirement is to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for 3 years then
you'll be wasting a lot of money buying
on demand instances you'll be wasting a
lot of money paying on an hourly basis
instead we should be going for reserved
instance where we can reserve the
capacity for the complete one year or
complete 3 years and save huge amount in
buying reserved instances all right so
underman is cheap to start with if
you're only planning to use it for a
short while but if you're planning to
run it for a long while then we should
be going for reserved instance that is
what is cost efficient so spot instance
is cheaper than OnDemand instance and
there are different use cases for spot
instance as well so let's look at one
after the other the on demand instance
the on demand instance is purchased at
fixed rate per hour this is very
shortterm and irregular workloads and
for testing for development on demand
instance is a very good use case we
shouldn't be using on demand for
production spot instance spot instance
allows users to purchase ec2 at a
reduced price and anytime we have more
instances we can always go and sell it
in spot instances I'm referring to
anytime we have more reserved instances
we can always sell them in spot instance
uh catalog and the way we buy Spot
instance is we actually put a budget
this is how much I'm willing to pay
right would you be able to give service
within this cost so anytime the price
comes down and meets the cost that we
have put in we be assigned an instance
and anytime the price shoots up the
instance will be taken away from us but
in case of on demand instances we have
bought that instance for that particular
R and it stays with us but with spot
instances it varies based on the price
if you meet the price you get the
instance if you don't meet the price
goes away to somebody else and a spot
instance availability is actually based
on supply and demand in the market
there's no guarantee that you will get
spot instance at all time all right so
that's a caveat there you should be
familiar with that's a caveat there you
should be aware when you are proposing
somebody that we can go for spot
instance and save money it's not always
going to be available if you want your
spot in stance to be available to you
then we need to carefully watch the
history of of the price of the spot
instance now how much was it last month
then how much was it how much is it this
month so how can I code or how much can
I code stuff like that so you got to
look at those history before you propose
somebody that well we're going to save
money using spot instance on the other
hand reserved instance provide cost
savings for the company or we can opt
for reserved instances for you know one
year or three years there are actually
three types of reserved instances light
medium and heavy reserved instances they
are based on the amount that we would be
paying and cost benefit also depends
with reserved instance the cost benefit
also depends based on are we doing all
upfront or no upfront or partial payment
then split the rest as monthly payments
so there are many purchase options
available but overall if you're looking
at using an application for the next 1
year and 3 years you should not be going
for on demand instance you should be
going for reserved instance and that's
what gives you the cost benefit and in
an AWS interview sometimes you might be
asked you know how you interact with the
AWS environment are you using CLI are
you using console and depending on your
answer whether console or CLI the
panelist put a score okay this person is
CLI specific this person is console
specific or this person has used AWS
environment through the SDK stuff like
that so this question test whether you
are a CLI person or an console person
and the question goes like this how do
you set up SSH agent forwarding so that
you do not have to copy the key every
time you log in if you have used Puri
anytime if you want to log into to an
ec2 instance you will have to put the IP
and the port number along with that you
will have to map or we will have to map
the key in the Puri and this has to be
done every time that's what we would
have done in our lab environments right
but in production environment using the
same key or mapping the same key again
and again every time it's actually an
hazle it's considered as a blocker so
you might want to Cache it you might
want to permanently add it in your puty
session so you can immediately log in
and start using it so here in the place
where you would actually map the private
key there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your SSH to
your puty instance so we can enable SSH
agent forwarding uh that will actually
bind our key to the SSH and next time
when we try to log in we don't have to
always go through mapping the key and
trying to log in all right this question
what are Solaris and ax operating
systems are they available with AWS that
question generally gets asked to test
how familiar are you with the uh Amis
available how familiar are you with ec2
how familiar are you with the E2
Hardwares available that basically test
that now the first question or the first
thought that comes to your mind is well
everything is available with AWS I've
seen Windows I've seen Ubuntu I've seen
Red Hat I've seen Amazon uh Amis and if
I don't see my operating system there I
can always go to Marketplace and try
them if I don't find in Marketplace I
can always go to community and try them
so there lot of Amis available there lot
of operating systems available I will be
able to find Solaris and ax but that's
not the case solar s and ax are not
available with AWS that's because
Solaris uses a different I me Solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public Cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well and they run on
power CPU and not on Intel and as of now
Amazon does not provide Power machines
this should not be confused with the HPC
which is high performance Computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different Hardwares different
CPU itself that the cloud providers did
do not provide yet
here we wrap up our Cloud devops course
video if you have any questions or
queries regarding any Concept in this
video feel free to edit in the comment
section and our experts will be happy to
help you do subscribe to Simply learn to
stay updated with new technology Trends
thanks for watching staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here